THIS HEARING OF THE BUDGET
SENATE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE ON
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
SOMEWHAT THANK EVERYONE FOR
BEING HERE -- THE THIS BASIC
THIS HEARING WILL FOCUS ON
OVERSIGHT OF THE DEPARTMENT
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES AND VARIOUS
AUTOMATION PROJECTS UNDER
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES AND
THE OFFICE OF SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION -- THERE IS -- NO
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR TODAY ALL
ITEMS ARE UP FOR DISCUSSION AND
WE'RE NOT TAKING ANY VOTES TODAY --
BUT OBVIOUSLY THE THIS -- WILL
BE HEARING ABOUT THESE VARIOUS
ITEMS AND THEN AFTER THE END OF
EACH -- MAJORS SEGMENT WE WILL
BE TAKING OUT PUBLIC COMMENT AND
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT -- WE ASK IF
YOU CAN TRY.
TO KEEPS YOUR COMMENT TO A
MINUTE OF COURSE WE ALWAYS HAPPY
TO ACCEPT -- WRITTEN SUBMISSIONS ---TO ARE SAID TO THE BUDGET STAFF --
AS WELL SO -- WE DON'T CERTAINLY
WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU AND SO
WITH THAT -- ONE WELCOME
EVERYONE HERE WHEN IT BEGIN WITH --
I AM FORTY SEVEN HUNDRED
APARTMENT OF COMMITTEE SERVICES
DEVELOPMENT AND WILL COME AND WE
CAN ALSO COME UP THE WELCOME UP
THE LA -- AND FINANCE.
FOLKS AS WELL [inaudible]
Q..
AND IF EVERYONE CAN INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES FOR THE RECORD
STARTING WITH THE AGENCY.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR PAN AND UP
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE LYNN
A STOUT FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT ON THE DIRECTOR OKAY
THANK YOU WELCOME. TO SOMEONE
BELIEVE THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR I THANK YOU ALEJO.
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WELCOME FINANCE.
PLEASE FOR DROUGHT APARTMENT
FINANCE.
AND CHECK A POOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE EXCELLENT THANK YOU. FOR
IT SO -- I THINK JUST THREE
DEPARTMENT IT'S A IT'S JUST AN
OVERVIEW -- THIS IS THE JUSTIN
OVER YOU VIEW YOU DO A LOT OF
VERY IMPORTANT WORK WE DO HAVE A
FAIRLY -- A GOOD WRITE UP ABOUT
IT BUT IF YOU CAN HIT SERVE THE
HIGHLIGHTS OF WHAT YOU'RE
DEPARTMENTS DOING AND WHAT
YOU'RE ACCOMPLISHING AND WHAT
YOU HOPE PLANNED ACCOMPLISH NEXT
YEAR [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE DEPARTMENT IS PRIMARILY
FEDERALLY FUNDED WITH SOME
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUNDING
AND ALL OF THE DEPARTMENTS
FUNDING WHICH IS VERY IMPORTANT
PROVIDE SERVICES AND SUPPORT TO
THOSE LIVING IN POVERTY AND
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
AS NOTED IN THE AGENDA FEDERAL
FUNDING HAS REMAINED RELATIVELY
CONSISTENT.
THERE HAS BEEN AN INCREASE IN
THE FUNDING FOR THE LOW INCOME
HOME ENERGY ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED TWO HUNDRED
AND FOUR MILLION FOR FEDERAL
FISCAL YEAR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WHICH WAS AN INCREASE
OF THIRTEEN POINT TWO FROM LAST
YEAR AND THE ACTUAL THIRTY THREE
AND A HALF INCREASE FROM FEDERAL
FISCAL YEAR. SEVENTEEN THE
COMMUNITY SERVICES BLOCK GRANTS
FOR FEDERAL FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN
IS A POSSIBLY SIXTY THREE AND A
HALF MILLION AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF ENERGY WEATHERIZATION
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. SEVEN AND
HALF MILLION.
THE PRESIDENT'S PROPOSED TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET RECOMMENDS
ELIMINATING ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS.
HOWEVER HISTORICALLY CONGRESS
HAS BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THESE FEDERAL PROGRAMS SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN CST HAS
BEEN APPROPRIATED TWO HUNDRED
AND TWO MILLION FROM THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND.
FOR OUR LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM. TEN AND
A HALF MILLION OF THE TOTAL WILL
BE AWARDED IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS
FOR OUR FARM WORKER HOUSING
COMPONENT.
THE BALANCE HAS EITHER BEEN
EXPENDED OR A WORD.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
INCLUDES TEN MILLION FOR THE LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM
HOW THESE FUNDS WILL BE USED
WILL DEPEND ON THE FINAL
APPROPRIATION.
AND ANY PRIORITIES THAT MAY BE
IDENTIFIED THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
THE COMMUNITY SERVICES BLOCK
GRANT IS UNIQUE IN THAT IT
ALLOWS LOCAL AGENCIES TO PROVIDE
A RANGE OF SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
TO HELP LOW INCOME PEOPLE ATTAIN
ECONOMIC STABILITY.
THE SERVICES ARE BASED ON LOW
INCOME.
ON LOCAL NEEDS OF A AND INCLUDE
WHICH IS REALLY IMPORTANT THE
LOW INCOME COMMUNITY DIRECTLY
ACTUALLY SITTING IN ON PART OF
THE BOARDS FOR THE COMMUNITY
ACTION AGENCIES.
ABOUT TWO MILLION LOW INCOME.
CALIFORNIANS ARE SERVED ANNUALLY.
THE LOW INCOME HOME ENERGY
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM HELPS LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS REDUCE THEIR
HOME ENERGY COSTS BY PROVIDING
PAYMENT ASSISTANCE CRISIS
ASSISTANCE TO PREVENT UTILITY
DISCONNECTION.
AND WHETHER IS ASIAN SERVICES
THAT HELP REDUCE ENERGY COSTS
AND IMPROVE HOUSEHOLD ENERGY
EFFICIENCY WHILE IMPROVING THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF OCCUPANTS.
LAST YEAR LOCAL AGENCIES
ASSISTED OVER TWO HUNDRED AND
TEN THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS PAY
THEIR UTILITY BILLS INCLUDING
MORE THAN NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND
AND CRISIS SERVICES.
AND IMPROVED ENERGY EFFICIENCY
OF TWELFTH OVER TWELVE THOUSAND
HOMES.
MANY OF THESE HOUSEHOLDS INCLUDE
ELDERLY DISABLED AND OR CHILDREN
UNDER.
FIVE THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUNDED LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM PROVIDES
ENERGY EFFICIENCY UPGRADES AND
SOLAR PHOTOVOLTAIC SYSTEMS TO
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
THE PRIMARY GOAL OF THE PROGRAM
IS TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS BUT JUST AS
IMPORTANTLY.
THE LOW INCOME WATHERIZATION
PROGRAM REDUCES ENERGY EXPENSES
FOR LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
FREEING UP LIMITED DISPOSABLE
INCOME FOR OTHER CRITICAL
EXPENSES.
THIS IS THE ONLY PROGRAM OF ITS
KIND IN CALIFORNIA PROVIDING LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WITH SOLAR
PHOTOVOLTAIC AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY UPGRADES AT NO COST.
THERE'S A TOTAL OF FOUR
COMPONENTS TO THE LOW.
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM
THE FIRST IS OUR SINGLE FAMILY
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND SOLAR
PEAVEY.
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS FIFTY
SEVEN MILLION HAS BEEN ALLOCATED
AND OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS SERVED THROUGH ENERGY
EFFICIENCY UPGRADES.
AND OVER FORTY TWO HUNDRED
HOUSEHOLDS HAVE RECEIVED SOLAR
PEAVEY SYSTEMS.
THE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
RECEIVING THE SERVICES ARE MADE
UPOF FIVE REGIONS IN THE STATE.
AND FOR THE FIVE REGIONS FUNDING
HAS BEEN EXPENDED AND THE FIFTH
REGION WILL BE FULLY EXPENDED BY
THE END OF THIS MONTH.
CONTINUATION OF THE SINGLE
FAMILY AND SOLAR PEAVEY SERVICES
IN DISADVANTAGED CAN UNITIES IS
DEPENDENT UPON FUTURE FUNDING.
THE SECOND COMPONENT OF THE
PROGRAM PROVIDES TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND INCENTIVES FOR
THE INSTALLATION OF ENERGY
EFFICIENCY MEASURES AND SOLAR
PEAVEY AND LOW INCOME MULTI
FAMILY DWELLINGS.
AND PROVIDES A DIRECT BENEFIT TO
LOW INCOME TENANTS WHILE ALSO
HELPING TO PRESERVE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
A TOTAL OF FIFTY FOUR MILLION
HAS BEEN ALLOCATED. TO DATE
FIFTY SEVEN HUNDRED HOUSEHOLDS
HAVE BEEN SERVED AND THE
DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES THAT
PROJECTS WILL BE FULLY AND
ROLLED BY JUNE.
THE ENROLLMENT OF ADDITIONAL
MULTI FAMILY PROJECTS IS
CONTINGENT UPON FUTURE FUNDING.
TWO NEW COMPONENTS OF THE LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM OR
THE COMMUNITY SOLAR PILOT AND
THE FARM WORKER HOUSING THE
PILOT IS DESIGNED TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO RENEWABLE ENERGY FOR
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
INCLUDING THOSE THAT DO NOT HAVE
THE ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE EXISTING LOW INCOME SOLAR
PEAVEY.
EITHER DUE TO A LACK OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP INADEQUATE ROOFING
OR OTHER FACTORS.
GREAT ALTERNATIVES IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE SANTA ROSA
BAND OF COLA INDIANS IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY WAS AWARDED A
LITTLE OVER TWO MILLION DOLLARS
TO BENEFIT TRIBAL AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES.
GRID ALSO IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE PORT OF RICHMOND WAS AWARDED.
ABOUT TWO POINT FOUR MILLION FOR
A PROJECT THAT WILL BENEFIT LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS IN RICHMOND'S
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
THE CONTRACTS WILL BE AWARDED IN
APRIL.
FARM WORKER HOUSING WILL PROVIDE
ENERGY EFFICIENCY MEASURES AND
SOLAR PEAVEY SYSTEMS AND SINGLE
FAMILY FARM WORKER HOMES ACROSS
TWELVE COUNTIES IN THE STATE
WITH THE HIGHEST FARM WORKER
POPULATIONS. TEN AND A HALF
MILLION WILL BE AWARDED NEXT
MONTH.
AND THEN FINALLY THE EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT AS YOU KNOW IS
ONE OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE ANTI
POVERTY TOOLS IN THE DEPARTMENT
CONTINUES TO LEAD A WORK GROUP
OF PUBLIC AND PRIVATE AGENCIES
COMMITTED TO EXPANDING THE
NUMBER OF CALIFORNIANS CLAIMING
THE CREDIT.
THE DEPARTMENT ALSO CONTINUES TO
PARTNER WITH THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD TO ADMINISTER THE
CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
GRANTS.
AS WELL AS THE NEW FREE TAX
PREPARATION ASSISTANCE GRANTS.
FOR THE THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN TAX YEARS USED TO
PROVIDE FUNDING TO LOCAL
AGENCIES THROUGH COMPETITIVE
GROUND AWARDS EIGHTEEN WERE
AWARDED FOR THE EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH AND FIFTEEN TO SUPPORT
OF THE FREE TAX PREPARATION
ASSISTANCE.
AND IN CLOSING I JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORK OF THE
COMMUNITY ACTION AGENCIES AS
WELL AS OTHER NONPROFIT AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES THAT
WORK TO ALLEVIATE THE CAUSES AND
CONDITIONS OF POVERTY.
AND THEIR COMMUNITIES AND ARE
COMMITTED TO STRENGTHENING THE
ECONOMIC SECURITY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY COMES
FROM ELIA [inaudible]
FINANCE [inaudible]
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
pSO FIRST OF ALL -- IN TERMS OF
THE COMMITTEE SERVICES OF BLOCK
GRANTS I MEAN YOU'RE DOING A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
HOW HOW DOES YOUR DEPARTMENT SO
HOMELESSNESS DRESSING
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING IS A
BIG ISSUE -- ENOUGH FOR THE ONLY
FOR THE LEGISLATURE FOR FOR THE
GOVERNOR -- HOW DOES YOUR AGENCY
INTERFACE WITH OUR VARIOUS
EFFORTS THAT WERE DOING ITS
STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL -- IT TO
TRY ADDRESS -- HOMELESSNESS
GIVEN THE FACT THAT YOU'RE DOING
THESE PROGRAMS ON WELL WRITER
FOR PROGRAMS THIS.
THE AS I SAID THE UNIQUENESS OF
THE COMMUNITY SERVICES BLOCK
GRANT REALLY DOES ALLOW A LOCAL
AGENCY TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITY.
SOME OF OUR AGENCIES FOR EXAMPLE
IN SAN LUIS OBISPO THE COMMUNITY
ACTION AGENCY THERE HAS A AN
ACTUAL SHELTERS IN WHICH THEY
PROVIDE -- HOUSING FOR HOMELESS --
WE ISSUED FUNDING FOR THE
RECENTLY IN WHICH THEY WERE ABLE
TO BUY COTTS FOR FOR THE SHELTER
SO IT IS VERY DEPENDENT UPON
EACH LOCAL AGENCY AND WHAT THE
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY ALREADY MAY
HAVE IN THE COMMUNITY THAT IS
ADDRESSING THAT NEED.
BUT THEY'RE DEFINITELY
DEFINITELY AT THE FOREFRONT OF
ADDRESSING THOSE ISSUES TO THE
TO THE DEGREE THAT I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS AND NO ONE ONE HAND
THE THE I THINK FIFTY NINE
COMMUNITY ACTION AGENCIES
HOPEFULLY.
IS AT THAT.
IN IN YOUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
THEM RIGHTS YOU'RE GIVING OUT
THE GRANTS -- VISIBLE IS THIS
DEPARTMENT USUALLY AT THE TABLE
AND DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS AND DO YOU I GUESS
DIRECTIVES NOT THE RIGHT WORD
BUT IN TERMS OF GUIDANCE -- TO
THESE AGENCIES AN OBJECT AND
THAT THE AGENCY SHOULD BE
INVOLVED THEIR BEACH.
I I'M INDUSTRY A BETTER HANDLE
ON I'M SURE THE COMMITTEE ACTION
AGENCIES ARE DOING A LOT OF
WONDERFUL WORK.
I'M JUST TRYING TO THINK ABOUT
HOW HOW WE ARE DAY AT THE TABLE
LOCALLY ARE THEY STILL AT THE
ASK DOT EIGHT TABLE LOCALLY TO
WHAT DEGREE IS THIS DEPARTMENT
AT THE TABLE AND THAT
DISCUSSIONS AT THE STATE AND AND
DO YOU THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THIS DEPARTMENT SHOULD BE.
GIVEN THE WORK YOU DO AND
EXACTLY WHAT'S RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN YOUR AGENCY ITEGRANTES
WHEN IT COMES TO TRYING TO MOVE
THE NEEDLE.
ON THESE ISSUES.
YES EACH AGENCIES -- PROVIDES TO
THE DEPARTMENT EVERY OTHER YEAR --
THE COMMUNITY ACTION PLAN SO THE
DEPARTMENT RCEIVES A PLANS
THOSE ARE THE PLANS THAT THEN GO
IN WHEN WE HAVE OUR ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE -- HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE AND WE PRESENT THE
STATE PLAN.
AND SO THOSE -- BOB PLANS ARE
REVIEWED BY THE DEPARTMENT IT'S
I THINK TO THE DEGREE THAT WE
SEE THAT THERE'S A AND IS AN
ADDITIONAL NEEDS AT THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY WE TRY TO HELP THEM IN
ANY KIND OF BUREAUCRACY THAT
THEY MAY HAVE BUT IT'S
DEFINITELY -- A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN BEING A STATE
ORGANIZATION HELPING TO ENSURE
THAT FUNDING ARE USED
APPROPRIATELY AND STILL ALLOWING
FOR THAT LOCAL FLEXIBILITY WHICH
IS REALLY IMPORTANT WHAT THESE
DOLLARS.
BUT WE DO FOR INSTANCE HAVE SOME --
WHAT'S CALLED DISCRETIONARY
DOLLARS WITH THE COMMUNITY
SERVICES BLOCK GRANT AND WE'VE
DONE TARGETED INITIATIVES WHERE
WE'VE IDENTIFIED HOUSING --
ISSUES -- EMPLOYMENT ISSUES AS
WELL AS THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT SO IT'S IT'S A UNIQUE
RELATIONSHIP BECAUSE IT IS SO --
LOCALLY CONTROLLED BUT TO THE
DOES THE WHEN THERE'S TASK FORCE
OR OTHER EFFORTS AT THE STATE
LEVEL AGAIN THAT PARTNERSHIP
SIMILAR TO THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT.
THE DEPARTMENT ALSO PARTICIPATES
TO THE DEGREE THAT WE HAVE ANY
DIRECT FUNDING OR DIRECT ABILITY
TO SAY THAT.
IT'S HARD BECAUSE IT'S NOT
EXACTLY A PROGRAM IS A FUN
SOURCE AND THEIR AGENCY BRINGS
AND ALL SORTS OF REVENUE FROM
ALL SORTS OF PHILANTHROPIC
LITTLE THAT SAYS EIGHTY ANY YOU
ARE TO CHANNEL FOR THE ELF Là
FEDERAL FUNDS I MEAN WE WERE
ONLY DOING TEN MILLION FROM THE
STATE'S.
SELLIER BUDGETS NEARLY FEDERAL
BUT I'M JUST TRYING TO GET A
SENSE OF YEAH HOW YOU JUST SAY.
PASTEURIZATION ARE IS THERE YOU
KNOW AT THAT THE I MEAN.
ASIDE FROM JUST LIKE -- HERE'S
THE MONEY I MEAN YOU'D REFUSING
TO MEET THE PLANS AND SO FORTH
AND JUST TRY TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT'S THE PROCESS BY WHICH WE
PROVIDE SOME AND AGAIN I
RECOGNIZE THAT -- THERE'S STILL
A DIFFERENT COMMITTEES ARE
DIFFERENT AND AND THAT THE
PEOPLE ON THE CLOSER TO THE
GROUND HAVE A BETTER IDEA WHAT'S.
AND IN TERMS OF BUT JUST.
THAT'S BECAUSE I WENT YOU KNOW
YOU TALK ABOUT THE FEDERAL LEVEL --
THE LEAST THERE SOME PEOPLE
HOPEFULLY NOT SUCCESSFULLY ONE
OF LINE OUT.
THE BODY RIGHT NAY TODAY THEN --
IN THE BUDGET SO THE
ADMINISTRATION SO I AND I DID IT
JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT LIKE
IN TERMS OF ACCOUNTABILITY LIKE
OKAY IN AND YOU DID REALLY LIKE
OKAY WE PUT UP THIS MONEY HERE
TO SAY BUT WHAT WHAT ARE THE
OUTCOME IN THE RESULTS AND WHAT.
TO WHAT DEGREE IS THIS MONEY
HELPING SOLVE SOME OF THESE
BIGGER THESE THESE LARGER ISSUES.
AND YOU SEEM TO BE THE TYPES OF
ACTIVITIES IN THE WELL SUITED TO
NOT SOLVE THE ENTIRE ISSUE BUT
TO CONTRIBUTE.
AND IN MANY WAYS AND HOW CAN WE
TRY TO COMPILE THAT INFORMATION
IN A WAY THAT -- THAT SHOWS THE
VALUE OF OF THE OF OF THE MONEY
THAT -- IS THAT THAT'S BEEN
GRANTED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE BENEFITS THAT
SO.
YEAH AND AND WE WE DO GET
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA THAT SHOWS THE
SERVICES ARE PROVIDED AS I SAID
IN THE TESTIMONY ABOUT TWO
MILLION INDIVIDUALS ARE SERVED
ANNUALLY.
BUT AGAIN IT IS THE WHAT MAKES
IT WORK SO WELL IS THE FACT THAT
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST OF
FLEXIBLE FUND SOURCE FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND IT ALLOWS
THE AGENCY TO REALLY LEVERAGE
AND AGAINST ALL SORTS OF FEDERAL
PROGRAMS AND AND LOCAL DOLLARS
THAT THEY HAVE -- BUT WE DO
OVERSEE THEM AND THE EXPENDITURE
pSAME TYPE OF RELATIONSHIP IT
WOULD BE IF IT WAS IN STATE
STATUTE THAT WERE.
PROVIDING A HOUSING PROGRAM OR
DOING SOMETHING SPECIFIC BUT
THERE THEY DO FOOD BANKS THEY DO
ALL SORTS OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
USING REALLY OVERALL A SMALL
AMOUNT OF FEDERAL DOLLARS AND IT
WAS.
SIXTY THREE YEAH I GUESS I'M
SAYING IS I MEAN THERE'S THERE'S
THE OKAY WHAT THE FISCAL ROLE IN
DID YOU DOT ALL THE I'S AND
TEASING YEP INVOICES FOR
EVERYTHING AND THEN THERE'S THE
STORIES THAT I CAN TELL RIGHT
THE THINGS TO ACCOMPLISH IS A
VERY IMPORTANT THING THAT.
WE FIND A WAY TO BETTER CAPTURE
THE STORIES IN ADDITION TO
KNOWING THAT THE INVOICE
EVERYTHING CORRECTLY --
DEFINITELY AND AND WE DO DO THAT
WE CAN COLLECT THE STORIES AGAIN
AND HAVE THAT.
AVAILABLE AND AND DEFINITELY
SURE THAT INFORMATION OKAY.
WITH ALL RIGHT SUBCOMMITTEE OKAY
SO FULL AND THEN THE OTHER
QUESTION WAS -- YEAH GREAT WE'RE
GETTING SOLAR AND OTHER THINGS
TO LOW INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS I
WAS ACTUALLY EIGHT THAT --
CEREMONY SEVERAL YEARS AGO -- I
THINK THIS ONE THE QUESTION I
HAVE IS I DON'T IT'S SORT OF WE
DO SOMETHING TO PUT MONEY WE
BUILD THINGS -- AND THEN IF IT'S
A LOW INCOME NEIGHBORHOOD LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS THERE'S
MAINTENANCE NOW SOLAR.
PANEL SUNSHINE'S BUT STILL -- IS
IT D. IT'S IT IS THERE ANY SORT
OF FOLLOW UP AT ANY CONCERNED I
MEAN.
THOSE ARE ANY HELP IN TERMS OF
SOMETHING BREAKS IS OF FOURTH
THAT WE DON'T END UP WITH WE PUT
A BUNCH OF MONEY IN SOMETHING
BROKE AND THEY JUST CAN'T FIX IT
THEY DON'T HAVE THE WHEREWITHAL
TO FIX IT.
AND AND WHICH MAY BE SO I I'M
JUST WONDERING TERMS ON THE
MAINTENANCE SIDE -- IS THERE ANY
HELP WE GIVE THESE HOUSEHOLDS WE
FOLLOW UP WITH THEM AND SAY HEY
HOW'S YOUR SOLAR STILL WORKING.
YOU KNOW. THREE YEARS LATER WE
BUILT THIS THING CELL AND IT YES --
I CAN ANSWER THAT -- THE REASON
THE SINCE CAN ATTENTION IS GIVEN
TO MAINTENANCE A WARRANTY FOR
THE WORK THAT WE PERFORM BOTH ON
THE ENERGY EFFICIENCY ON THE
SELLER'S SIDE.
BUT TO YOUR SPECIFIC QUESTION ON
SOLAR THERE ARE STRONG
WARRANTIES TO A TEN YEAR
WARRANTY FOR EXAMPLE SO THERE
ARE BEEN.
A FEW INSTANCES WHERE CLIENTS
HAVE HAD PROBLEMS WITH THE
SYSTEMS THAT WERE INSTALLED --
THE CUT ON THE COMPANIES
ORGANIZATIONS INVOLVED IN AN
INSULATION WILL GO OUT AND
TYPICALLY REMEDY -- THOSE THAT
THOSE ISSUES SO WE'RE CERTAIN
THAT THE THE PERFORMANCE OF
THESE SYSTEMS ARE CONTINUING AND
THE PROVIDING THE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY BENEFITS IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS.
AND IN YOUR FOLLOWING UP WITH
THE WITH THE CLIENTS TO BE SURE
THAT -- SO YOU CAN HAVE A
WARRANTY AND SOMETIMES PEOPLE
FOLLOW THROUGH THE WARRANTY OR
NOT SO I JUST -- SO IT'S GREATER
THERE IT'S IT'S ON BE SURE THAT
THE SYSTEM SIR THAT SOMEONE'S
DOING -- SOME FOLLOW UP TO SHARE
THE SYSTEMS ARE STILL UP AND
RUNNING AND THAT THEY'RE NOT --
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE AND CERTAINLY
HAVING WARRANTIES ARE IMPORTANT
BUT ALSO PEOPLE NEED.
TO FOLLOW THROUGH IN.
DON'T BE SURE THEY'RE USING THE
WARRANTY THAT PEOPLE THAT ARE.
NOW HOW DID HOW TO DRAW DOWN AND
AT THAT THE COMPANIES ARE
FOLLOWING THROUGH ON THAT WHICH
OF SURE THEY ARE MONDAY WHEN
THEY'RE CALLED.
YEAH -- IN IN PART OF THE
SERVICE THAT WE PROVIDE IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S GOOD
REPRESENTATION OF WHO THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE INVOLVED
IN THIS ACTIVITY THAT SUPPORT IT.
AND IF THERE ARE PROBLEMS WITH
PARTNERSHIP OR ANYTHING ELSE
THEY KNOW THEY KNOW THE CONTACT
THE PRO QUE ALL RIGHT USE THE
OTHER CHALLENGED IT -- LOW
INCOME FAMILIES FOR FOR MANY
GOOD REASONS ARE OFF AND
UNFORTUNATELY THEY OFTEN HAVE TO
MOVE MORE OFTEN RIGHT -- IS A
JOB GET A NEW JOB ETCETERA SO.
YOU MAY NOT BE EVEN DEALING WITH
THE REGIONAL OWNER ARE NICE
OWNER LEASE OR WHATEVER AT THE
TIME YOU INSTALL AND YOU KNOW WE
TALK ABOUT FARMWORKERS AND
SOMETIMES YOU KNOW THAT THEIR
BILL IS MOVING AROUND SO.
IT MADE THE LITTLE EXTRA
ATTENTION TO BE SURE THAT THE
PERSON WHO MOVED IN.
THINGS THAT WORKING THEY DON'T
KNOW ABOUT THE WARRANTY THEY
WEREN'T AROUND WHEN THE THING
WAS FIRST PUT UP NO ONE TOLD
THEM KIND OF THING SO.
JUST ONE JUST ONE TO CHECK IN
WHAT THE FOLLOW THROUGH IN THE
MAIN.
EDUCATION WAS SO ALL RIGHT.
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
OKAY PUBLIC COMMENT.
NO PUBLIC COMMENT ALL RIGHT WELL
I THINK THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU -- SOMEONE'S.
RIGHT SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
THEN -- TO DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES.
SO WE'RE GOING ACTUALLY IT'S
JUST AN OVERVIEW SAYS NOTHING
OLD OPEN.
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY.
AND SO SINCE THIS IS A NEW MAJOR
SECTIONAL AGAIN EVERYONE GO
ROUND THE TABLE AGAIN FOR
DIRECTOR TO INTRODUCTION
STARTING WITH THE AGENCY.
OKAY CAN BE THAT AGAIN YEAH YOUR
YOUR LIGHT CAME TO GET.
BACK TO FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES THANK YOU.
TENSION -- CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER FOR THE DEPARTMENT THANK
YOU ELIA.
JACKIE BRAZIL ELIA.
GINNY BALLOT ILIO YOU FINANCE.
WHISPERS WHAT APARTMENT FINANCE.
JAKE A PORT FINANCE THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH AN OVERVIEW OF THE
DEPARTMENT WE DO HAVE A VERY
NICE RIGHT UP BUT HE CAN GIVE US
THE HIGHLIGHTS ON THE THINGS
THAT YOU'RE DOING AND ALSO WHERE
THE THINGS YOU LOOK TO NEXT YEAR
AND ANY. TO ANY OF THE MAJOR
ISSUES THAT -- HE THAT SAID THAT
ARE FACING THE DEPARTMENTS OF
THANK YOU WELCOME.
A MAN START WITH A OVERVIEW THE
BUDGET.
THANK YOU -- SO IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE D. SAYS
SYSTEM DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING
ONE POINT ZERO EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS -- THAT'S THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY NINE MILLION GENERAL FUND
AND SEVEN HUNDRED FORTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS OF FEDERAL
FUNDING -- THIS IS A SIXTY ONE
MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE IN
COMPARISON TO THE CURRENT
ENACTED BUDGET.
PRIMARILY THE INCREASE IS TIED
TO A FIFTY SIX MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL ON THE WILL DISCUSS
LATER ON IN THE AGENDA FOR ISSUE
NUMBER.
TWO AND OTHER INCREASES ARE TIED
TO A FOUR MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE FOR STAFFING COSTS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT.
TIED TO INCREASE SALARIES AND
BENEFITS -- THE BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
FOUR FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
TO ESTABLISH PARENTAGE
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM -- FOR SAME
SEX -- AND ON WHAT OPPOSED TO
ESTABLISH PARENTAGE AND OTHER
FOLKS THAT MAYBE USING --
REPRODUCTIVE ASSISTANCE METHODS --
THE BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR ESTIMATED
INCREASE FEDERAL INCENTIVES AS
WELL.
ON THE BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES
ESTIMATED TWO POINT FIVE FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN COLLECTIONS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT THIS IS A
FIFTY EIGHT POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR INCREASE IN COMPARISON TO
THE CURRENT ENACTED BUDGET --
THE INCREASE IS PRIMARILY DUE --
TO ESTIMATES TIED TO NOT
ASSISTANCE COLLECTIONS AND FOR
ASSISTANCE QUESTIONS WERE
ASSUMING THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
REMAIN RELATIVELY FLAT.
AT FOUR HUNDRED NINE MILLION
DOLLARS.
FROM A PROGRAM CHANGES
PERSPECTIVE -- WHEN THE PRIMARY
ISSUES THAT SPACE AND A CHANCE
FOR PROGRAM IS -- IN DECEMBER
TWENTIETH OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
FEDERAL CSE PUBLISHED THE
FLEXIBILITY EFFICIENCY
MODERNIZATION OF THE CHILD
SUPPORT PROGRAM -- WHICH THEY
REFER TO AS THE FINAL RULE THE
FINAL RULE MAKECHANGES TO THE
CHILD SUPPORT PROGRAM INTENDED
TO INCREASE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE PROGRAM FOR ALL FAMILIES.
STATES TERRITORIES IN TRAVEL
PROGRAMS AND TO ENSURE THAT THE
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES ARE
ACCESSIBLE TO FAMILIES AND
DELIVERED IN A FAIR AND
TRANSPARENT MANNER.
SOME OF THESE KEY CHANGES
INCLUDE CLARIFYING IN
STREAMLINING REGULATIONS TO
IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY OF THE
CHILD'S OR PROGRAM.
CLARIFYING VARIABLES THAT SHOULD
BE CONSIDERED OR INCLUDED WHEN
CALCULATING CHILD SUPPORT ORDER
AMOUNTS IN ORDER TO IMPROVE THE
FAIRNESS AND ACCURACY OF CHILD
SUPPORT ORDERS IT EXPANDS THE
CRITERIA FOR CLOSING CHILD
SUPPORT CASES.
AND EXPANDS THE TYPES OF
SERVICES FOR WHICH THE FEDERAL
FINANCIAL PARTICIPATION IS
AVAILABLE.
DECSS WILL BE EVALUATING THESE
PROVISIONS RELATED TO CHARLES
PARK EILING CALCULATE --
CALCULATOR IN THE CONTEXT THE
CURRENT GUIDELINE QUADRENNIAL
REVIEW WHICH IS A FEDERALLY
REQUIRED REVIEW THE STATE CHILD
SUPPORT ORDER SETTING GUIDELINES
DECSS MET WITH THE LOCAL
TRANSPORT AGENCIES IN THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL CALIFORNIA
THROUGHOUT. TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO
REVIEW BOTH THE FINAL RULE
PROVISIONS AS WELL AS RELATED TO
THE GUIDELINE AS WELLS AS THE
CORNEA REVIEW REPORT.
SINCE LAST YEAR THE DEPARTMENT
HAS IMPLEMENTED MANY PROVISIONS
REQUIRED BY THE FEDERAL WRITING.
BUT IS STILL WORKING ON
IMPLEMENTING A FEW OF THE
REMAINING ONES THE DEPARTMENT IS
AWAITING FEEDBACK FROM ITS WORK
GROUPS ON THOSE IMPLEMENTATION
DECISIONS.
AND THE PROVISIONS AWAITING A
DECISION ARE OPTIONAL AND THEY
HAVE AND COMPLAIN ST OF JANUARY --
TWENTY JENNIFER TWENTY TWENTY
TWO FRAP -- FOR IMPLEMENTATION.
ASIDE FROM THE PATERNITY
OPPORTUNITY -- DAY BY THAT
REMARK IDENTIFIED THERE ONE
ADDITIONAL THING THAT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW ASIDE FROM
THE GRANTS THAT WE ARE ALREADY
RUNNING IS A DIGITAL MARKETING
GRANT.
AND THAT'S KICKING OFF IN A VERY
DIFFERENT COUNTIES -- TO PROVIDE
AN INCREASED AWARENESS OF THE
CHILD SUPPORT PROGRAM SEE -- HOW
THAT IMPACTS THE AM INDIVIDUALS
AND CONSTITUENTS IN CALIFORNIA?
THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
COMES FROM L. L..
ON THE OVERVIEW.
NO COMMENTS ON THE OVERVIEW I
WILL RESERVE OUR COMMENTS --
REGARDING THE NEW PROPOSED
BUDGET METHODOLOGY FOR ISSUE TWO
OKAY THANK YOU I FINANCE.
NOTHING THAT HAPPENED YESTERDAY
QUESTIONS OKAY THANK YOU.
PACIFIC REMEMBERS.
UP SO JUST IN TERMS OF THE
FEDERAL PERFORMANCE MEASURES IN
THE NEW FINAL RULE.
SO GIVEN THE AND INTO YOUR EVEN
MADE SOME CHANGES IS ALSO THAT.
A GIVEN WHERE WE ARE NOW TO OF
OF EVERYBODY ARE WE GOING TO BE
OKAY ARE WE GOING TO FIND
OURSELVES AFOUL OF THE NEW
STANDARDS I MEAN EVERY BEHIND WE
ON TRACK EVERY OKAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR WE'RE IN FRONT
OF THE CURVE WHEN IT COMES TO
THE FINAL RULE MANY OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE IN THE
FINAL RULE CALIFORNIA HAS HAD
ADOPTED FOR QUITE SOME TIME SO
THERE'S SOME FINE TUNING TO BE
DONE AROUND.
THE GUIDELINE CALCULATION ITSELF
AND IDENTIFYING FAIR AND
EQUITABLE ORDERS ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES FOR RIGHT NOW WE'RE
FACING IS -- PART OF OUR
GUIDELINE AND IS A PRESUMED
INCOME IF WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
PEOPLE ARE MAKING WE PRESUME
THAT THEY'RE MAKING AT LEAST
MINIMUM WAGE FORTY HOURS.
AND THAT MIGHT NOT BE THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE FACING IN
CALIFORNIA SO THE QUADRENNIAL
REVIEW AND UNDERSTANDING EXACTLY
WHAT THAT GUY AND I NEED TO
BEING IS ONE OF THE BIG QUESTION
MARKS THAT THINK WE STILL TO
WORK THROUGH -- THROUGHOUT THIS
COUNTRY -- REVIEW THAT WERE WERE
ENGAGED IN PROFESSOR PERFORMANCE
PERCEPT RAM PERSPECTIVE -- COST
EFFECTIVENESS CONTINUES TO BE
WORK CALIFORNIA STRUGGLES THE
MOST WERE ON THE BOTTOM OF THAT --
LIST BUT WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE REST OF THE FEATHER
PERFORMANCE MEASURES WERE TOP
FIFTEEN AM STATE IN THE NATION
SO ON COLLECTIONS AND GRAN COURT
ORDERS AND THINGS LIKE THAT
WHERE WE'RE HIGH PERFORMING.
COMPARED TO THE OTHER STATES
SOARING WHAT WE'RE HIGH
PERFORMING THEY THINK WE SPEND
TOO MUCH ON HIGH PERFORMANCE
WELL WE HAVE INVESTED A LOT IN A
JOBS.
PROGRAM AND YOU KNOW GIVEN THE
POPULATION SIZES CALIFORNIA
POVERTY RATES AND THINGS LIKE
THAT FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
PERFORM SO WELL AND THEN ON THE
TRANSFER PROGRAM KIND OF SPEAKS
TO THAT IN.
THAT -- INVESTMENT IN THE
PROGRAM OKAY ALL RIGHT A GOOD
POINT.
EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT -- KATE SNOW
THE QUESTIONS SO WE'RE GONNA
TAKE PUBLIC COME AT THE END OF
THE SECTION -- THIS LET'S MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO LOCAL
TRANSPORT AGENCIES A MYSTERY
FUNDING AUGMENTATION.
SO LAST NAME TO GIVE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE FUNDING MODEL
ITSELF AND THEN MAYBE WE CAN
TALK TO THE SPECIFICS THERE.
THANK YOU -- DEGENERATE DOES A
REALLY GREAT JOB OF OUTLINING
THE OVERALL PROPOSAL AND SONS
GOING TO KIND OF GO THROUGH IT --
BRIEFLY AND SO STE COMING BACK --
STARTING BACK IN SPRING OF LAST
YEAR DURING THE LAST BUDGET
CYCLE ON THE DEPARTMENT -- IN
CONJUNCTION CSTA HAD TO SUBMIT A
PROPOSAL -- TO ESSENTIALLY
AUGMENT THE LCS A BUDGET FOR
STAFFING SHORTAGES OR STAFFING
AND FUNDING SHORTAGES AND THE
CURRENT ENACTED BUDGET INCLUDES
THREE MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND EIGHT POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLAR TOLL FUNDS. TO HELP
SUPPORT NINETEEN OF THE LOWEST
FUNDED COUNTIES -- SENSE THAN
THE DEPARTMENT AND CSTA HAVE
KIND OF GONE BACK AND ESTABLISH
WORK GROUPS TO LOOK AT THAT --
PROPOSAL -- SUBMITTED LAST YEAR
AND ESSENTIALLY THE PROPOSAL
BEFORE YOU IS A PART A PRODUCT
OF THAT EFFORT.
THE DEPARTMENT CSTA HAD SEVERAL
CORE PILLARS THAT WE WANTED TO
FOLLOW -- ONE OF WHICH WAS THAT
WE WANTED TO EXISTS IMPROVE
EXISTING BUDGING PRACTICES
ADDRESS ALSO SEE STAFFING --
COST PRESSURES AND FUTURE COST
PRESSURES AND BUILD ON THE
EFFICIENCIES OF SHARED SERVICES
AS WELL AS A CORE UNDERSTANDING
OF THE COLLABORATIVE EFFORT
WHAT'S THE HOLD HARMLESS DEALS
THIS IS A ARE CURRENTLY FUNDED
MORE THAN WHAT THE METHODOLOGY
WOULD CALCULATE -- FROM THAT THE
FUNDAMENTAL CORE METHODOLOGY
INCOMES THREE MAJOR COMPONENTS --
ONE BASE LEVEL STAFFING FOR CASE
WORK OPERATIONS TO CALL CENTER
OPERATIONS AND THREE A
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE COMPONENT.
FOR CASE WORK OPERATIONS CSTA IN
THE L. -- THE CSA'S AND DECSS
SELECTED FIFTEEN LCS ACE TO
SAMPLE I'M RANGING FROM VERY
LARGE SUCH AS LOS ANGELES TO
SMALL -- SUCH AS MARIN TO
CONDUCT LEVEL OF EFFORT STUDIES
TO DETERMINE WHAT IS THE TASKS
AND THE AMOUNT OF EFFORT IT
TAKES ON AVERAGE FOR STAFF TO
COMPLETE A WIDE ARRAY OF
MANDATORY CASE WORK TASKS.
THESE TESTS INCLUDING SUCH AS
OPENING CASES ESTABLISHING
ORDERS AND FORCING ORDERS.
REVIEW AND JUST EXISTING ORDERS
CASE WORK FINANCIALS
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT.
AS A RESULT OF THAT EFFORT --
THE LEVEL OF EFFORT STUDY
YIELDED RESULTS THAT ESTIMATED
IT WOULD TAKE APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN CASES FOUR
ONE F. T..
AND BASED ON THAT RATIO --
THERE'S ALSO A TWENTY POINT 9%
WE ANY COMPONENT ADDED ON TOP OF
THAT FOR COSTS SUCH AS FACILITY
LEASES CONTRACTS MAINTENANCE
UTILITIES AND OTHER OR ANY NEEDS.
THE SECOND COMPONENT THE FOR
CALL CENTER OPERATIONS IS BUILT
AROUND.
THE RATIO OF CAUGHT -- CALLS PER
FTE.
THE APARTMENT LOOKED AT HOW
CURRENT CALL CENTERS ARE
OPERATING TODAY AND DECIDED THAT
A RATIO SIXTY SIX THOUSAND I'M
SORRY.
SIX THOUSAND AND THIRTY COST PER
FTE -- AS THE METRIC BY WHICH TO
MEASURE PERFORMANCE AND FUNDING --
THIS IS KIND OF A MIDDLE GROUND
BETWEEN LC ESSAYS ARE CUTTING
RUNNING CURRENTLY RUNNING CALL
CENTERS EFFICIENTLY AND SOME
THAT FALL A LITTLE BIT BELOW THE
THRESHOLD.
AND WITH THE NEED TO IMPROVE
THEIR PERFORMANCE TO MEET -- THE
EXPECTATIONS.
THE THIRD COMPONENT IS FOR
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVES -- THE
DEPARTMENT DELTA CAM
PERFORMANCES CENTER MODEL THAT
LOOKS AT TWO COMPONENTS THE
FIRST IS -- TOTAL COLLECTIONS AT
FOR NOW CSA AND THE SECOND IS
COLLECTION PER CASE.
THE REASON FOR PICKING THESE TWO
POINTS MATCHES IS OBVIOUSLY THE
PRIME EXISTS -- TO EFFECTUALLY
COLLECTIONS FOR FAMILIES BUT WE
DIDN'T WANT TO SIMPLY LOOK AT
TOTAL COLLECTIONS BECAUSE THAT
COULD JUST SIMPLY BE TIED TO
TOTAL -- INCREASING CASELOADS
WHICH IS THE CASE THAT WE WILL
ALSO WANTED TO IMPROVE.
ON INDIVIDUAL CASES ARE
INDIVIDUAL FAMILIES OUTCOMES AS
WELL AND SO BY LOOKING ABOVE.
THERE'S A FAIR BALANCE BETWEEN
THOSE TWO METRICS ON THE OTHER
COMPONENT OF THE PERFORMANCES
AND OF FINDING IS THAT WE'RE
COMPARING ELSE JUST SAY TO
THEMSELVES.
AND SO CALIFORNIA IS VERY
DIVERSE IN ITS DEMOGRAPHICS AND
SUCH AND WE DIDN'T WANT TO
PENALIZE CERTAIN COUNTIES THAT
HAVE LESS AFFLUENT DEMOGRAPHICS
WHEN BEING COMPARED TO OTHERS
AND SO.
WIN A COUNTIES WHEN COMPARED TO
THEMSELVES THIS KIND OF
ESTABLISH ABOUT FAIRNESS AND
THANK YOU.
SIDE THIS S. SAY THERE'S THREE
MAJOR GOALS OF THIS PROPOSAL
ONCE REDUCING POVERTY IN THE
TWENTY ONE COUNTIES TO LOCAL
TRUST RIGHT AGENCIES WHICH
RECEIVED THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
IT ENABLES FAMILIES IN THESE
COUNTIES TO BE MORE SEL
SUFFICIENT AND IMPROVES THE
FUNDING EQUITY FOR THE STATE'S
LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES
THAT THE CHILD'S FOR CUSTOMERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA CAN
RECEIVE.
CONSISTENT LEVELS OF SERVICE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SPECIFIC TO POVERTY TWENTY ONE
IN THE TWENTY ONE COUNTIES ARE
IMPACTED HERE RECEIVE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING HAVE SOME OF THE HIGHEST
RATES OF POVERTY INSIDE STATE.
PARTY RATES AMONGST THE TWENTY
ONE COUNTIES IS AVERAGING
FIFTEEN POINT 1% AMONGST THEM.
AND WHILE THE RATES AS HIGH AS
21% IN FRESNO KERN A MADERA
SPECIFIC TAKE THE CASE LOADS AND
HE'S TWENTY ONE COUNTY 78% OF
THE CASES ARE CURRENTLY FORMER
OR NEVER EIGHTY OR CURRENT OR
FORMALLY EIGHT IN.
WITH REGARD TO SELF SUFFICIENCY
IS CHALLENGING FOR FAMILIES IN
OUR CASE LIVE IN THESE COUNTIES
TO BE SELF SUFFICIENT CURRENTLY
THE AVERAGE COLLECTIONS PER CASE
FOR THE TWENTY ONE COUNTIES AS A
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE DOLLARS PER YEAR.
THAT'S COMPARED BY THE AVERAGE
OF THE 200-040-0401 PER YEAR OF
THE OTHER THIRTY LOCAL TRANSFER
AGENCIES.
ACCORDING TO THE STUDY CONDUCT
BY THE URBAN INSTITUTE THE CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS CAN ACCOUNT FOR
UP 240%.
OF A LOW INCOME RECIPIENTS
HOUSEHOLD INCOME.
WITH REGARD TO FIT FUNDING
EQUITY THE LA -- REPORTEDLY
CORRECTLY REPORTS THERE'S A
GREAT DISPARITY IN THE FUNDING
ACROSS LOCAL CHANNELS FOR
AGENCIES THE AVERAGE FUNDING FOR
CASE FOR THE TWENTY ONE COUNTIES
IS FIVE HUNDRED ONE DOLLARS PER
CASE.
COMPARED TO THE AVERAGE OF EIGHT
HUNDRED AND NINETY FOUR PER CASE
FOR THE OTHER THIRTY COUNTIES
STOPPING FUNDING EQUITY IS
CRITICAL TO ENSURE THAT THE
CHILD SUPPORT PROGRAM IS ABLE TO
PROVIDE.
A CONSISTENT LEVEL OF SERVICE
STATEWIDE FOR CHILD SUPPORT
CUSTOMERS DESPITE GEOGRAPHIC AND
SOCIOECONOMIC DIFFERENCES ACROSS
THE STATE.
SO WE ATTEMPTED TO TACKLE A LOT
OF THESE -- INSIDE THE PROPOSAL
THE DAN FIGHT ISSUES ONCE
WITHOUT POVERTY AND AND SELF
SUFFICIENCY AND THE OTHER WITH
EQUITY AND AND I I REALLY WANT
EMPHASIZE WHY I'M CONCERNED THAT
WE SHOULDN'T AND CAN'T WAIT --
TO MOVE FORWARD ON THIS PROPOSAL.
THERE WERE TWENTY ONE COUNTIES
LAW FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR
POSITIONS OF THE LAST SIX YEARS
AND IF YOU GO BACK EVEN FURTHER
THAT'S AN EVEN MORE DRASTIC
NUMBER.
STAFFING REDUCTIONS OF 12% AS
NOTED ABOVE THIS IS RESULTED IN
LOWER PROGRAM PERFORMANCE
MEASURES DELIVERY OF SERVICING
COLLECTIONS CUSTOMERS THE COST
OF WAITING IS THAT THE
ECONOMICALLY CHALLENGED FAMILIES
IN THESE COUNTIES.
WILL CONTINUE TO BE UNDERSERVED
COMPARATIVE FAMILIES SERVE BY
ADEQUATELY FUNDED LCS ACE.
EFFICIENCY IS A BIT OF A KEY
DISCUSSION IS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THE MOST SICK SIGNIFICANT
EFFICIENCY WITH WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED IS THAT OF THE CALL
CENTERS WHICH WE SPECIFICALLY
CALLED OUT IN A PROPOSAL.
VIC SUCCESSFUL ENCOURAGE CELSIUS
IS TO CONSOLIDATE THEIR CALL
CENTERS TO REDUCE THE COST OF
RUNNING INDEPENDENT CALL CENTERS
AN AERIAL CEASING TO PROPOSAL
MAKES CALL CENTERS EVEN MORE
EFFICIENT BY ESTABLISHING A SET
RATIO. FOR CALLS PRIDGEN BASED
ON THOSE CALLS AND DRIVING AND
DRIVING ESTIMATES SEVEN MILLION
OF FEATURES FOR THEIR SAVINGS
COMPARED THE ACTUAL COSTS.
THE BULLS ARE RE DIRECTS THESE
RESOURCES AN OFFSET THE OVERALL
COST OF THE MUZZLE IN A CALL
CENTER THAT FALLS BELOW THOSE
BEST PRACTICE METRICS WE NEED TO
REDUCE STAFFING AND STREAMLINE
OPERATIONS OR FALL IN LINE WITH
THE RATIO.
I CAN REPORT THAT TO DATE
OUTSIDE THE CALL CENTER PROPOSAL
WE HAVE NOT IDENTIFIED ANY FOR
POLLS OR OR EFFICIENCIES THAT
WOULD HAVE SAVED WOULD SAVE
SIGNIFICANT COSTS.
IN THE MAGNITUDE OF THE TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT THIS
RIPPLES IS TALKING ABOUT.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE CASE
WORKERS IN THE CASE RATIOS ARE
PROPOSAL?
THE RACES THAT WE PROPOSE OR
WHAT WE BELIEVE IS NECESSARY FOR
CASE WORKERS TO REACH OUT
PROACTIVELY. TO CUSTOMERS AND
WORK WITH HIM CLARITY TO ACHIEVE
POSITIVE OUTCOMES IN THE CASES
AND OBTAIN FUNDING THIS SIR.
SO IN ADDITION THAT WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE FINAL RULE AND
EVERYTHING IN THE FINAL RULE IS
TALKING ABOUT GETTING AWAY FROM
TECHNOLOGY IN INCREASING OUR
INVOLVEMENT ON A ON A CASE BY
CASE BASIS WITH OUR CONSTITUENTS.
SINCE OUR IN THE BUDGET
METHODOLOGY IDENTIFIES AN
APPROPRIATE LEVEL RESOURCES AND
STANDARD OF SERVICE FOR THE
FAMILIES.
COUNTY IS CURRENTLY FUNDED ABOVE
THE TWENTY ONE AND FINING
COUNTIES YIELD HIGHER
PERFORMANCE BRING IN THE LOWER
TWENTY ONE FUNNY COUNTIES TO
PARITY IS EXPECTED TO YIELD
SIMILAR RESULTS.
REALLOCATING FUNDING FROM THE
OTHER COUNTIES COULD LEAD TO
STAFFING RATIOS -- REDUCTIONS IN
THOSE COUNTIES WHICH WE THINK
WILL NEGATIVELY IMPACT OUR
OVERALL COLLECTIONS ACROSS THE
STATE.
DEPARTMENT'S PROPOSAL SEEKS TO
CREATE EQUITY AMONGST ALL THE
COUNTIES WELL RESPECTED THE
FLEXIBILITY OF THE LOCALLY
OPERATED PROGRAMS TO RUN THE
PROGRAMS THANK YOU.
THANK QUESTIONS -- ALEJO.
AS A THE DEPARTMENT MENTIONED
THERE HAS BEEN A LONG STANDING
ISSUE WITH FUNDING WHEN IT COMES
TO LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES
IN THIS ISSUE DID COME UP LAST
YEAR AND THE LEGISLATURE SHARED
A SIMILAR CONCERN.
THAT THE CURRENT FUNDING
METHODOLOGY ISN'T NECESSARILY
BASED ON ANY POLICY RATIONALE OR
ANY STATE OBJECTIVE -- DOES
FOLLOWING THOSE CONVERSATIONS
THE LEGISLATURE DID PROVIDE AN
AUGMENTATION TO FUNDING OF THREE
MILLION GENERAL FUND BUT ALSO
REQUIRED THE ADMINISTRATION.
IN COLLABORATION WITH LOCAL
CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES TO TAKE
OF RE LOOK AT THE PROGRAM REALLY
INVESTIGATE SERVICE DELIVERY
PROGRAM STRUCTURE AND IDENTIFY
ANY POSSIBLE OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCIES.
BE IT -- COST OF FOR COST
EFFECTIVENESS OR JUST OVERALL --
EFFICIENCIES OF PROGRAM SERVICE
DELIVERY -- THAT SPECIFIC REPORT
ISN'T DUE UNTIL JULY FIRST
TWENTY NINETEEN OF THIS YEAR --
WITH REGARDS TO THE PROPOSED NEW
BUDGETING METHODOLOGY OUR OFFICE
DID -- CONDUCT AN ANALYSIS AND
ULTIMATELY WE FOUND THAT IT IS
PREMATURE AND RAISES A NUMBER OF
POLICY QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS.
THE PRE MATURITY OF THE PROPOSAL
IS TWO PRONGED AS THE DEPARTMENT
MENTIONED -- WITHIN THE PAST FEW
YEARS WE DID RECEIVE FEDERAL
GUIDANCE BUT REALLY TASKS STATES
TOTE RELOOK AT TELL THEIR
PROGRAMS OPERATE -- FOR THE
PURPOSES OF ABILITY TO PAY
HAVING ORDERS -- REFLECT ABILITY
TO PAY BUT ALSO THESE BROADER
POLICY CONVERSATIONS AROUND --
PRESUMED AND COME ARE HOW WE
ESTABLISH ORDERS -- ARE ARE
PREMATURE AT THE END TO THE
EXTENT -- DEPENDING ON HOW WE
APPROACH THOSE -- GUIDANCE THAT
COULD AFFECT NOT ONLY SERVICE
DELIVERY BUT ALSO WORKLOAD IN
ACROSS LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT
AGENCIES -- BUT THE MAIN GUY --
POINT OF FREE MATURITY REALLY
HAS TO DO WITH THIS MORE
IMMEDIATE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTED
TO REALLY LOOK AT OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCIES AND THE REASON WHY
THAT MATTERS IS -- WERE FOR
WHATEVER OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCIES ARE IDENTIFIED SOME
OF WHICH I AM WE IDENTIFIED SOME
IN OUR REPORT.
THAT COULD HAVE IMPLICATIONS NOT
ONLY ON HOW SERVICES ARE
DELIVERED BUT ALSO THE
ASSOCIATED WORKLOAD ACROSS LOCAL
CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES WE COULD
SEE AN INCREASE IN WORKLOAD
RELATIVE TODAY OR DECREASE AND
WORKLOAD -- BUT UNTIL THAT WORK%
HAS BEEN DONE ND WE GET A
BETTER SENSE OF THE NET IMPACT
BUT IT WOULD HAVE ON THE PROGRAM --
IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT TO THEN
PROPOSE A NEW BUDGETING
METHODOLOGY AND ATTACHED WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE REPORTING
REQUIREMENT WAS.
ONCE WE IDENTIFY THE OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCIES WAS TO THEN
IDENTIFY BUDGET REFINEMENTS THAT
WOULD BE NEEDED TO ADDRESS THE
NET IMPACT THOSE WOULD HOP ON
THE PROGRAM AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT.
IS MISSING FROM THE PROPOSAL --
THE OTHER POINT SETTING THAT
ASIDE THE PRE MATURITY THE
PROPOSAL WE DID IDENTIFY NUMBER
OF POLICY QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS
SOME OF THEM RELATED -- TO THE
ASSUMPTION THAT FUNDING WOULD
RESULT IN IMPROVED PERFORMANCE --
NOT ADDRESSING THE NURSES THE
TRADE OFFS -- ASSOCIATED WITH
LOOKING AT FINDING AMONGST THOSE
ELSE -- LOCAL TRANSPORT AGENCIES
THAT WERE IDENTIFIED AS HAVING
MORE FUNDING THAN IS NEEDED TO
OPERATE THE PROGRAM AND
EVALUATING -- WHAT A
REALLOCATION WOULD LOOK LIKE IN
THE TRADEOFFS ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT BUT ALSO OTHER MORE
TECHNICAL ASPECTS OF THE
PROPOSAL WHICH WERE HAPPY TO GO
INTO IN MORE DETAIL IF NEEDED --
BUT BECAUSE OF THE PRE MATURITY
IN THESE POLICY QUESTIONS OUR
RECOMMENDATION WAS TO WITHHOLD
ACTION UNTIL MORE WORK IS DONE --
SPECIFICALLY ON ADDRESSING THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTIVE OF
OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCIES AND
THEN DETERMINING HOW DOES THAT
AFFECT FUNDING LEVELS.
NOT ONLY THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THAT'S NEEDED BUT ALSO
THE ALLOCATION OF ABOUT FUNDING
ACROSS ALL CSAA'S -- THE BUDGET
PROPOSALS MAINLY BASED OFF OF
CURRENT PRACTICES BUT IN LIGHT
OF OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCIES ARE
EVER WE DID DECIDE TO APPROACH
THE FEDERAL GUIDANCE.
ON THAT COULD CHANGE THE
OPERATION OF THE PROGRAM BUT
THEN ALSO WHICH LC ESSAYS ARE
IDENTIFIED AS REQUIRING MORE
RESOURCES -- HOWEVER AGAIN WE
DID ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE CURRENT
FUNDING STRUCTURE IS OF CONCERN
SEN ARE -- REPORT WE DID MENTION
SUMMER TO LAST YEAR HOW THE
LEGISLATURE WAS CONCERNED ABOUT
THIS YOU COULD TAKE A SIMILAR
APPROACH OF PROVIDING STOP GAP
FUNDING IN THE INTERIM.
UNTIL THESE BROADER POLICY
QUESTIONS ARE DRESSED -- ONE
OPTION THAT WE PRESENTED IN THE
REPORT WAS JUST A A REGULAR
INFLATION ADJUSTMENT TO THE
STATE FUNDING THAT'S PROVIDED TO
ALL ALL CSA'S -- BUT THERE ARE
ALSO OTHER OPTIONS AS WELL I'M
SO HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU -- FINANCE -- YES I'D
LIKE TO NOTE THAT THIS PROPOSALS
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S EARLY
CHILDHOOD BUDGET PACKAGE WHICH
IS ONE OF HIS PRIORITIES AND
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSES.
EASING FINANCIAL PRESSURES ON
PARENTS SO THAT THEY CAN ESCAPE
THE CYCLE OF POVERTY AND FOCUS
ON THE HEALTHY DEVELOPMENT OF
THEIR CHILDREN.
AND WE VIEW THIS AS AN
INVESTMENT TO CREATE A MORE
EQUITABLE FUNDING DISTRIBUTION
ACROSS ALL COUNTIES AND REDUCE
GEOGRAPHIC AND DEMOGRAPHIC
DISPARITIES IN FUNDING.
AND AFTER FULL IMPLEMENTATION
INCREASE COLLECTIONS RESULTING
FROM THIS INVESTMENT WILL
DIRECTLY BENEFIT FAMILIES.
PARTICULARLY LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS A TEND TO BE
CONCENTRATED IN THE TWENTY ONE
LC ESSAYS THAT WILL RECEIVE.
THE FUNDING AUGMENTATION --
ACTUALLY [inaudible]
SENSING.
IS THERE A REPRESENTED THE CHILD
SUPPORT DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
HERE -- TWELVE DAYS -- TAKE.
ONE WILL BE A SPOKESPERSON --
DIVIDE COMING UP TO THE TABLE.
I THINK YOU SHOULD BE PART OF
THE DISCUSSION.
BUT WE HAVE A QUESTION PERIOD.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT.
THE SUN ORDERS THE OFFER THE
REQUESTED.
OKAY THANK THANK YOU FOR BEING
UP HERE -- IN.
THE RIGHTS TWENTY ASK ONE
QUESTION BEFORE KNOW ALL OF THAT
AND THEN AT AND SO -- IN THE
JUST CLARIFIED IN THE PROPOSAL
BEING PRESENTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION -- CAN YOU JUST
MAYBE SPEAK TO THE HOW INVOLVED
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
WERE IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF THESE
NEW STANDARDS ARE FOR THIS
PROPOSAL.
SO IT'S READ MEAN EMMA.
YES AND ACTUALLY FUTURE USES OF
FOR THE RECORD SEVEN FIRST NAME
IS PHYLLIS NANCE I AM THE
DIRECTOR.
OF ALAMEDA COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CHILD SUPPORT
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION --
DISSOCIATION WORKED --
COOPERATIVELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT IN TERMS OF CREATING
A WORK GROUP OF COUNTIES.
OF DIVERSITY OF COUNTIES AND
ACTUALLY WORKED ON THIS PROPOSAL.
WE PATTERN ARE A STUDY IN OUR
EFFORT -- WITH OTHER SOCIAL
SERVICES STUDIES AND WE WORKED
TO DETERMINE.
THE FUNDING LEVELS.
FOR THE PROGRAM OKAY SO THIS
THIS PROPOSAL AS A RESULT OF
ACTUALLY DISCUSSIONS BETWEEN
BOTH THE COUNTY AND
ADMINISTRATION AND AND JUST ONE
OTHER QUESTION FOR
ADMINISTRATION -- WHAT'S THE
STATUS THE REPORT WE SHOULD
ANTICIPATE THE REPORT THAT I WAS
REFERRED TO BY THAT THE THAT THE
DEADLINE SOMEWHERE THAT REPORT
WE HAVE ALSO BEEN WORKING HAND
IN HAND WITH A CHANCE FOR
TRACTORS SO STATION IDENTIFY
THOSE EFFICIENCIES INTO PLAN
HAVE THAT REPORT AND BY JULY
FIRST.
OKAY I THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
SEARCH ENGINE ANY QUESTION
TWENTY SURE WE GOT THIS FAX
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I'M
I'M SORRY -- I WAS LATE I HAD A
COUPLE OF EMERGENCIES OF AND
TAKE CARE OF SO I'M I'M SORRY I
IF I A MISSED SOME IMPORTANT
PARTS OF THE PRESENTATION -- BUT
EVERY MYSTIFIED INSURER -- SOME
MY CONCERNS AND APPRECIATE THE
THE GOVERNOR'S GOALS I THINK --
LAUDABLE -- BUT THE THE IS THIS
A CASE WHERE THE STATE IS JUST
YOU KNOW THROWING MORE MONEY AT
A PROBLEM THAT IS -- NOT --
CLEARLY -- IDENTIFIED AS TO HOW
WE'RE GOING TO RETURN OUR GOALS --
CALIFORNIA RANKS LAST IN THE
NATION IN COST EFFECTIVENESS AS
FAR AS ADMINISTRATIVE CHILD
SUPPORT PROGRAM.
SO I THINK BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE SPENDS ANOTHER SIXTY
MILLION BUCKS ON THE PROGRAM I
THINK WE SHOULD LOOK AT ALL WAYS
TO STREAMLINE.
AND HEAVY FISSION OPERATIONAL
EXPENSES SO. FOR THE DEPARTMENT --
WHAT IDEAS HAVE YOU SHARED IF
YOU HAVE ALREADY OR DO YOU HAVE?
THAT WILL STREAMLINE OPERATIONAL
DEFICIENCIES AND IMPROVE THE
pPROGRAM.
AND CAN THE DEPARTMENT TELL US
WHAT KIND OF RECOMMENDATIONS WE
MIGHT SEE IN THE CHART REPORT --
I DID TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE EFFICIENCIES THAT ARE THAT
ARE IN THE WORKS OF THE THE
PRIMARY FISSIONS IF THEY WERE
ABLE TO FIND AT THE LOCAL
CHANNELS FOR AGENCIES AS WITH
THE RATE WITH REGARD TO THE CALL
CENTERS AND HOW WE ORGANIZE
THOSE WE'VE STARTED CONSOLIDATE.
THOSE DOWN -- TO PRESERVATION
SEES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IT'S
REALLY CASE MANAGEMENT AND SO
IT'S ABOT THE RATIO AND DYNAMIC
OF THE NUMBER OF CASE WORKERS TO
THE CASES -- EFFICIENCIES IN THE
OVERALL PROGRAM ARE GOING TO
HAPPEN IN STATE POLICY AND WITH
OUR CHILD SUPPORT ENFORCEMENT
SYSTEM ON A STATEWIDE BASIS AND
THAT'S RUN UP AT THE STATE --
BUT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND AND I'VE
HAD MY EXPERIENCE AND AS THE
DIRECTOR OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY IN
UNDERSTANDING KIND THAT
CHALLENGE OF OF CASE WORKERS
WHEN YOU GOT.
FAR MORE CASES THAT YOU CAN GET.
TO HOME WE WERE LEFT WITH THE IT
WITH THE NEED TO SHIP CASES TO
OTHER PLACES BECAUSE WE JUST
COULDN'T HANDLE -- TOUCHING
THOSE CASES AND THOSE OF THE
COUNTIES WERE ABLE TO BRING THEM
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE COLLECTIONS
I CASES WE JUST COULDN'T GET TO
YOU.
SO WHEN IT GETS DOWN TO THE LINE
LEVEL IT'S REALLY ABOUT THE
NUMBER OF BODIES WE HAVE WORKING
WITH THESE CONSTITUENTS TO HELP
THEM GET BACK UP ON THEIR FATE
FEE AND DELIVER THE COLLECTIONS.
SO WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
EFFICIENCY THE LOCAL WE HAVE NOT
IDENTIFIED ANY OTHER MAJOR
EFFICIENCIES THAT ARE GONNA MAKE
UP DEFICIT LIKE THIS.
AND THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT IN
THIS PROPOSAL SO WOULD YOU --
OPINED THAT THE CASE LOADS FOR
OUR OUR WONDERFUL CHAMPIONS IN
THE COUNTIES THAT ARE TRYING.
TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIVES
HERE -- WOULD YOU SAY THE
CASELOADS IN IN CALIFORNIA ARE
MUCH HIGHER FOR EACH -- EMPLOYEE
THIS HELPING CAN IN COMPARISON
TO OTHER STATES OF OUR OF OUR
SIZE TAXES -- NEW YORK.
I WOULDN'T SAY THE CASE THOSE
ARE NECESSARY HIGHER OR LOWER IT
DEPENDS ON THE STAGE TALKING
HAVE -- SOME COUNTIES THAT ARE --
HIGHER AND COST EFFICIENCIES ARE
STATE RUN AND NOT LOCALLY
OPERATED AND THE VALUE OF HAVING
A LOCALLY OPERATED PROGRAM HERE
IN CALIFORNIA IS THE TWO POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN THE HAND
IN HAND -- CONNECTION THAT WE
HAVE IN IN THE CHALLENGES WE
ENGAGE IN AND TRYING -- TO
TAILOR OUR SERVICES TO THE
CONSTITUENTS ABOUT RESPECTIVE
COUNTY -- SO THAT THAT'S A
DIFFERENT A FUNDAMENTAL
DIFFERENCE IN THE PROGRAM
ANOTHER FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE
IN OUR STATE COMPARED TO OTHER
STATES IS THAT JUDICIAL VERSES
ADMINISTRATIVE APPROACH -- A WE
HAVE A JUDICIAL BASE SYSTEM HERE
AND THEN INCREASES SOME OF THE
COSTS THAT GO ALONG WITH THE
PROGRAM.
BUT THOSE ARE FUNDAMENTAL
CALIFORNIA LIKE LEGISLATIVE
KINDS OF DISCUSSIONS AND NOT
EFFICIENCIES THAT WE CAN ADDRESS
AT THE LCS A LEVEL.
AND THAT MAYBE YOU ARE THE LA --
AND ADDRESS THOSE JUDICIAL
VERSES ADMINISTRATIVE --
PATHWAYS IN ADMINISTERING THE
PROGRAM THE THE BENEFITS OF ONE
OVER THE OTHER ARE WE USING THE
WRONG THE WRONG METHOD
METHODOLOGY HERE.
BECAUSE IT WAS HE LIKE AND I I
THINK I SHARE THE LA OWES
CONCERNED CITIZENS DID DOESN'T
SEEM TO BE A A CLEAR MARCHING
PLAN FORWARD TO ACCOMPLISH OUR
GOALS MAY BE CAN COMMENT ON THAT.
I THINK THE QUESTION YOU'RE
RAISING IN TERMS OF SHOULD THE
STATE INCREASE THE USE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE PRACTICES TO
ESTABLISH OUR OPERATE THE
PROGRAM THAT'S ONE OF THE TYPE
OF OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCIES THAT
WE SUGGESTED THE LEGISLATURE.
FLAK FOR THE ADMINISTRATION TO
LOOK INTO -- FOR THEIR JULY
FIRST REPORT -- IT DEFINITELY.
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE ARE CURRENT ADMINISTRATIVE
PRACTICES THAT ARE HAPPENING ONE
WAY IS -- A LOT OF L. C. ESSAYS
ARE DOING UP FRONT WORK TO TRY --
TO ESTABLISH A PRE COURT
AGREEMENT AMONGST CUSTODIAL
NONCUSTODIAL PARENTS IN THOSE
ARE CALLED STIPULATED ORDERS --
THAT REDUCES THEN THE NEED OF
CUSTODIAL NONCUSTODIAL PARENTS
POTENTIALLY TO THEN BE INVOLVED
IN THE JUDICIAL PROCESS -- AND
IT COULD -- THEN POSSIBLY REDUCE
THE NEED OF STAFF BEING INVOLVED
IN THAT PROCESS THAT OPERATES
DIFFERENTLY BECAUSE AGAIN IT IT
IS A RELATIONSHIP WITH LOCAL
COURTS -- BUT TO THE EXTENT THAT
THAT COULD BE EXPANDED -- IT
COULD BE EMPHASIZED IT IT DOES
REQUIRE SOME FORM OF STATE
LEADERSHIP BUT THAT'S A TYPE OF
OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCY THAT WE
IDENTIFIED IN OUR REPORT.
THAT -- IT'S A NEW WAY OR A NEW
WAY OF DOING THINGS POSSIBLY
STATEWIDE AND FOR AND MAYBE IN
SOME LC ESSAYS -- BUT THEN
UNDERSTANDING THAT NET COST OVER
THE NET CHANGING CURRENT
OPERATIONS -- SOMETHING THAT
HOPEFULLY THAT JULY FIRST REPORT
THAT TYPE OF LEVEL OF
OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCIES IS
SOMETHING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
MAY.
FLAG AS SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
LOOKED INTO PROCEDURES SPONSORED
I LOOK FOR TO GET IN THE JULY --
REPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- SO A FEW QUESTIONS
AND SO FIRST OF ALL I I MEAN I I
I SIT HERE AND I AND I IS THAT
WELL BY MEMBER LAST YEAR.
I TOLD DEPARTMENT.
THEY SOLD THE DIRECTORS GET
TOGETHER AND FIGURE THIS OUT
BECAUSE WE HAD A TOTALLY
DYSFUNCTIONAL WAY OF
DISTRIBUTING THE FUNDS WE HAD.
COUNTIES RICHMOND CENTER FUND
SURE THERE'S SOME COUNTIES DON'T
SAY THEY'RE OVER FUNDED BUT I
GET A BIT MORE.
AND THEY SAID WE WE NEED TO
FIGURE THIS OUT -- AND IT'S BEEN
GOING ON FOR WAY TOO LONG.
SO AND I ACTUALLY FIRST OF ALL I
HAVE TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
ACTUALLY DOING WHAT.
I WHAT I ASKED -- WHICH IS GET
TOGETHER FIGURE THIS OUT AND
LET'S TRY TO COME UP WITH A MORE
EQUITABLE WAY OF DOING THINGS
NOW IS THE PERFECT.
AND ART OF PERHAPS MORE
INFORMATION WE NEED TO GET --
NOW I'M SURE IS CA MORE DATA
THEY'LL HELP REFINE FUTURE BUT I
I EIGHT AND AND AND I THINK THE
ONLY A RAISES SOME SOME GOOD
QUESTIONS -- BUT BUT I DO HAVE
TO SAY IS THAT WHAT WILL -- I
DON'T WANT TO DO IS LEAVE THE
OLD SYSTEM IN PLACE.
ALL RIGHT THAT'S BEEN AROUND HOW
HOW MANY YEARS NOW AND A GATES
TWO DECADES RIGHT WHICH REALLY I
MEAN.
SO SO AT REALIZE THERE MAY BE
SOME STILL SOME QUESTIONS HE
FIGURED OUT -- BUT AND FRANKLY I
WONDERED TO WHAT DEGREE IS OUR
QUOTE INEFFICIENCY RELATE TO THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY --
WHAT PORTION OF OUR STATE
BECAUSE THE IF YOU HAD ALL THE
PEOPLE IN THAT IS COUNTY HIS
ALTOGETHER?
YEAH THAT 70% OF OUR CASELOAD
RESIDES IN THESE TWENTY ONE
CALIBRATE THE SO SO SO BASICALLY
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT WE HAVE.
BECAUSE WE DO IT AND THERE'S
DIFFERENT REASONS WHY WE HAVE
COUNT YET WE HAVE WITH MR
THROUGH THE COUNTIES BUT
BASICALLY HAVE A GOOD CHUNK OF
THE STATE.
THAT IS UNDER FUNDED AND
THEREFORE NOT ABLE TO ACHIEVE
CERTAIN LEVELS EFFICIENCY OR
SCALE -- AND AND SO MAYBE THAT
THEY'LL IT WE WE THINK ABOUT
LIKE WHAT'S THE RETURN ON THE
INVESTMENT -- THAT -- THAT WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY
IMPROVE EFFICIENCY SIMPLY BY.
GETTING.
EVERYONE -- NOT JUST PART OF THE
STATE BUT THE ENTIRE STATE UP TO
A TO TO TO A POINT WHERE WE CAN
ACTUALLY -- MORE EFFICIENTLY GET
THE WORK DONE.
I'M SURE THERE ARE PROCESSES WE
CAN IMPROVE AS WELL -- AND IN A
KNOW YOU'VE TALKED AND THAT'S
WHY I WANT YOU UP HERE BECAUSE I
THINK THIS REALLY IS A
COLLABORATION AND WE NEED TO
TALK ABOUT HOW THIS COMES
TOGETHER.
SO AND WE DO THERE IS A REPORT
THAT SHOULD BE COMING OUT AND
AND I GUESS IT'S NOW APRIL RIGHT
SO MAY JUNE.
COUPLE COUPLE MONTHS -- AND NICE
THAT AND I SENATOR AGENCIES
PRODUCING THE REPORT.
OKAY SO THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
PRODUCING REPORT AND HAVE THAT
HAVE THAT THEY'VE BEEN WALLED
OFF FROM THE REST OF THE
DEPARTMENT OR THEY'VE SORT OF
FED BACK INFORMATION TO OTHER
PEOPLE IN THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
ONGOING DISCUSSIONS AND
DEVELOPMENT.
PROPOSAL WE'VE BEEN MOVING THAT
THAT CONVERSATION ACROSS BOTH
THE DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS WITH
THE LOCAL TOWN OKAY AGENCIES AND
WRITE A DIFFERENT VENUES OKAY SO
THEN THE THE THE THE
INVESTIGATION THAT THERE.
THE DATA COLLECTING AND PUTTING
TOGETHER AND ANALYZING TO HELP
FINALLY PRODUCE THAT REPORT.
WAS ALSO MEANS NOT COMPLETE WE
DON'T KNOW THEY MAY HAVE SOME
MORE STUFF THEY DISCOVER THE
NEXT COUPLE MONTHS BUT WAS ALSO
PART OF THE PROCESS AND HELPING
DEVELOP THIS PROPOSAL.
IS THAT CORRECT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT -- SO I MEAN IT'S
THAT.
SO I MADE A THINK.
YOU KNOW I I AND I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO ANSWER THE QUESTIONS
THAT.
THAT YOU RAISING AT THE LA OWES
RAISING I THINK THERE'S
ADJUSTMENTS WE NEED MAY
EFFECTIVELY MOVED TO YELL OKAY
WE WANT THIS TO A MORE
ADMINISTRATIVE.
I'M NOT SURE HOW.
SOME OF THOSE DECISIONS --
EFFORTS THAT GO DOWN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS HAVE
HAPPENED IN THE PAST AND THEY
HAVE NOT GONE RIGHT SO IT MAY BE
REFRESHING LOOK AT THOSE MIGHT
AN OPTION BUT YEAH WELL I I
GUESS WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THAT I
DON'T SEE YOUR PROPOSALS.
PREVENTING THAT FROM US FROM
DOING THAT THE FUTURE IF THAT
TURNS OUT THAT'S WHERE WE WANT
TO GO AND OBVIOUSLY.
THERE'S OTHER DISCUSSIONS THAT
NEED TO HAPPEN SO SO I GUESS
PART OF ME.
IS SAYING THAT I APPRECIATE THE
SUGGESTION WHAT WE CAN DO IS WE
CAN JUST DO ANOTHER AUGMENTATION
ADDED INSULATION ADJUSTER BUT
NOT ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT SOMETHING
AT THIS POINT -- BUT WHAT I SEE
HERE IS IS THAT.
THINGS WERE SO BAD FOR TWO
DECADES.
I I DON'T SEE HOW AND AND AND I
AND A GOOD TO GET THE IDEA THAT
OKAY WHAT HAPPENS NOW WE HAVE A
PROPOSAL THAT WERE OUT THERE.
COUNTY AGENCIES WILL BE MAKING
CERTAIN DECISIONS BASED ON THE
MAKING CERTAIN HIRING DECISIONS
CELLS ARE CERTAIN STAFFING
DECISIONS BUT BUT I ALSO THINK
THE PROPOSAL'S.
SEEM LIKE A AGAIN I HAVEN'T I'LL
WAIT TO SEE WHAT THE REPORT IS
NOW I THINK OUR FORM THAT I
THINK WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MAKING
ADJUSTMENTS TO THAT AND NOT THAT --
THE REPORT'S GONNA COME OUT AND
WHOLESALE WOW THIS WHOLE
PROPOSAL.
DOESN'T WORK AND WE HAVE TO
REBUILD THIS THING FROM SCRATCH
AGAIN.
IS -- SO I I JUST.
THEN I'D THAT'S WHY LAST YEAR
SAID GET TOGETHER AND FIGURE
THIS OUT AND ACTUALLY APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT GOT TOGETHER YOU
FIGURED OUT YOU HERE BEFORE ME
SAYING THIS IS WHAT WE FIGURED
OUT TOGETHER.
RIGHT AND WE HAD THAT YOU KNOW
HOW THE CONVERSATION AND AND
INSTEAD OF SAYING WHAT WE GOT
AWAY FROM CELLS ARE YOU.
KELLY FOR THE REPORT BEFORE YOU
DO ANYTHING I I LIKE THE FACT
THAT WE'RE MOVING FOR THAT WERE
MOVING FORWARD AND THAT THEY
THESE CONVERSATIONS HAVE THAT
HAPPEN -- BECAUSE IT AT LEAST I
DON'T SEE THIS PROPOSAL IS LET'S
SAY.
I THINK THE PAST SYSTEM IS MUCH
WORSE THAN WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED
HERE EVEN IF WE HAVE TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS LATER ON THAT MAKES
SENSE.
SO SO -- BUT I DO WANT I THINK
YOU KNOW WE DO ONE WE SEE THE
REPORT AND I THINK THE ISSUES
THE LA -- IS RAISING AND WE WILL
WHAT WANT TO FOLLOW THROUGH AND
MAKE THOSE ADJUSTMENTS AND HAVE
THAT ON GOING CONVERSATION IT
RIGHT NOW SO BUT IT YOU KNOW
WHATEVER HAPPENS IN THE FINAL
BUDGET -- BUT I THAT --
HOPEFULLY -- THAT'S NOT THE END
OF THE STORY THAT'S NOT THE END
OF THE CONVERSATION -- BUT I I
DO WANT TO JUST -- EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION FOR THE FACT THAT
WE RECOGNIZE THE PROBLEM LAST
YEAR.
THERE'S A COMMITMENT BY BOTH THE
ADMINISTRATION AT TO MAKE YOUR
PROCESS OF WAS A LITTLE ROCK LE
RELUCTANCE.
BUT AND THE AND THE DIRECTORS
AND SAID COME TOGETHER FIGURE
THIS OUT LET'S STOP LET'S FIX
THIS PROBLEM -- DISTANCE
FUNCTIONAL PROBLEM.
AND YOU'RE BOTH HERE TOGETHER
SAYING WE WE HAVE WE HAVE US WE
HAVE A SOLUTION AND YOU KNOW WE
NEED TO EVALUATE IT WE NEED TO
BE SURE IT WORKS NOW WE CAN WE
GET DEFICIENCIES RIGHT.
ETCETERA -- BUT CERTAINLY WHAT
WE KNOW WHAT WE HAD FOR WASN'T
WORKING [inaudible]
RIGHT YES.
WHO AM I DO WANT TO SAY THAT IN
OUR LEVEL OF EFFORT STUDY WE
TOOK A CROSS SECTION?
OF LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES
NOT ONLY IN TERMS OF THEIR
DEMOGRAPHICS ANDTHEIR SIZE BUT
ALSO THEIR PERFORMANCE.
AND IN THAT EFFORT STUDY WE
INCLUDED THOSE CONVERSATIONS
pCOUNTIES AND MAYBE SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT THEY WERE DOING SO
THAT WE COULD -- REALIZE A
CASELOAD -- TO F. T. E. RATIO SO
PART OF OUR OUR WORK THAT WE DID
WAS TO BE.
COGNIZANT OF THE FACT THAT WE
REALLY WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE WEREN'T JUST LOOKING AT
THINGS AS THEY ARE -- IN LOOKING
AT STRICTLY BY THE NUMBERS BUT
I'M TRYING TO INCORPORATE SOME
OF THOSE PRACTICES THAT ARE
INCLUSIVE OF THE EFFICIENCIES
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE
TODAY.
ALONG WITH THAT THE DEPARTMENT
AS WELL AS THE CHILD SUPPORT
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION HAS BEEN
WORKING REALLY REALLY HARD TO
IDENTIFY THE BEST PRACTICES THE
EFFICIENCIES THAT HAVE.
BUDGETARY IMPACTS AS WELL AS
CUSTOMER IMPACTS AND I THINK WE
HAVE A REALLY GREAT RELATIONSHIP
AND THIS.
BUDGET PROPOSAL WITH THE
METHODOLOGY -- WE THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO GO FORWARD --
WITH AND WE ALSO I'M WILL NOT
PREVENT -- US FOR COMING BACK
AND AND REALLY -- COMING UPON
AGREEMENT -- IN OTHER AREAS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS MEANS IN COMMON
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
SELL ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD.
THE VOTE IS WILL CONTINUE ON AND
THEN WE'LL HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING UP
HERE THANK YOU.
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
THREE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
IMPROVE PERFORMANCE INCENTIVES.
SO THIS SAM AND THIS IS ASKING
TO CONTINUE TO SUSPEND --
PERFORMANCE IMPROVEMENT
INITIATIVES THAT WAS ESTABLISHED
A LONG LONG TIME AGO -- THIS
PROPOSAL I AM TYPICALLY WOULD
HAVE HAD SIX MILLION DOLLARS
DISTRIBUTED OUT AND AND OFTEN TO
THE TOP TEN HIGHEST PERFORMING
COUNTIES TYPICALLY THE MOST
AFFLUENT COUNTIES.
WOULD GET ALL OF THAT FUNDING SO
WE DON'T FEEL LIKE THIS
PERFORMANCE AND AN INCENTIVE
PROGRAM IS WORKING WELL AND
WE'VE GOT A A POTENTIAL AND ARE.
MUCH METHODOLOGY TO CORRECT THIS
SO IF THIS ALL WORKS OUT WILL
CONTINUE TO GET TO A POINT WHERE
REPLACE THIS WITH THE NOW.
OKAY.
YOU LA YOU COMMENTS ON THAT NO
FINANCE.
QUESTIONS ARE.
EIGHT OKAY VERY GOOD WHEN WE
MOVE ON ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FEDERAL
DEFICIT REDUCTION ACT MANDATORY
FEE INCREASE.
THIS IS A MANDATORY FEE PROVIDED --
ARE EXPECTED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SO AFTER FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS IS COLLECTED -- AND
THERE'S A FEE OF TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS AS OPPOSED ON THE
PARTICIPANTS IN OUR CASE LOAD.
THEIR INCREASING THAT TO FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS IN
COLLECTIONS WITH A THIRTY FIVE
DOLLAR FEE SO THIS IS A LIMITED
LANGUAGE TO COME INTO COMPLIANCE
WITH THE REQUIREMENTS.
EXCELLENT -- LA YOU THE COMMENTS
FINANCE.
QUESTIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS ALL
RIGHT.
THE FEDS ARE MAKING US DO IT ALL
RIGHT ISSUE NUMBER.
FIVE HUMAN SERVICES TECHNICAL
BCP VOLUNTARY PRAYER PARENTAGE
ESTABLISHMENT PROGRAM.
IN SUMMARY THIS -- PROPOSAL IS
TO I I JUST OUR WAY OF DOING
BUSINESS IN COMPLIANCE WITH AB --
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FOUR CURRENTLY
WE RUN A PATERNITY OPPORTUNITY --
PROGRAM -- WHERE ALL THE
HOSPITALS AND -- BIRTHING
CENTERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA ARE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY AND AND
ESTABLISH.
PATERNITY. FOR FATHERS THAT ARE
IN AND WEBER IS THIS EXPAND SET
OUT -- TO SAME SEX MARRIAGES AND
AND AND INCORPORATES A LOT MORE
FOLKS SO WE WANTED TO I DID --
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TO
ROLL AND ENACT THIS LEGISLATION
AND THREE YEARS I THINK WE'LL
HAVE AN UNDERSTANDING WITH THE
VOLUME IS TO SEE IF THERE'S
FURTHER AUGMENTATION IS NEEDED
OR IF WE CAN RETURN TO NORMAL
LEVELS.
OKAY THANK YOU -- ELIA INCOMES
[inaudible]
FINANCE [inaudible]
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
EXCELLENT OKAY -- AND THEN
FINALLY WE HAD TO HAVE A
PROPOSAL FOR INVESTMENTS -- SO
ACTUALLY MAKE A LITTLE ROOM AB
SHIFT OVER -- ONE AND SEE IF WE
HAVE -- ALICE LEAH FERGUSON --
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN AND JAMIE AUSTIN
TIPPING POINT TO RE BE
PRESENTING ITS REBUTTAL THIS IS --
LANGUAGE ON A CHILD SUPPORT
COLLECTIONS [inaudible]
WELCOME.
AND IF YOU CAN ACTUALLY FIRST
INTRODUCE YOURSELVES FOR THE
RECORD ESPECIALLY ON THE
MICROPHONES AND THEN -- SO IF
YOU CAN -- RESCUE.
TO BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU BIRTH
PRESENTING -- THREE MINUTES AND
THEN WE MAY HAVE QUESTIONS WE
HAVE MORE TIME TO LEVERAGE.
THANK YOU I'M JAMIE AWESOME A
TIPPING POINT.
I'M I LIVE FIGURES IN LEGAL
SERVICES OF PRISONERS OF
CHILDREN ALL OF US ARE NONE.
A CERTAIN POINT IS A GRANT
MAKING ORGANIZATION THAT FIGHTS
POVERTY THAT AREA.
NOW WE CO AUTHORED A REPORT TO
REVEAL THAT EVERY YEAR HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN LIVING IN POVERTY DO
NOT RECEIVE.
ALL OF THE CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENTS MADE BY THEIR PARENTS.
FOR LOW INCOME PARENTS MOST OF
THEIR CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS GO
TO THE GOVERNMENT TO PAY BACK
THE COST OF PUBLIC ASSISTANCE.
AND NOT TO THEIR CHILDREN.
NGUYEN NONCUSTODIAL PARENTS MOST
OF WHOM ARE LOW INCOME MEN OF
COLOR CANNOT REPAY THE COST OF
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE THEY FACE
SUSPENSION OF DRIVER'S AND
PROFESSIONAL LICENSES AND
INCARCERATION.
THESE PENALTIES ARE
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
CALIFORNIA HAS ONE OF THE
COUNTRY'S MOST STRINGENT
POLICIES.
YEAH WHEN PARENTS LOSE THEIR
LICENSES THEY CANNOT STRIVE TO
WORK AND OFTEN LOSE THE ABILITY
TO PAY CHILD SUPPORT.
BECAUSE DRIVERS LICENSE
SUSPENSION IS INEFFECTIVE
CALIFORNIA ELIMINATED THIS
PRACTICE FOR FAILING TO PAY
TRAFFIC COURT DEBT.
MORE THAN 80% OF CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES INCARCERATE FOR FAILURE
TO PAY CHILD SUPPORT THAT EVEN
WHEN THAT DEBT IS OWED TO THE
GOVERNMENT.
WHEN COURSE RATED PARENTS' DEATH
ON PUBLIC ASSISTANCE GROWS
EXPONENTIALLY?
PERRANCE LEAVING JAIL WITH HIGH
LEVELS OF DEBT ARE FAR MORE
LIKELY TO EXIT THE FORMAL
ECONOMY NOT PAY CHILD SUPPORT
REDUCE CONTACT WITH THEIR
WE SEE NO EVIDENCE THAT
INCARCERATION OF LICENSE
SUSPENSION INCREASES PAYMENT OF
CHILD SUPPORT ORDERS WE ARE
BUDGET ACTION TO END THESE
INEFFECTIVE AND HARMFUL
PRACTICES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- I WORK AT A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
THAT -- ADVOCATES AND ORGANIZES
FOR IT THE CIVIL AND HUMAN
RIGHTS OF FORMALLY INCLUDING
CRAZY PEOPLE AND THEIR FAMILIES.
WE WERE HOPING TO HAVE SOMEONE
IS DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY THE
SYSTEM COME AND TELL YOU GUYS
ABOUT HOW IT AFFECTS THEM -- BUT
DID ALL KINDS OF STRUCTURAL
BARRIERS THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO
STOMACH CURRENTLY INCARCERATED
SUMMER EACH CAR SERRATED MEANING
THAT THEIR MOVEMENT IS
RESTRICTED.
BY A ANKLE MONITOR AND SOME WERE
WORKING GRAVEYARD SHIFTS AND
COULDN'T MISS THEIR THEIR TIME
THERE -- AND SO IN PREPARING FOR
THIS I TALK TO THEM ABOUT HOW
THIS AFFECTED THEIR LIVES AND
THE ISSUES THAT THEY WERE FACING
AND IN THAT CONCERNS FELL INTO
TWO MAIN BEAMS -- ONE BEING THAT
THE CURRENT SYSTEM DIDN'T INVEST
INVEST ENOUGH IN FAMILY UNITY
AND THE OTHER THAT IT DIDN'T
INVEST ENOUGH IN PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND SO LIKE MY COLLEAGUE WAS
TALKING ABOUT.
I'M THESE SYSTEMS AT CREATE AN
ADVERSARIAL RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
THE PARENTS THAT ONE NOW FEELS
LIKE THE OTHER HAS YOU KNOW SET
THE SENT THE DA AFTER THEM AND
AS IMPLIED THAT THERE THAT THE
FATHER.
OR THE OTHER ONE FEELS LIKE
THEY'RE IN BEING CALL THE
WELFARE QUEEN OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT IN THE FALL INTO THESE
RACES TRIPS AND AND HEARD THE
FAMILY ALONG THE WAY.
AND IT'S ALWAYS THE RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE CHILD WHO NOW FEELS
LIKE THE FATHER'S NOT PROVIDING
EVEN IF HE'S PAYING INTO THE
SYSTEM THE CHILD OFTEN NEVER
KNOWS THAT IN EVERY SEIZE ANY OF
THAT MONEY -- FURTHER.
THE DISCORD BETWEEN THE PARENTS --
INCREASES THE CHANCES OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE REFUSE TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WHICH IS A
HUGE ISSUE FOR PUBLIC SAFETY --
AND AS MY COLLEAGUE WAS ALSO
TALKING ABOUT DRIVER LICENSE
SUSPENSIONS THAT INCREASES THE
CHANCE OF PEOPLE DRIVING ON A
SUSPENDED LICENSE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE.
TO AND INCREASES THE CHANCE OF
POLICE CONTACT WHICH ALSO
INCREASES THE CHANCE OF VIOLENCE --
AND FINALLY IT PUSHES PEOPLE
INTO BLACK MARKETS WHERE THEY
WON'T BE REACHED BY GARNISHMENT
AND BANK LEVY AND CAN ACTUALLY
GIVE MORE MONEY TO THE CHILD AND
THEY GET THROUGH THE SYSTEM --
AND LASTLY I THIS THIS SYSTEM --
THIS INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE FROM.
FROM SIGNING UP FOR PUBLIC
BENEFITS BECAUSE OF THESE THINGS.
OKAY THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH --
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE AGENCY.
WITH REGARD TO THE FITNESS.
IS A IN REGARD TO THE RED DAY
TODAY IT IF YOU HAVE ANY
OPINIONS YOU WISH TO EXPRESS
ABOUT THE THE THAT THAT THAT THE
PROPOSAL.
AND NOTHING SPECIFIC ON THE
COMMENTS WE DO UNDERSTAND AND
DOESN'T LOW INCOME ARE
PARTICULARLY IMPACTED --
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT COMES TO
FORSMAN ACTIONS WITHIN SHOWS PER
SYSTEM A LOT OF THESE THINGS ARE
ESTABLISHED BY STATUTE AND ARE
GOVERNED BY CERTAIN THRESHOLDS
IN OBVIOUSLY THOSE ARE SHOWS CAN
BE LOOKED AT TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS.
ABILITY TO PAY IS A KEY PIECE OF
WEATHER -- FOLKS ARE GETTING
IMPACTED BY THESE OR NOT AND
RIGHT NOW THAT'S NOT TYPICALLY A
PART OF OUR THRESHOLDS AND THE
FINAL RULE AND WE'VE WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT ACTUALLY SPEAKS TO
OUR NEED TO ADDRESS THAT MORE
CLEARLY -- AN UPCOMING --
LEGISLATION TRIPLING WHICH
THINGS LIKE THAT OKAY IN THAT
THING TO PRY BE IMPORTANT TRACK
CLARIFY WHAT'S FEDERAL
REQUIREMENT VERSUS STATE OKAY
AVAIL.
COMMENTS FINANCE COMMENTS
QUESTIONS MEMBERS OKAY.
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION AND IS THE
DEPARTMENT WILL.
IT WILL FIX WILL SEE WILL THINK
ABOUT IN A CELL THANK YOU -- ALL
RIGHT SO WE CAN TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT NOW ON IN THE SECTION SO --
ASK PEOPLE TO AND THEN A FOR
YOURSELF AND THEN FIVE WHAT --
SO IT'S FOR ALL OF THE SECTIONS
ON FOR A CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES
SO -- PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF
AND SHOWS WHAT -- YOU THINK ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU WELCOME THE
CURRENT FUNDING STRUCTURE OVER
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS HAS
CREATED INCONSISTENCY IN
AVAILABLE RESOURCES FROM COUNTY
TO COUNTY TO CARRY OUT THE
MANDATORY.
MANDATES OF THE PROGRAM WHICH
HAS SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
FAMILIES.
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AS A CASELOAD
OF MORE THAN SEVENTY THREE
THOUSAND CASES.
THE FAMILIES THAT ARE IN OUR
CASE LOAD MORE THAN 80% OF THEM
ARE CURRENTLY ON ASSISTANCE OR
FORMALLY ON ASSISTANCE.
AND IN ORDER FOR THEM TO EITHER
MAINTAIN SELF SUFFICIENCY OR
MOVE OUT OF SELF SUFFICIENCY
CHILD SUPPORT IN THIS IS AN
ESSENTIAL PART.
OF THE INCOME COMING INTO THEIR
FAMILY.
CHILD SUPPORT IS A CRITICAL TOOL
IN THE STATE'S EFFORTS TO COMBAT --
CHILD POVERTY I APPRECIATE THE
THE CONCERNS THAT WERE BROUGHT
UP ABOUT QUESTIONS THAT STILL
THAT STILL REMAIN AND AND THINGS
THAT WE CAN LOOK AT I DON'T KNOW
THAT IT PRECLUDES US. TO TO
IMPLEMENT A METHODOLOGY FROM
ADDRESSING SOME OF THOSE
CONCERNS THAT CAN THE
METHODOLOGY MAY NOT BE PERFECT
CAN BE REFINED.
I ASK FOR YOUR RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
A GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS LAURIE
CRUZ I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES WE MET
LAST YEAR WHEN WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT LOCAL AENCY FUNDING --
LET ME THANK YOU FIRST FOR THE
SUPPORT OF LAST YEAR'S --
FLASHERS FUNDING FOR THE LOCAL
AGENCIES I'M HERE ALSO TODAY
TRUE -- REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT AND
PROVIDE MY SUPPORT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT'S REQUEST FOR LOCAL
AGENCY FUNDING.
I THINK IT IS -- FOR IMPORTANT.
THAT WE NOT WEIGHED ON THE
REQUEST I DO ACKNOWLEDGE THE LA
A REPORT AND THE RIVER
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THE LA WERE
REPORT THEY DO HAVE VALUE.
BUT THEY DON'T BELIEVE THAT
WAITING AT THIS POINT WOULD HELP.
THE LOCAL AGENCY RESPONSE TO
DELIVERY OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES -- PRIMARILY BECAUSE
WERE A CHILD'S CHILD POVERTY
REDUCTION PROGRAM.
AND THE LONGER WE WAIT.
TO PUT FUNDING INTO OUR PROGRAM
SEE THE EFFECT OF THOSE MEASURES
THAT WE WOULD LKE TO PROVIDE
FOR THE FAMILIES THAT WE SERVE --
FOR SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WOULD MEAN
ABOUT THREE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR.
AND EFFECT ESSENTIALLY WHAT THAT
WILL MEAN LAW THAT WILL GIVE ME
THE ABILITY TO HIRE CASE WORKERS
TO PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES TO
PROVIDE FINANCIAL SECURITY.
AND ALSO -- TO HELP US TO IT IN
AN ACT THE MEASURES -- TO
PROVIDE COMPLIANCE WITH THE NEW
BONTA ROOM THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR PAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS NATALIE DILLON I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF THE YOLO COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES.
I'M ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF
COLUSA AND SUTTER COUNTY LOCAL
TRANSPORT AGENCIES AS THEIR
INTERIM DIRECTOR.
ALTHOUGH THESE THREE COUNTIES
ARE NOT PART OF THE TWENTY ONE
THAT WOULD RECEIVE MONEY IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BUDGET
METHODOLOGY AS DEFINED IN THAT
JOB BUDGET.
I AS THE PAST PRESIDENT FOR THE
CHILD SUPPORT DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION.
CO FACILITATED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT THE FUNDING
METHODOLOGY TASK FORCE.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY NOW TO INVEST IN THE
CALIFORNIA CHILD SUPPORT PROGRAM
WE WILL STUDY THE RESULTS OF
THIS METHODOLOGY WILL BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE REPORTS BACK.
IT IS FOR THESE REASONS THATTHE
COUNTIES OF YOLO SATTAR AND
COLUSA FULLY SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
MONEY TO THE CALIFORNIA CHILD
SUPPORT PROGRAM THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MORNING CHAIR PAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SEAN FERAL.
ON THE DIRECTOR FOR THE BUTTE
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES.
MY DEPARTMENTS HOME TO ONE OF
THE STATE CALL CENTERS AND IN
ADDITION TO OUR OWN CUSTOMERS WE
TAKE CALLS FROM NINE OTHER CHILD
SUPPORT AGENCIES WHICH A QUIZ TO
ABOUT. TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND CALLS PER MONTH.
MORE THAN MONEY RUNNING A CALL
CENTER REQUIRES SKILL AND
TRAINING AND WE'RE GLAD TO
PROVIDE THIS SERVICE TO OTHER
CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES BECAUSE
WE THINK IT HELPS TO IMPROVE OUR
PROGRAM.
ON WE ALSO DO IT BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE AND AND INEFFICIENCIES
WITHIN THE PROGRAM -- THE
PROPOSED FUNDING WOULD ALLOW FOR
MORE EFFICIENCIES LIKE THIS --
AND AND AND OTHER INNOVATION
STATEWIDE FOR THESE REASONS
BUTTE COUNTY SUPPORTS THE FUNNY
REQUEST AND PREFER YOUR TIME
TODAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
GOOD AT THE DAY MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MIGHT THE GUERRERO
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ARE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY -- CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES DEPARTMENT
APPRECIATES THE RELATIONSHIP
THAT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
ESTABLISH THIS -- PROPOSAL WITH
THE STATE AND WITH THE CHILD
SUPPORT DIRECTORS ADMINISTRATION --
WE HAVE A TWO HUNDRED AND TEN
CASES IN THE CAST IN THE PAST TO
AN URGENT CASES PER FULL TIME
EMPLOYEE AND WE HAVE ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND CHILD
SUPPORT CASES ANNUALLY
COMPRISING OF 21%.
OF THE TOTAL STATE WHY CHILD
SUPPORTCASELOAD.
I HAD -- SERGEANT DISTRIBUTE
SOME HANDOUTS ON OF WHAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY DOING IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND WE HAVE ESTABLISHED
THE OFFICE OF INNOVATION AND
CUSTOMER ENGAGEMENT THIS IS
WHERE WE HOUSE.
ALL OF OUR WORK IN BEHAVIORAL
ECONOMICS AND THIS IS A SCIENCE
WHEREBY WE ARE RE EXAMINING ALL
SIXTY FIVE PIECES OVER TURN OLY
GENERATED CORRESPONDENCE TO
INCORPORATE.
BEHAVIORAL ECONOMIC PRINCIPLES
IN ORDER TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
CUSTOMERS TO MAKE DECISIONS
ABOUT THEIR CHILD SUPPORT CASES.
SO FOR EXAMPLE THE HANDOUT THAT
YOU HAVE IS ONE OF OUR CAMPAIGNS
WHERE WE SENT A LETTER AND ABOUT
THE CHILD SUPPORT CASES ARE
PARTICULARLY THEIR LICENSE
SUSPENSIONS.
AND WE TEND TO CHANGE THE FORMAT
OF THE APPEARANCE OF THE LETTER
SO THAT HE CAN CATCH THEIR EYE --
SO WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO A YOU
KNOW IT LET YOU KNOW JUST BE ONE
TO CONTINUE TO DO THIS WORK WE
ARE DOING THIS WORK THAT THE LA
ALL HAS RECOMMENDED -- TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCIES AND STRONGER
CUSTOMER SERVICE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING TO ANYONE WITH A C.
R. U. CALIFORNIA -- HERE ON
BEHALF OF THOUSAND OF CHILD
SUPPORT WORKERS WHO COLLECT THE
FUNDS ON BEHALF OF THE STATE --
WE SUPPORT THE THE FUNDING TO
INCREASE FUNDING FOR THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS THIS IS
IMPORTANT -- FOR REASON STATED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION RELATED TO
THE CURRENT -- STAFFING
REDUCTIONS WE DO SHARE SOME OF
THE CONCERNS AS OUTLINED -- IN
THE ANALYSIS AND LOOK FOR TO
COME A CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS
ON WHAT THE APPROPRIATE
METHODOLOGY IS BILL WOULD KNOW
THAT -- WE WOULD BE SUPPORTIVE
OF THE INCLUSION OF THE HOLD
HARMLESS THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI JUSTIN GARRETT CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES I
JUST WANT TO FIRST THANK THE
CHAIR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP IN
MOVING THIS CONVERSATION FOR
LAST YEAR IN GETTING US THE PART
WE ARE NOW WITH THIS NEW
PROPOSED METHODOLOGY.
ALSO I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR THE INCLUSION OF THIS
PROPOSAL IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO COMBAT CHILDHOOD
POVERTY AND RECOGNIZING THE
VALUE THAT THIS PROGRAM BRINGS --
THE NEW METHODOLOGY IS A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT BETWEEN THE
ASSOCIATION AN APARTMENT AND IT
MAKES SENSE FOR ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES.
I THIS INCREASED INVESTMENT IN
THE PROGRAM.
WILL HELP US IMPROVE PROGRAM
PERFORMANCE AND REDUCE CHILD
POVERTY AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING BALAJI TATTOO ON
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES IN
STANISLAUS COUNTY -- I WAS HERE
LAST YEAR -- TO ADVOCATING I
JUST WANT TO SAY I MEAN SUPPORT
OF MY MY COUNTY AND I ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR THE INCLUSION OF
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
TWENTY ONE COUNTIES -- I WON'T
GO ON ABOUT HOW YOU ALREADY
RECOGNIZED THAT THE FACT THAT
CHILD SUPPORT IS A POVERTY
PREVENTION -- PROGRAM I DO WANT
TO SAY IN STANISLAUS COUNTY
SPECIFICALLY TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
CHILDREN ARE SERVED BY THE
PROGRAM.
AND OF THE FIFTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE COLLECTED LAST
YEAR ABOUT FORTY ONE MILLION
WENT DIRECTLY -- TO TO DIRECTLY
TO FAMILIES FOR THOSE FAMILIES
I'VE HEARD PERSONALLY FROM
FAMILIES THAT HAVE SAID THIS
MEANS HEALTHIER FOOD ON THE
TABLE -- MEDICAL SUPPORT THAT
THEY OTHERWISE WOULDN'T HAVE
RECEIVED AND SOME OF EVEN
MENTION SMALL SAVINGS PLANS THAT
THEY NEVER DREAMT ABOUT --
PUTTING TOGETHER FOR COLLEGE --
BUT IN ONE IN FOUR CHILDREN IN
EACH IN STANISLAUS LIVE IN
POVERTY AND I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT THERE ARE MANY MORE
FAMILIES WHO NEED THE
PROGRAMMING I COMMUNITY.
IN ADDITION TO THAT I AM ONE OF
THE MEMBERS OF THE WORK WHAT
GROUP THAT'S WORKING ON
OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCIES.
IN FACT I'M LEAVING LEADING THAT
WORK GROUP WORKING ALONGSIDE
FEET ABOUT FIFTEEN OTHER DIVERSE
COUNTIES AND THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES.
I FEEL ABOUT SIR [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING I'M SURE NORTEL TRY
HOME THE DIRECTOR OF THE MERCED
MARIPOSA REGIONAL DEPARTMENT
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES AND I'M
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF BOTH OF MY
COUNTIES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS ASK -- AB COMING FROM
MERCED COUNTY WITH A VERY HIGH
POVERTY RATE WE ARE WE ARE.
VERY FORTUNATE TO HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR A PROGRAM
AND LOOK FORWARD TO BEING ABLE
TO EXPAND OUR SERVICES SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAMBERS
KAREN LAYING ON BEHALF OF THE
FRESNO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THANK YOU THANK YOU
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THANK YOU TO DOCTOR PAN FOR
GETTING US WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
WANTED TO OBSERVER NOTES HERE IN
THE TERM NEW METHODOLOGY NOON
NEW METHODOLOGY WE WERE HERE
LAST YEAR THERE NEVER BEEN A
METHODOLOGY WAS JUST BASED ON
YOU GET WHAT YOU GOT AND IT'S
NOT EVEN WITH A CALL.
FOLLOWING THE INFLATION FACTOR
THERE'S BEEN LITERALLY NOTHING
EXCEPT FOR THE SEVERAL MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE LAST TWENTY YEARS
THAT ALL THESE DEPARTMENTS THAT
HAD.
TO MAKE WORK I AND IT'S ALSO MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT WITH THE
FEDERAL CHANGES THAT WERE
REFERENCE A FEW TIMES IT'S GOING
TO REQUIRE MORE MANUAL
INTERVENTION.
AND THE DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE
ASKING FOR MORE MONEY HAVE HAD
TO LAY EOPLE OFF AND NOT FILL
POSITIONS BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH TO DO THE WORK NOW
AND IF THERE ARE MORE MANUAL
INTERVENTIONS.
INVOLVED THEY'RE GOING TO NEED
TO HIRE NEW STAFF INTO THE
FINALLY HAVE ARRIVED IN
METHODOLOGY AFTER NINETEEN YEARS
AND THREE FAILED EFFORTS SO
PLEASE DON'T.
LET ALL OF THAT WORK THE DOCTOR
PAN SET INTO MOTION LAST YEAR GO
TO WASTE -- YES METHODOLOGIES
CAN BE REVISED THIS IS CRITICAL
AND WE ASK FOR YOU TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD.
LATER THIS YEAR WHEN YOU BECAUSE
ALL THESE ITEMS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THE CENTER
STONE POLLY -- I AM SHOWING THE
FLAG TODAY FOR KERN COUNTY I
WOULD ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THE
REMARKS SECURE ONLINE JUST MAY
LOVE THESE DIRECTORS OR IN
COUNTY SO WE REPRESENT.
REALLY WANT TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR THE PROPOSAL ON
THIS THE TWO TO ONE MATCH IS
JUST.
IT'S IT'S INCREDIBLE HOW MUCH
MONEY WE COULD PUT IT IN THE
SYSTEM RIGHT AWAY SO I WOULD
URGE THIS TO MOVE FORWARD THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
THE CORPSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ALSO SUPPORTIVE OF
THE GOVERNOR'S AUGMENTATION WE
ARE PARTICULARLY.
LOW FUNDED IN OUR COUNTY AND IT
WILL GO A LONG WAY TO HELP THE
CHILDREN WHO ARE IN POVERTY.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING AYE MELINDA SELF
THE DIRECTOR FOR THE COUNTRY
COSTA COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES -- ARE DEPRIVE
OUR DEPARTMENT PROVIDE SERVICES
FOR TWENTY SIX THOUSAND CHILDREN
IN COUNTRY COSTA COUNTY -- 73%
OF THE CUSTODIAL PARTIES ARE
EITHER RECEIVING PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE OR FORMALLY RECEIVE
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND OUR STAFFING
LEVEL HAS GONE FROM A HIGH OF
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE FULL
TIME EMPLOYEES TO A CURRENT
TODAY OF A HUNDRED AND THIRTY WE
HAVE OVER TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
CASES THAT WE MANAGE.
WITHOUT AN INCREASE IN OUR
BUDGET ALLOCATION FOR THE NEXT
STATE FISCAL YEAR -- THE CURRENT
AT THE CURRENT ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE FULL TIME EMPLOYEE
LEVEL. 91% OF MY BUDGET FUNDING
WILL BE GOING TOWARD SALARY AND
BENEFITS WHICH MEANS THAT I
CAN'T PAY THE RENT SO I WILL
HAVE TO REDUCE STAFFING. FOR THE
PAST EIGHTEEN YEARS CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY HAS BEEN KNOWN AS AN
INNOVATOR IN TECHNOLOGY AND
AUTOMATION AND WE HAVE AUTOMATED
EVERYTHING THAT WE POSSIBLY CAN
IN OUR DEPARTMENT TO BE AS
EFFICIENT AS WE CAN -- WE ARE
NOW AT AT THE PARADE WHERE ARE
WE REALLY NEED ADDITIONAL
FUNDING IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE -- THE MINIMUM OF CORD
SERVICES ALSO I ASK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
MICHELLE RECOVER BEHALF OF THE
CONTRA COSTA BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND WE JOIN C.
SECOND OTHERS IN SUPPORTING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
FUNDING TO LOCAL TRANSPORT
AGENCIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT ON GREAT WILL SEND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE CHILD
SUPPORT ASSOCIATION WHICH
REPRESENTS THE MORE THAN SEVEN
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES OF THE FORTY
NINE LC ESSAYS AND WE STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THE BUDGET ASK.
THERE HAS BEEN NO REASONABLE
METHODOLOGY SINCE PRIOR -- TO
TWO THOUSAND TWO MY YOUNGEST SON
WILL TURN TWENTY ONE LATER THIS
YEAR WITH THAT MEANS THAT HE WAS
BORN.
BEFORE THERE WAS ANY EVEN NOTION
OF A REASONABLE METHODOLOGY I
RAISED HIM TO ADULTHOOD
AND IN THAT TIME BECAME
DIVORCING PAID CHILD SUPPORT ON
HIS BEHALF TO HIS MOM.
UNDER ON REASONABLE METHODOLOGY
WE FINALLY HAVE ONE BECAUSE WE
WORKED VERY DILIGENTLY AND
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT --
AND I WOULD URGE YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT IN PUTTING THIS FORWARD
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JEAN HEARST HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ALSO
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL EIGHT ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF MY COLLEAGUES PREVIOUSLY AND
EXTEND OUR APPRECIATION TO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND TO YOU FOR
YOUR EFFORTS.
ON THIS THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
WELCOME BACK GOOD MORNING WHAT
HAPPENED I AM BACK -- I'M
PHYLLIS NANCE I AM THE DIRECTOR
OF ALAMEDA COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES AND THE
PRESIDENT.
OF THE CHILD SUPPORT DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION.
ALAMEDA COUNTY IS APPRECIATIVE
AND SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND THE MINISTRATIONS
RECOGNITION OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
CHILD SUPPORT THE CHILD SUPPORT
PLEASE IN THE LIVES OF THE
FAMILIES OF CALIFORNIA.
AS THE DIRECTOR OF ALAMEDA AND
THE PRESIDENT OF CSTA.
MY COLLEAGUES AND I WE REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
CHILD SUPPORT PROGRAM.
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY WE HAVE A
CASELOAD OF THIRTY ONE THOUSAND
AND LAST YEAR WE COLLECTED OVER
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS WITH 80%
OF THE COLLECTIONS GOING
DIRECTLY TO FAMILY SO IT IS A
DIRECT IMPACT.
THE HUMAN IMPACT OF THIS FUNDING
ISRAEL.
AND IT MAKES A DIFFERENCE IN THE
FAMILIES IN ALAMEDA COUNTY AND
IN CALIFORNIA.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
WELCOME THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FRANK MECCA EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL.
CHILD SUPPORT SYSTEM IS AN
IMPORTANT ALLY TO US IN OUR
QUEST TO FIGHT CHILDPOVERTY WE
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THE ISSUE.
OKAY THANK YOU.
RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
MEMBERS SO I WANT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR WORK -- I REALLY
DO NO I SAID WE WE NEED A
METHODOLOGY THE THE THE THE WHAT
WHAT CURRENTLY EXISTS IS DOESN'T
WORK IT'S BEEN THERE FOR WAY TOO
LONG.
WE WILL NEED TO EVALUATE IT WE
WILL NEED TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS OR
MAYBE THINGS WE HAVE TO DO THE
LEGISLATURE -- TO IF WE NEED TO
MAKE SOME CHANGES. TO TO A STATE
LAW OF THEIR IF IF WE WE CAN
COME TO AGREEMENT ABOUT OTHER
DASCHLE CHANGES BUT I THINK.
WE NEED TO TAKE THE STEP.
AND HAVE A METHODOLOGY THAN WE
CAN MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO IT AS
NECESSARY BUT WHAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE -- I THINK WE'VE HEARD FROM
EVERYONE NAY THAT PLEASE ENABLE
I THINK THE LA -- FOR THE WORK
THAT YOU DID WITH THE REPORT
BECAUSE IS ACTUALLY YOUR REPORT
THAT PROMPTED ME TO SAY LOOK WE
NEED TO FIX THIS THING RIGHT WE
NEED TO HAVE SOMETHING HAPPENED.
AND AND IT REALLY WANT TO THANK
AGAIN THE THE APARTMENT AND AND
AND THE AND THE COUNTY DIRECTORS
BECAUSE IN FAIRLY SHORT ORDER
BECAUSE THIS SYSTEM MAY EVEN I'M
QUITE A YEAR AGO IS SAID WELL.
GET TOGETHER AND NOW YOU HAVE A
PROPOSAL HERE AND AND AND AND
AND WORKING THIS OUT AND SO.
I I REALLY APPRECIATE WE WILL
HOLD THE ITEMS OPEN SO THAT'S
ISSUE NUMBER TWO FOR THE RECORD
ISSUE NUMBER TWO WE HELD OPEN.
ISSUE NUMBER THREE FOUR FIVE AND
SIX THE INVESTMENT POSTAL SO
WE'LL BE HEARING YOU KNOW DOING
THE VOTING PRICE AFTER MAY
REVISE BUT CERTAINLY -- I'M
FULLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE PROPOSAL
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION AND
DIRECTORS BECAUSE I THINK WE
NEED TO MAKE IT HAPPEN FIRST
CELL.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT THANKS FOR MUCH
[inaudible]
OKAY.
NEXT REMOVE TO HELP HIM SERVICES
AGENCY OFFICE OF SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION AND THE PART OF
SOCIAL SERVICES SO -- WE GET TO
TALK IN THIS CAN WE GET TO TALK
ABOUT COMPUTERS AND I. T..
AS A WHAT AT THEIR BIG CHANCE TO
DO IT THIS IS TODAY.
THE NERD IN A SCAN ALL THE OUT
COME OUT FOR TONIGHT.
OKAY SO MAY SOON ENOUGH FOR
FINDING OKAY.
SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE EVERYONE
[inaudible]
SOMEONE TECHNOLOGY [inaudible]
THE OKAY IS -- SOMEONE FROM.
CAL TECHNOLOGY HERE TOO I THINK
OKAY WHICH IS COMMON SET UP THE
TABLE AND I KNOW YOU'RE NOT PART
OF THE FORMAL PRESENTATION BUT
WE JUST.
I KNOW IS I KNOW IT HAS
EVERYTHING COVERED BUT WE JUST
LIKE TO THANK YOU -- SO OKAY SO --
FOR FOR THE RECORD AND IF WE
CENTER ONE INTRODUCE THEMSELVES
ON THE TABLE START OF THE AGENCY.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR PAN
SENATOR STONE MY NAME'S MATULA
AROUND THE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
WITH THE OFFICE OF SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION OKAY THANK YOU WHICH
INTRODUCE YOURSELF FOR THE
RECORD.
SEE OUR TECHNOLOGY IS GETTING
THE BEST OF ALL AND RED LIGHT.
THE SERGEANTS ALSO GOOD TURNING
IT ON SOME DAYS IT OUT MIKE ALL
RIGHT -- BRAND ENHANCER DEPUTY
DIRECTOR PROJECT MANAGEMENT
OFFICE AT DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY OKAY THANK YOU ELIA.
BRENT METZ CARRILLO.
JANIE BELL LA O. OKAY FINANCE.
JUST INCREASED BERMAN FINANCE
OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO
LET'S GO AHEAD AND BEGIN WITH AN
OVERVIEW OF THE OFFICER SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION AUTOMATION PROJECTS
AS I'D MAKE NOTE.
THAT WE HAVE AN EXCELLENT RIGHT
UP SO YOU CAN FOCUS ON SORT OF
THE IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT YOU
SEE IN THE BUDGET AND THAT THE
ANTICIPATE COMING UP IN THIS
COMING YEAR.
THANK YOU CERTAINLY SO THE
OFFICES SYSTEMS INTEGRATION IS
AN OFFICE WITHIN HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY THAT
HANDLES PROJECT MANAGEMENT
ACTIVITIES. FOR A VARIETY OF
SPONSORED DEPARTMENTS WITHIN THE
AGENCY -- WE PROVIDE PLANNING
AND PROCUREMENT SUPPORT FOR THE
SELECTION OF INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SOLUTIONS AND THEN
AFTER THAT -- PROCUREMENT PHASE --
WE ARE ENGAGED IN HELPING TO
ESTABLISH GOVERNANCE AND THEN
HELP MANAGE THE DESIGN
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF THOSE INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
SOLUTIONS AND OFTEN TIMES -- WE
ARE ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR THAN
THE ONGOING OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE OF THE SYSTEMS.
I WE CURRENTLY HAVE A LARGE
PORTFOLIO OF A MULTI PROGRAM --
PROJECTS AND ALL JUST HIT THE
HIGHLIGHTS OF EACH OF THOSE THAT
YOU HAVE OUTLINED IN THE AGENDA --
THE FIRST ONE THE APPEALS CASEMANAGEMENT SYSTEM IS A SYSTEM
THAT ENSURES DUE PROCESS. FOR
CLIENTS ACROSS A VARIETY OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS.
AND IT HELPS THE FACILITATION OF
THE ADJUDICATION OF CLAIMS FOR
THE STATE HEARINGS DIVISION.
WE HAVE ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTED
THAT SYSTEM AND IT IS IN THE
PROCESS OF BEING TRANSITION BACK
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES IN YOUR YOU'LL HEAR
ABOUT A BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL
ABOUT THAT LATER.
THE CASE MANAGEMENT INFORMATION
AND PAY ROLLING SYSTEM DOES CASE
MANAGER IN PAY ROLLING FOR THE
IN HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
PROGRAM BOTH RECIPIENTS AND
PROVIDERS -- RECENTLY WE HAD AN
EXPIRATION OF OUR VENDOR
CONTRACT THAT PROVIDES --
OPERATIONS -- FOR THAT PROJECT
WE CONDUCTED A COMPETITIVE
PROCUREMENT SELECTED A NEW
VENDOR AND FOR THE PAST YEAR
WE'VE BEEN UNDERGOING TRANSITION
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE SCHEDULED TO
COMPLETE IN APRIL.
OF TWENTY NINETEEN THE CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES CALIFORNIA
AUTOMATED RESPONSE AN ENGAGEMENT
SYSTEM.
IS AN EFFORT TO REPLACE THE
EXISTING CHILD WELFARE CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM.
UTILIZING A MODERN APPROACH TO
DELIVER MODERN FUNCTIONALITY FOR
CHILD WELFARE WORKERS.
YOU'RE ALSO GOING TO HEAR A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THAT LATER
IN THE AGENDA.
WE HAVE OUR ELECTRONIC BENEFIT
TRANSFER THAT PROJECT -- WHICH
DELIVERS BOTH -- CASH AND FOOD
ASSISTANCE TO CLIENTS.
AND ELECTRONICALLY THROUGH A
DEBIT CARD AND WE RECENTLY
TRANSITION TO A NEW VENDOR FOR
THAT SYSTEM AND THAT WAS
EFFECTIVE IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN A CLOSELY RELATED WE
HAVE OUR ELECTRONIC WOMEN'S
INFANTS AND CHILDREN MANAGEMENT
INFORMATION PROJECT AND WHAT
THAT IS.
DOING IS IT IS MODERNIZING --
THE EXISTING ERIC MARBURY
SWITCHING TO A MODERN MANAGEMENT
INFORMATION SYSTEM BECAUSE THE
CURRENT.
ONE IS NOT GOING -- TO ALLOW FOR
V. -- CONNECTION TO D. V. T.
BECAUSE WE HAVE A FEDERAL
MANDATE TO DELIVER BENEFITS LIKE
CHRONICALLY IN THE WEEK PROGRAM.
IN -- TWENTY TWENTY CURRENTLY WE
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
APPROACHING A PILOT FOR THAT
PROJECT.
AND IN MAY AND THEN THROUGH
AUGUST -- TWENTY NINETEEN TO
APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY THERE
WILL BE A TEN WAY IF.
IMPLEMENTATION -- TO ROLL THAT
OUT -- TO LOCAL AGENCIES AND
COUNTIES.
THE NEXT PROJECT IS THE
STATEWIDE AUTOMATED WELFARE
SYSTEM -- THE STATEWIDE
AUTOMATED WELFARE SYSTEM DOES
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATION AND
BENEFIT CALCULATION FOR THE MOST
OF THE MAJOR HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES.
PROGRAMS AND THAT'S CURRENTLY --
RUN BY THREE COUNTY CONSORTIA --
AND THEN YOU'RE ALSO GOING TO
HEAR ABOUT THAT LATER IN THE
JENDA IN TERMS OF MOVING FROM
pHAVE A SMALL A STATE RUN PROJECT
THAT IS THE WELFARE DATA
TRACKING IMPLEMENTATION PROJECT
THE TRACKS TIME ON AID. FOR A
VARIETY PROGRAMS.
AND THEN -- ALSO THE MEDI CAL
ELIGIBILITY DATA SYSTEM
MODERNIZATION PROJECT WHICH IS A
MODERNIZATION FOR THE SYSTEM OF
RECORD FOR MANY OF THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAMS THAT
WE'VE.
DISCUSSED THAT WITH THE OTHER
SYSTEMS HERE -- WE ARE ABOUT --
TO EMBARK ON THE FIRST PHASE WE
HAVE A SOLICITATION FOR
DEVELOPMENT VENDOR IN ORDER TO
START THAT MODERNIZATION EFFORT --
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE HAVE COMING
UP NEXT.
I'M WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON
OUR DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS --
CONTINUE TO MOVE THOSE FORWARD
CONTINUE TO KEEP THE LIGHTS ON
FOR THE MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATIONS PIECES THAT WE HAVE.
WHICH IS YOU KNOW INCLUDES NOT
ONLY KEEPING THE LIGHTS ON BUT
THEN ALSO MAKING SYSTEM CHANGES
THAT ARE REQUIRED BY BOTH POLICY
AND LAW.
OKAY THANK YOU -- COMES FROM
OHIO [inaudible]
FINANCE.
AND BEFORE WE GET TO QUESTIONS
ME -- AND I APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE -- COLLEGE CAN CAN MAYBE
CAN YOU JUST SPEAK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN --
OUR MINUTES IT DEPARTMENT A AT
FIVE TECHNOLOGY AND AND SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION REALIZING THAT YOU
KNOW YOU.
SEE A LOT OF EIGHTY PROJECTS
GOING ON AND I KNOW THAT THE
FARM TECHNOLOGY DOES A GOOD
PROVIDE SUPPORT AND ASSISTANCE
IN SOME OF OUR SITE AS WELL YEAH.
THAT'S CORRECT AND WE DO ALL
THOSE -- WITH -- THE OFFICE
SYSTEM INTEGRATION.
SO -- OUR INTERACTIONS -- CAN IT
CAN RUN THE GAMUT FROM --
ADVISORY AS WELL AS CONSULTANT --
AND WE DO THIS IN MALTA THE
MULTITUDE OF WAYS BUT SIGH AND
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY PARTNER AT
LEAST ON A MONTHLY BASIS AT THE
HIGHEST LEVELS.
OF GOING OVER THE PORTFOLIO
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE STATE
AND STATUS OF EACH -- PROJECT IS
AND GIVEN THAT GUIDANCE AS WELL
AS WHEN NECESSARY DIRECTIVE OF
HOW THE PROJECT SHOULD BE --
MOVING FORWARD FOR SUCCESS -- IN
ADDITION WE HAVE DIRECT PROJECT
OVERSIGHT OF THEREPORT WILL NON
DELEGATED IS NOW THE NEW TERM --
PROJECTS -- MUCH MANY OF THEM IN
THE OFFICE SYSTEM INTEGRATION OR
pENOUGH CRITICAL ENOUGH THAT WE
PUT IN BETTER OVERSIGHT.
SO WE HAVE STAFF THEIR ON SITE
WITH THE PROJECT MONITORING
OBSERVING REPORTING YOU CAN SEE
A REPORTS ON A WEBSITE -- AND
MANY OF THESE -- PROJECTS HAVE --
UP TO DATE REPORTING SO YOU CAN
SEE WITH THIS THE STATUS OF
THOSE PROJECTS ARE.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS REMEMBERS.
SO I'D SELL.
THE I. T. IS ONE OF THOSE AREAS
WHERE USUALLY THE ONLY NEWS HERE
ABOUT SOME THINGS DON'T GO WELL.
SO -- MAYBE THIS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE WHAT THINGS.
WELL YOU MIGHT TELL ME WHETHER
WHAT WELL OR NOT SO -- DOES THAT
AND WE'LL GET TOUCH AND SO THE
BIGGER SYSTEMS A LITTLE LATER
BUT THE EXAMPLE APPEALS CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM YOU'RE BEING
FROM DEVELOPMENT TO MAINTENANCE
OPERATION PHASE -- YES YOU ON
BUDGET ON TIME.
YES.
OKAY AND AND HELP WITH THE WHAT
WAS THE OVERALL BUDGET FOR DOING
THIS TINO OVERALL PROJECT YEAH
THE FEELS CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM.
OKAY.
HOW DO I COME UP AND
[inaudible]
HOW MUCH? EIGHT EIGHTEEN POINT
EIGHT MILLION OKAY BUT ALL RIGHT
SO -- SO I WILL I I'M NOT SURE
GO SEE ANYTHING ON THAT SECOND
AB COUNSELOR.
FEELS MAKE CASE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM A TWENTY MILLION ON
BUDGET ON TIME BUT BY SIDE THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT YEAH.
THE CAN I ALSO ADD THIS.
ON BUDGET ON TIME GREAT METRICS
FOR FOR PROJECTS ASSESS BUT
REALLY WHEN I LOOK AT A CMS IS
DELIVERING THE BUSINESS VALUE
THAT SUPPORTS THE BUSINESS
FUNCTIONS.
AND I THINK -- IF IF YOU WERE
ABLE TO SPEAK WITH THE BUSINESS
BEING SUPPORTED BY THE SYSTEM I
MEAN THAT'S THAT IS THE TRUE
MEASURE OF SUCCESS.
AND I APPRECIATE -- THAT COMMENT
ONE OF THE THINGS I SOMETIMES
ALSO ASKED WE MAKE IT
INVESTMENTS AND WE GET IT.
IS THAT ARE CAN WE PROVE --
ENGINE INCREASED EFFICIENCY BOTH
IN -- INCREASED EFFICIENCY AND
INCREASE PRODUCTIVITY OF THE
STAFF BECAUSE THAT'S IDEALLY
WHAT THIS IS GOING TO ALLOW THEM
TO DO THE GIVEN GREATER CAPACITY
TO DO THE WORK THAT WE ASK THEM
TO DO.
AND I KNOW WE HAVE -- WE
ACTUALLY HAVE SOME THE MOST
EFFICIENT STATE WORKERS IN THE
IN THE COUNTRY WITH THE LOWEST
RATIO STATE WORKERS.
TO POPULATION AND AND IN THE
COUNTRY ONE THE LOWEST -- BUT AS
WE INVEST IN I. T. AND WE PUT IN
OUR EIGHTEEN L..
MILLION -- HUNDRED MILLION FOR
SOMETHING ELSE SOME OF THE
BIGGER SYSTEMS AND SO FORTH --
THAT THAT RETURN SHOULD INVOLVED
BETTER SERVICE AND GREATER
EFFICIENCY MORE CAPACITY FOR FOR
OUR FIRM PLACER DOING ITSELF.
YEAH -- YEAH.
AND THEN -- LET'S SEE TO IT --
THE CASE MANAGER INFORMATION HEY
ROLLING SYSTEM THAT ONE IS --
CURRENTLY IN MAINTENANCE
OPERATIONS SO THAT WAS ON BUDGET
ON TIME.
YEP OKAY SEE MORE GOOD NEWS
ALRIGHT.
OKAY ONES THAT ONE'S BEEN A
PLACE FOR QUITE AWHILE YEAH IT'S
TRUE HAS A RICH HISTORY HAS A
RICH HISTORY BUT IT'S WORKING
WELL [inaudible]
SIR CAN.
IS IT OKAY ALL RIGHT OKAY BUT
CURRENT EFFORTS AT UNIV FOR
TRANSITIONING TO THE NEW VENDOR
AND CONTINUING TO PROVIDE THE
FUNCTIONALITY THAT'S BENEFICIAL
TO THE BOTH THE RECIPIENTS AND
PROVIDERS I MEAN IS YOU KNOW IT
CAN TAKE TIME AND I THAT HAS
WORKED WELL.
YEAH AND I THINK THE OTHER THING
WE'RE ACTUALLY TRYING TO MOVE
AWAY FROM THIS I CALLED BIG BANG
APPROACH WOULD BASICALLY LIKE
OKAY WE'RE GOING AND WE'RE
BUILDING THIS BIG BOOM HE MISSED
IT PROJECT RIGHT.
INSTEAD IT'S A CREATING A SYSTEM
THAT'S EVOLUTIONARY IS NOT LIKE --
WE'VE BUILT IN AND IT'S DONE AND
THEN OF COURSE IT GETS OUT OF
DATE AND HOWEVER MANY YEARS BUT
IT'S SYSTEM THAT CONSTANTLY
INVOLVES IS MODULAR AND SO FORTH
AND CAN ADD FUNCTIONALITY
OVERTIME AND I'D JUST LIKE WE
HAVE TO REBUILD IT EVERY TIME.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS TO
THAT YOU'LL HEAR YOU KNOW
CONSISTENTLY WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
RELEASES OR IMPLEMENTATION IS
THAT WE REALLY TAKE THAT TO
HEART IN TERMS OF A WAVE TO PRO.
NO GIVEN THE THE DIVERSE CITY --
FOR THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES AND
THEIR NEEDS YEAH DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE TO ROLL EVERYTHING OUT OF
THE SINGLE TIME IN A SINGLE
BLAST SO WE'RE DEFINITELY
SENSITIVE TO THAT IN TERMS OF
SUCCESS.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WELL I WON'T KEEP
ROLLING DOWN THE SYSTEMS THAT
WAY BUT BUT IT'S ONLY THEY THINK
THAT WOULD HAPPEN IT IN ANY I
REALIZE IT'S NOT EXCITING NEWS
TO SAY OH YEAH THE EIGHTY SYSTEM
WORKS -- BUT I THINK SOMETIMES
THE ONLY NEWS WE HERE'S THE ID
SYSTEM DOESN'T WORK NOT TO MEET
THERE ARE TIMES THINGS HAVE NOT
WORKED VERY WELL AND WE'VE HAD A
LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT
APPROPRIATELY BUT I DID WANT.
TO TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO POINT
OUT THAT SOMETIMES THAT ACTUALLY
THINGS DO WORK MORE OFTEN SOME
PEOPLE EXPECT WHEN HE COMES IT.
ALL RIGHT THERE'S NO OTHER
QUESTIONS -- WE'RE GONNA TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE END OF THIS
SECTION -- SO LET'S MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER -- TWO SO NOW
DIVING INTO SOME OF OUR BIGGER
SYSTEMS THE CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES CALIFORNIA -- A
RESPONSE IN ENGAGEMENT SYSTEM
UPDATE.
RIGHT PEOPLE WANT.
PEOPLE COMING UP THE TABLE TO
INTRODUCE HIMSELF TO THE RECORD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBER --
PALLY REACTING DIRECTOR
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
THANK YOU.
IT'S A GOOD IDEA TO BE.
EXACTLY GOOD MORNING I'M BECKY
STEALING A MONTH THE OFFICES
SYSTEMS INTEGRATION OKAY WELCOME
ALL RIGHT.
WE BEGIN.
OKAY OKAY.
THANK YOU FOR GIVING US SOME OF
YOUR TIME THIS AFTERNOON I'M
CURRENTLY THE PROJECT DIRECTOR
OF THE CARES PROJECT AND THAT'S
THE CHILD WELFARE -- REPLACEMENT
PROJECT WE'VE HAD A SYSTEM IN
PLACE.
FOR SINCE THE EARLY NINETIES --
AND THIS PROJECT IS DESIGNED --
TO REPLACE THAT SYSTEM WITH MORE
MODERN TECHNOLOGIES AND MORE
MODERN CAPABILITIES FOR CHILD
WELFARE WORKERS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
HAND THIS PAST YEAR WE'VE BEEN
WORKING VERY INTENSIVELY ON
IDENTIFYING AND AND IMPLEMENTING
WAYS TO IMPROVE.
OUR CAPACITY AND CAPABILITY TO
DELIVER MORE FASTER -- BUT WE'VE
ALSO BEEN ABLE TO HAVE --
SEVERAL STATEWIDE RELEASES OF
FUNCTIONALITY OF THE CARE SYSTEM --
FROM OCTOBER OF THIS PAST YEAR
TO CURRENTLY WE'VE -- BEEN ABLE
TO RELEASE OF FOUR MAJOR AREAS
OF FEATURES -- TO COUNTY WORKERS
IDENTITY MANAGEMENT IS ONE OF
THOSE FEATURES A PROVIDES FOR
THE SECURE LOG IN AND MANAGEMENT
OF USER ACCESS AND PERMISSIONS
TO THE CARE SYSTEM -- WE
IMPLEMENTED A FEATURE THAT WE
REFER TO A SNAPSHOT WHICH IS A
SEARCH CAPABILITY.
THAT -- LEVERAGES INFORMATION
FROM THE LEGACY SYSTEM AND MAKES
IT POSSIBLE FOR A WORKER TO SEE
AND ONE SIMPLE WAY --
DEMOGRAPHIC IN CASE MANAGEMENT
AND HISTORY INFORMATION.
WE'VE IMPLEMENTED THE FACILITY
SEARCH CAPABILITY WHICH IS
LINKING -- THREE LEGACY SYSTEMS
CHILD -- THE THE LEGACY CHAO
WELFARE SYSTEM AS WELL AS
FACILITY AND LICENSING
INFORMATION FROM US SYSTEMS OF
SOCIAL SERVICES MANAGES.
AND THAT GIVES THE WORKER
INFORMATION ABOUT THE FACILITIES
AND HOMES AND A CAPACITY OF
VARIOUS FACILITIES FOR CHILD
PLACEMENT SO -- THOSE TWO TOOLS --
IN -- HAVE BEEN -- REMARKABLY
WELL RECEIVED A BUYER COUNTIES.
AND THE LAST I WANTED TO MENTION
THAT WE'VE IMPLEMENTED -- EIGHTH --
FEATURE THAT WE REFER TO AS CANS
WHICH IS THE CHILD AND
pADOLESCENT NEEDS AND STRENGTHS
ASSESSMENT.
THIS IS THE FIRST OF AN
AUTOMATION EFFORT OF HELPING THE
STATE WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION.
OF AN INTEGRATED CORE PRACTICE
MODEL UNDER THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE REFORM AND THIS.
ASSESSMENT ALLOWS A CHILD
WELFARE WORKER -- TO TO WORK
THROUGH THE THE THE STANDARDIZED
QUESTIONS ABOUT -- CHILDREN AND
AND THEIR THEIR CURRENT
SITUATION AND THEN PROVIDES THAT
OPPORTUNITY IN IN THE CARE
SYSTEM. TO KEEP IT TO SEE IT
AGAIN -- TO LEVERAGE IT FOR
FUTURE REASSESSMENTS -- AND THEN --
WITH WITH MORE FUNCTIONALITY TO
COME TO ASSIST -- WITH THAT
EFFORT [inaudible]
SO -- WITH THOSE WITH THOSE
FEATURES IN KEEPING WITH THE
ENTERED OF DEPLOYMENT
[inaudible]
APPROACH WE WE CREATE THOSE
CAPABILITIES WE RELEASE THEM WE
GET FEEDBACK WE GET ADDED --
INSIDE AND WE CONTINUE TO
ENHANCE THEM AND SO -- WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL RELEASES PLAN FOR ALL
OF THOSE FEATURES IN APRIL AND
WE ALSO HAVE ADDITIONAL --
FEATURES -- PLANNED IN JULY IN
JULY IN PARTICULAR FOR CANS WILL
BE THE OPPORTUNITY -- FOR A
REASSESSMENT TO TAKE PLACE AND A
CHILD WELFARE WORKER WILL HAVE --
BE ABLE TO SEE WHAT THAT WAS
REPORTED FOR KERRY THAT
INFORMATION AND TRY TO IMPROVE
SOME FUNCTIONALITY -- SKEWS ME
EFFICIENCY AND USE OF THAT SO --
OF THOSE OF THOSE ARE ALL --
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THAT -- WERE
PLEASED WITH BUT AS I SAID WE'RE
WORKING ON IMPROVING OUR
CAPACITY AND AND CAPABILITY -- I
THINK -- WE WANTED TO MENTION I
THINK AS A RESULT OF THE
QUESTION THAT WE HAVE SPENT
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS --
TO DATE ON THIS PROJECT AND THE
BUDGET THAT'S REFLECTED IN THE
NOTES HERE OR YOU KNOW PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL DETAIL ON THAT.
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO PROCEED TO
QUESTION TWO OR DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING.
IN WHICH GOOD PROCEED WITH THE
THE OF THE CHANGE PROCESS OKAY
GOOD -- YES IT'S TRUE LAST LAST
SUMMER -- OUR PARTNER FEDERAL
PARTNERS ADMINISTRATION CHILDREN
YOUTH AND FAMILIES A SEE WHY OFF --
DID A SITE VISIT AND WE REPORT
TO THEM ON A REGULAR BASIS JUST
AS WE WORK WITH C. D. T. ON AN
ONGOING BASIS -- FOR THEIR HELP
IN AND GUIDANCE THEY'RE MANAGING
ALL THE STATES ARE DOING THESE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEMS AND SO
THEY HAVE SOME GOOD INSIDE --
AND THEY BRING SOME EXPERTISE
THAT WAS WELCOMED -- BY US
INCLUDING HOW TO OPTIMIZE YOUR
AGILE SOFTWARE DEVELOPMENT
APPROACH AND AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THEY STRONGLY
RECOMMENDED WE WE SAY DIRECTED
BUT IT WAS A WELCOME DIRECTION
AND THAT WAS -- INSTEAD OF
TRYING TO DO TOO MANY THINGS AT
ONE TIME WHICH I THINK.
IS STATE I TO PROJECTS ARE
COMPLEX AND THEIR LARGE AND WE
ALWAYS WANT TO GET THEM DONE
QUICKLY AND SO I THINK IN SOME
RESPECTS WE SAID.
LET'S HURRY UP AND GET
EVERYTHING DONE A WHILE THEY
SAID.
DO ONE THING AT A TIME AND AND
GET THAT PRACTICE DOWN IN IN A
REPEATABLE WAY ULTIMATELY TO GET
TO THE POINT OF SCALING AND THAT
THAT WAS ACTUALLY PRETTY WISE
ADVICE AND WE TOOK IT TO HEART
BECAUSE APPRECIATING THE THE THE
VERY LARGE AND COMPLEX AND AND
AS AS A MATTER.
OF PRACTICE THE DYNAMIC NATURE
OF CHILD WELFARE IT'S NOT A
LINEAR PROCESS CHILDREN.
LIVE SIR -- CHANGING ALL THE
TIME CONDITIONS ARE CHANGING ALL
THE TIME AND YOU WANT YOUR
SYSTEM. TO BE SUFFICIENTLY
ADAPTIVE AND COMPLETE TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT SO.
SO WE BEGAN TO REALIZE WE SHOULD
WORK ON THAT ONE DIGITAL SERVICE
AT A TIME GET THAT STRONG.
AND WELL DEVELOPED AND THEN
BUILD ON THAT AND WORK TOWARDS
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY.
IT'S ALSO -- DEVELOPING THE
PRACTICE -- OUR OWN CAPABILITY
TO FOLLOW THESE PRACTICES WHILE.
TOM.
THE OF THE ONE THING AT A TIME
APPROACH TO DOING THIS WE
BELIEVE WILL ACTUALLY ACCELERATE
ULTIMATELY ACCELERATE OUR
DELIVERY AND NOT TAKE LONGER
BECAUSE WHAT WE HAD FOUND IN THE
FIRST -- TWO YEARS OF OUR EFFORT
WAS THERE WAS CERTAINLY THE THE%
RISK OF HAVING DIFFERENT GROUPS
DEVELOP THINGS DIFFERENTLY AND
THEN WE END UP HAVING TO
RECONCILE THEM LATER AND
POTENTIALLY TO RE WORK SO IT
MAKES MORE SENSE. TO FOCUS ON
COMPONENTS AND SERVICES THAT ARE
HOLISTIC AND AND GET THOSE DONE
AND THEN LEVERAGE WHAT YOU DID
THERE FOR THE FUTURE THINGS SO
WE ACTUALLY WELCOME THAT
RECOMMENDATION WE THINK IT IS
THE RIGHT APPROACH -- FOR OUR
PROJECT AT THIS TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU A COMMENCEMENT
LEO.
PRIME MINISTER LA -- WE WOULD
JUST MENTION THAT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL BE
SUBMITTING -- SPECIAL PROJECT
REPORT TO ACTUALLY UPDATE THE
BASELINE COST AND SCHEDULE FOR
THIS PROJECT AND SO IT'S OUR
INTENT TO ANALYZE AND PROVIDE --
OUR COMMENTS ON THAT ONCE IT'S
AVAILABLE.
OKAY THANK YOU FINANCE QUESTIONS.
THEY TELL US WHAT TECHNOLOGY.
OF JUST THAT AGAIN WE'VE BEEN --
SIDE BY SIDE WITH THIS PROJECT
THROUGH THIS JOURNEY THEY ARE
THE DEMONSTRATION PROJECT --
I'VE BEEN HERE.
A FEW OF THESE BUDGET CYCLES IN
WHICH THIS WAS THE FIRST ONE
THAT WAS BLAZING THE TRAIL ON
TRAIN NEW METHODOLOGIES SO.
WHAT'S GREAT ABOUT IT IS THE
LESSONS LEARNED WE DON'T HAVE TO
WAIT FOR THIS PROJECT TO BE OVER
FOUR THIS FOR A CHANGE IN
DIRECTION OR TAKE THE LESSONS
LEARNED AND MODIFY SO WE CAN BE
BETTER.
BEFORE YOU YOU ACTUALLY GET TO
DONE.
AND SO IN THAT REGARD WERE.
WE WE APPRECIATE THIS REFLECTION
WE WERE WITH -- THE PROJECT WITH
A C. Y. F. WHEN ALL OF THIS
DISCOVERY WAS OCCURRING LAST
YEAR.
WE CONCEPTUALLY AGREE WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION BUT WE DO WANT TO
WORK WITH THE PROJECT TO MAKE
SURE THERE'S A A ROBUST STRATEGY.
THAT IS ARTICULATED IN THE
SPECIAL PROJECT REPORTS OF WILL
WE ARE WORKING WITH THEM THROUGH
THAT PROCESS.
THANK YOU.
I WOULD ALSO ADD THAT TIME IT IS
A CONDITION OF THIS PROJECT THAT
WE DO REGULAR REPORTING TO
LEGISLATIVE STAFF VIA A MONTHLY
REPORTS AND THEN ALSO QUARTERLY
BRIEFINGS. SEVEN IT'S NOT JUST
AT BUDGET HEARINGS THAT THIS IS
INFORMATION AVAILABLE ON THIS
PROJECT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SET ASIDE AND APPRECIATE -- YOUR
YOUR YOUR SPOTS BECAUSE I THINK
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT CAME UP
BEFORE AND I I SUPPORT THE EDGE
OUTRAGE.
BUT IT ALSO I THINK CREATED SOME
NEW CHALLENGES FOR OVERSIGHT
RIGHT.
AND SO I LIKE IT'S MY QUESTIONS
THE A -- IS BECAUSE LAST TIME
YOU KNOW YOU RAISE CONCERNS.
IN TERMS OF SO WHAT -- SO ARE WE
USE TO EVOLVING OUR PROCESSES IN
A WAY A TWO TO TO FIGURE OUT HOW
WE NEED TO THE APPROPRIATE
OVERSIGHT AND AND AN AGILE
PROCESS OR THINGS THAT.
THE USE THAT WE SHOULD BE DATA.
OTHER THINGS YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT TERMS OF HOW WE HOW WE DO
THIS OF OVERSIGHT WHILE STILL
ALLOWING -- THIS THIS -- PROCESS
TO MOVE FORWARD BECAUSE I THINK
THIS IS THE PRICE WE SHOULD
TAKEN IT IN MY OPINION.
I'M NOT THE EXPERT BUT I THINK
WE'RE HEARING FROM THAT YEAH --
BRENT METZ GIRLY I TIED -- TO BY
I APPRECIATE THE THE COMMENT I
THINK WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
TRYING TO DETERMINE HOW BEST TO
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT OF PROJECTS
THAT ARE USING THIS AGILE
APPROACH -- WE DO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT IT MAY BE HARD TO ESTABLISH
YOU KNOW AN ENTIRE PROJECT
KOSTER ENTIRE PROJECT SCHEDULE
GIVEN THAT YOU MAY NOT KNOW ALL
OF THE PIECES OF THE PROJECT.
AT THIS TIME HOWEVER WE'RE STILL
CONCERNED THAT YOU DON'T HAVE
THAT COMPLETE PORTFOLIO VIEW TO
KNOW KIND OF ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT MODULES THAT ARE PART
OF A PROJECT AS WELL AS THE COST
OF EACH OF THEM SO.
I THINK WE'RE STILL IN THE EARLY
PHASES OF TRYING TO FIGURE THIS
OUT AS WELL -- BUT WE'RE
CERTAINLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
THIS SPECIAL PROJECT REPORT AS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DID EVALUATE
HOW BEST TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
GOING FORWARD.
AND THE CERTAINLY APPRECIATED WE
GOT FIGURE OUT HOW TO HOW TO
MAKE THIS WORK.
SO I'M GONNA I AM GOING TO ASK
YOU QUESTIONS OF OVERSIGHT ISSUE
SO.
DEL PASTOR YOU USED SHAREDLISTS
THE MODULES THAT YOU'RE DOING UP
TO APRIL TWENTY NINETEEN YOU
MENTIONED THERE'S A JULY RELEASE.
BUDGET PROPOSAL YOU KNOW LAST
YEAR.
WAS NINETY NINE POINT EIGHT
MILLION FATAL FIFTY MILLION
GENERAL FUND IT'S ACTUALLY ONLY
THIRTEEN MILLION FOR THIS COMING
YEAR -- SO -- FIRED ERROR SO
BEYOND ACTUALLY WHAT'S GOING TO
BE IN THE JULY RELEASE AND WHAT
THE WHAT KIND OF AT LEAST
FUNCTIONALITIES ASIANS AND NOT
SO MUCH THE RELEASES ITS WHAT
KIND OF FUNCTIONALITY LOOKING.
TO TO TO ADD IN THE COMING YEAR
YOU MAY NOT KNOW THE MALL BUT
I'M JUST LIKE WHAT ARE YOU
PLANNING -- FOR IN TERMS OF YOUR
YOUR AS YOU SAID ONE AT A TIME
OKAY SO WHAT WHAT IT WHAT KIND
OF FUNCTIONALITIES ARE YOU
LOOKING AT TRYING TO DO FOR OUR
THIRTEEN MILLION OF GENERAL FUND
TWENTY SIX MILLION.
I'LL HAVE BECKY TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT -- THE FUNCTIONALITY
IN THE JULY RELEASE AND THEN I
CAN TOUCH LITTLE BIT ON THE ON
THE ON THE BUDGET OKAY THANK YOU --
WITH IT IN KEEPING WITH THE AT
JOE APPROACH -- WE'VE LEARNED A
AND ANOTHER MAJOR PRINCIPLE OF
THIS PROJECT IS THAT WE WOULD
USE UTILIZE USER RESEARCH AND
USER CENTERED DESIGN -- WHICH
MEANS A GREAT DEAL MORE CLOSE
WORKING RELATIONSHIP AND AND AND
SORT OF JUST IN TIME WORKING
RELATIONSHIP PARTICULARLY WITH
COUNTIES OTHER THAN THAT THE
LARGEST NUMBER OF USERS BUT BUT
IN SOME CASES SOCIAL SERVICES
STAFF AS WELL -- TO PLAN THE
NEXT THING -- AND AND TO BEGIN
TO ARTICULATE WHAT OF THOSE --
BUSINESS REQUIREMENTS NOT JUST
THE PAST ONES BUT THE FUTURE
ONES AND SO WE HAVE TEAMED UP TO
OTHER -- AREAS THAT WE HAVEN'T
SELECTED YET FOR THE NEXT THING --
AND THAT THAT.
IS IS PART OF THE ARTICULATION
OF OUR S. P. R. BUT QUITE A BIT
OUR USER CENTERED DESIGN A
RESEARCH HAS TAKEN PLACE IN THE
HOT LINE AREA WHICH IS THE
INTAKE PROCESS FOR CHILD WELFARE
CASES.
AND THE RESOURCE FAMILY --
APPLICATION PROCESS AND THAT'S A
FOR FOR PEOPLE -- TO APPLY TO BE
HOMES AND FACILITIES FOR
CHILDREN TO BE PLACED SO -- BOTH
OF THOSE ARE OUR CANDIDATES WERE
IT QUITE A BIT OF BUSINESS
REQUIREMENTS HAVE BEEN
ARTICULATED.
WE WE WANT TO DO IS HAVE ENOUGH --
DEPTH AND CLARITY ABOUT -- THOSE
REQUIREMENTS AND PARTICULARLY
THE VALUE PROPOSITION ONE OF
THOSE METRICS THAT WE'RE LOOKING
FOR TO ACHIEVE WHEN WE IMPLEMENT.
WHEN THAT WORK IS READY THEN THE
DEVELOPERS ARE READY TO GO WE
DON'T WANT TO HAVE THAT WORK
SLOWDOWN DEVELOPMENT WE SAW A
LITTLE OF THAT AT THE BEGINNING
OF OUR PROJECTS SO -- SO WE'RE
WE'RE PLEASED WITH THIS
REALIZATION WE HAVE ONE THING
WE'RE DOING NEXT THING WE DO SO
THERE'S KIND OF AN ITERATION AND
THAT WAY.
AND THEN REGARDING THE BUDGET
YOU KNOW THE LA -- POINTS OUT
CORRECTLY THAT YOU KNOW YOU
USING THIS METHOD IT'S HARD TO
YOU KNOW AT SASSON PREDICT HOW
MUCH THE TOTAL PROJECT COST IS
GOING TO BE AND AS A RESULT.
WE'VE BEEN YOU KNOW UP GETTING
APPROVAL ONE YEAR AT A TIME.
AS OPPOSED TO A TRADITIONAL AS
PR WHERE IT'S A LONGER VIEW SO
THE NUMBER THAT'S ACTUALLY IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS A
PLACEHOLDER PENDING.
AN UPDATE WITH THE SPECIAL
PROJECT REPORT AN INMATE
REVISION [inaudible]
YES HELLO -- AND I WOULD JUST
ALSO NOTE THAT WE ARE AWARE OF
THE DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY IS
ALSO KIND OF LOOKING INTO HOW
THEY'RE UPDATING OTHER PROJECTS
AS WELL THAT ARE USING NATURAL
APPROACH SO IT MIGHT BE.
USEFUL TO US THEM AS WELL OKAY
YEAH AND IT IT IS -- STILL IN
DEVELOPMENT BUT DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY THROUGH -- OUR
EXPERIENCES WITH THESE AT JOE
PROJECTS THERE'S A REALIZATION
THAT YOU CAN PROJECT OUT -- WITH
CERTAINTY ONLY SO FAR AND WE'VE
SEEN WITH ALL THE WATERFALL
PROJECTS THEY MAY GIVE YOU A
FIVE YEAR SCHEDULE ON A COST BUT
HOW MANY OF THEM HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO HOLD TO IT AGAIN THERE'S JUST
TOO MUCH UNCERTAINTY THAT FAR
OUT.
WHAT WE ARE LOOKING FOR IS MORE
OF AN ANNUAL UPDATE SO THAT --
THAT WE WE CAN SEE ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS WHAT WAS THE PLAN.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS THE ROAD MAP
THAT YOU THAT YOU THINK YOU'RE
GOING TO TO GO FORWARD WITH TO
DEVELOP THESE PRODUCTS.
AND THEN WERE ABLE TO EVALUATE
HOW DID YOU DO AGAINST THAT PLAN
FOR FOR ANOTHER TWELVE MONTHS
AND DOING THIS ON A ROLLING WAVE
TYPE OF BASIS MORE OF AN ANNUAL
UPDATE VERSES.
THE CONNOTATION THAT IT'S A
VARIANCE IN A SPECIAL PROJECT
REPORT EVERY TIME SO WE LOOKING.
TO DEVELOP THOSE PROCESSES AND
POLICIES AND WERE WERE IN FLIGHT
WITH THAT RIGHT NOW.
HEY.
YEAH I MEAN I THINK THE THE THIS
IS WHAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT --
BASICALLY ABOUT THE NEW
OVERSIGHT METHODOLOGIES --
OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENS
IS THAT WERE HERE ALLOCATING
MONEY IN THE HOUSE IT'S YOU.
THIS IS LIKE THIS HEARINGS IN
THE SHORTER TO INVEST THAT YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE PEOPLE STAND LINE
AND I HAVE PEOPLE ASKING ME.
FOR ALL ASKING THE LEGISLATURE'S
NOT ME AND JUST HEARING
SUBCOMMITTEE BUT WE HAVE
REQUESTS THAT RANGES FROM
SOMETIMES AS LOW AS HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS AND AND TELL THE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS.
AND SO WE SAY OKAY WELL WE'RE
GOING TO GIVE. THIRTEEN MILLION
FOR THIS -- I WAS THE NEXT
QUESTION IS WHAT WE GET FOR IT
RIGHT WHAT'S THE FOUR EIGHT AND
THEN YOU'RE GOING WELL WE WERE
STILL FIGURING IT OUT -- AND AND
I AM OF THE I WANT TO SAY IS I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE I'M ALWAYS
I AM REALLY HAPPY TO YEARS IT
WILL APPROACH AS WE FIRST TALKED
TO PEOPLE TO USE THE SYSTEM.
I THINK OUR BIGGEST FAILURES ARE
ONES WHERE SOMEONE SAID I'M
GONNA HIRE A SOMEONE TO DO A
TECHNOLOGY SOLUTION BUT NOT
TALKING TO PEOPLE USING IT I'D I
THINK I KNOW WHAT THEY WANT.
THE VENDORS HAPPY TO TELL YOU
WHAT THEY THINK THEY WANTED WITH
THE PEOPLE WANT THEY DID TALK TO
THEM.
AND YOU WONDER WHY DOESN'T WORK --
SO.
EIGHT DEAD ACTUALLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT IT PROJECTS NOT THE I.
T. PARTS THE PEOPLE PART THE
PEOPLE IN YOUR FACE I'D REALLY
HAPPY TO HEAR THAT.
BUT I THINK WE WE DO NEED TO
THINK ABOUT HOW -- WE GET THIS
ACCOUNTABILITY PIECE HOW SO AS
YOU MAKE YOUR DECISION AS TO
WHICH WHICH ONE YOU WANT TO GO
TO AND THEN ALSO.
THAT HOW HOW HOW TO BE SURE THAT
WE DO HAVE APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT --
ACCOUNTABILITY IN ITS IT AND AND
AND ALSO -- THERE'S A THE
THERE'S ALSO A BIT ABOUT -- YOU
KNOW OF I GUESS WE CAUGHT HELLO
WHAT THREE TERM WOULD BE.
SO OKAY NOW WE DECIDED TO USE
THIS BUT IS IS THE COST
EFFICIENCY RIGHT IS THAT WHAT
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS THAT IS
THAT IS THE REQUEST RIGHT YEAH
WE LIKE TO FISH WE OVER THE
FIRST.
WE LIKE THE FUNCTIONALITY BUT
ARE WE OVER PAYING FOR IT RIGHT
IS THIS IS THE THEM OUT WORKING.
AND AND WHAT KIND OF PROCESS WE
HAVE IN PLACE TO BE SURE THAT.
THE THE THE THE THE WORK THAT'S
BEING DONE WE'RE NOT OVERPAYING
FOR THAT AND AND BEING HAVE
HAVING CONFIDENCE OF THAT.
AS WELL.
AND THE AC DO THINK AT JOE PROP
HOPEFULLY LENDS ITSELF TO
HOPEFULLY VERY BECAUSE INSTEAD
OF HAVING A GIANT PROJECT
QUARTERS ONLY LIKE TWO OR THREE
THE AVENGERS WHO CAN ACTUALLY DO
IT -- AND SO YOU ONLY HAVE MUCH
OF A CHOICE TO SINCE YOU DIVE
INTO THE POOL -- THAT HOPEFULLY
THERE'S MORE OPPORTUNITIES WITH
WITH BY BREAKING THINGS OUT THAT
YOU ACTUALLY CAN GET MORE.
COMPANIES WERE ABLE TO DID AND
AND PARTICIPATE IN THE HAVE A
BETTER COST EFFICIENCY BUT I'D.
BUT PART OF IT IS IS THAT HOW DO
WE ENSURE THAT.
WE ARE GETTING -- HIM MAKING I
GUESS PUTTING USERS TAXPAYER
FUNDS.
AGREED AND WE WE'RE HAVE TAKEN
MANY STEPS TO TO ENSURE THAT
THAT COMPETITIVE MARKET -- FOR
THESE TYPES OF PROJECTS
INCLUDING A PRE QUALIFIED VENDOR
POOL -- AND LEVERAGE PROCUREMENT
SO THAT WE WE KNOW THERE'S MORE
TRANSPARENCY ATUALLY AND YOU
KNOW WHAT THE COST OF THE WORK
IS THAT'S BEING DONE.
AND SO WHEN WE LOOK AT THIS YOU
KNOW KIND OF AN ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS IT'S OKAY WE WE PUT CAN
PROJECT OUT WHAT THE COST IS AND
WHAT IS THAT THAT RETURN ON
INVESTMENT IS WHAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR AND WE CAN ALWAYS
MONETIZE THAT BUT IT'S THE
BUSINESS.
VALUE.
IN WITH -- WHAT ARE THE THE THE
THE VALUE PROPOSITIONS THAT THAT
A PROJECT IS PROPOSING TO
ACCOMPLISH THEY WERE ABLE TO
LOOK AT THAT AND REFLECT ON WAS
WAS THAT ACCOMPLISHED?
BEFORE WE MAKE ANOTHER
INVESTMENT.
SO I GUESS THOUGH ABOVE AS TO
SERVE WRAP UP THIS PART -- SERVE
MORE BROADLY.
IN NINETEEN FEATURES WHAT THE LA
A DANIELLE L..
I USED TO SENATE BUDGET SUB FOR
WHERE WE DO A LOT OF BIG IT
PROJECTS HERE WE'RE NOT USED TO
DEALING AS MUCH AS OF THE
HEARING WE'RE DEALING WITH A
VARIETY PROJECTS BUT I DON'T
KNOW WHETHER -- THERE'S A I WAS
A REPORT BUT SOME SIR UPDATE
FROM LA -- AND I'M NOT SURE IS
IT THAT I SPECIFICALLY THE
SUBCOMMITTEE BUT SORT OF SAYING
OKAY THIS IS OUR CURRENT STATE
AND WHAT WE SEE IN TERMS OF THE
OVERSIGHT FUNCTION WHAT'S A
LEGISLATORS FUNCTION TO BE SURE
THAT WE ARE EXCITED.
WITH THESE NEW PROCESSES FOR IT
RIGHT AND AND WHAT ARE SOME
THINGS WE SHOULD BE EXPLORING IN
TERMS OF OUR PROCESSES IN OUR
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEES AND SO
FORTH OF THE INTERFACE.
T. THAT PERHAPS -- MAYBE WE'LL
GET ENOUGH EXPERIENCE BY NEXT
BUDGET CYCLE OF LATE NEXT YEAR
TO TO HAVE SOME SOME IDEAS --
SUGGESTIONS.
MAYBE IT'S A REALLY AT BUDGET
CHAIRED QUESTIONS IN THE END IN
THE AND NOT MINE BUT I MEAN THE
THE BUT DESPITE THOSE THAT IDEA --
I THANK YOU AGAIN I THINK THIS
IS PART OF MY ADDITIONAL
STATEMENT ABOUT KIND OF WERE IN
THE EARLY STAGES OF VALUE
WAITING HOW TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
ENOUGH EFFECTIVE MANNER WITH THE
NEW PROCESSES THAT ARE UNDER WAY.
WE DID PUBLISH SOMETHING IN THIS
BUDGET CYCLE REGARDING THE
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFE CYCLE AND
ITS ALIGNMENT WITH THE BUDGET
PROCESS AS A WAY OF KIND OF STE
FIRST KIND OF GOING INTO THIS
KIND OF LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT --
PEACE AND TRYING TO UNCOVER YOU
KNOW WHAT ARE THE BEST WAYS TO
ALIGN THE EXISTING PROCESSES IN
THE NEW PROCESSES THAT ARE
COMING ONLINE -- WITH THE
EXISTING PROCESS WE HAVE WITH
THE LEGISLATURE LIKED BUDGET
PROCESS AND SO I THINK AGAIN
WERE WERE CONTINUING TO SEEM
MORE PROJECTS MOVE TOWARDS AGILE
WE'RE CONTINUING TO MONITOR THEM
TO SEE WHETHER THEY'RE YOU KNOW
MORE SUCCESSFUL THAN PRIOR
PROJECTS HAVE BEEN -- USING THE
METRICS THAT YOU KNOW WE'VE
DISCUSSED LIKE COST AND SCHEDULE
BUT CERTAINLY APPRECIATING
BUSINESS VALUE -- AND I THINK
WE'LL BE CERTAINLY INTERESTED IN
IN SOMETHING LIKE A AN UPDATE A
REPORT LATER ON ABOUT
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OF THESE
PROJECTS.
YEAH I WAS I JUST IMAGINE THAT
EACH OF US SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS
WE HAVE OUR OWN LITTLE PIECE
RIGHT WE'RE HAVING OUR PEACE
HERE TODAY SERVICES FOR WILL
HAVE THEIR P. SITES IN THE OF
SOME OF THE OTHER BUDGETS OF
COMMITTEES BUT THAT AGENCIES ARE
OVERSEEING.
AND DEPENDING IN THE ICE A LOT
OF FAITH IN BY MY FELLOW BUDGET
CHAIRS ARE PRETTY SMART PEOPLE
BUT I'D THINKING ABOUT SOME
CONSISTENCY ACROSS ALL OF US IN
TERMS DEEPER USING SOME YEAH.
SIMILAR PROCESSES AND SO FORTH.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT IF THERE'S NOTHING
ELSE ON THIS THEN LET'S MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE SAUCE AND
WE WILL REPEAT THE WHOLE
DISCUSSION.
SO THIS IS A BIG PROJECT.
OKAY AND I GUESS WE'LL.
SEE WHITE AUTOMATED WELFARE
SYSTEM UPDATE.
OKAY HELLO OF THE FIGURE OUT HOW
WE IN A LOT OF PEOPLE HERE.
I HAVE THE RIGHT.
SOME RESTAURANTS THE AGENCY IN
THE PRESENTATION OF WHAT.
OKAY.
YES SO WE HAVE -- WILL START OFF
WITH THAT AGENCY PRESENTATION
AND THEN WE HAVE A PANEL -- THIS
AFTER AFTER AGENCY AND FINANCE
IN LA -- SO -- WHAT WITH SAID
JUST EVERYONE INTRODUCES
THEMSELVES AROUND THE TABLE FOR
THE WEEKEND WE'LL START WITH --
THE AGENCY AND GOOD AFTERNOONON
TODD PLAN ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES FOR AUTOMATION
INTEGRITY INCLINE INITIATIVES.
THANK YOU.
CHRIS DUDLEY I'M THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE OFFICE OF
SYSTEMS INTEGRATION OKAY ANY
OTHER AGENCY FOLKS OKAY LA --
BRENT METZ GRAHAM.
JANIE BELL LA -- FINANCE.
HER WORDS FINANCE.
OKAY AND I KNOW WE HAVE SEVERAL
PEOPLE BE PRESENTING AS PART OF
A THE PANEL SO WE JUST GO AHEAD
HAVE YOU INTRODUCE YOURSELVES
NOW BUT OF COURSE WE'LL GET TO
YOU AFTER WE FINISH KEVIN AS THE
NICOLE RICHIE CALIFORNIA WHAT
FOR RIGHTS ORGANIZATION THANK
YOU FOR INVITING US.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TRACY PATTERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE TO
TRANSFORM CAL FRESH THANK YOU
AND THE DOCTOR PAN IS JOHN DELAY
I AM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALLUSES I WILL TRANSITION TO BE
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. FOR CAL
SAWS LATER ON THIS SUMMER IT'S
NICE TO BE BACK BEFORE THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE LAST TIME I WAS
HERE WAS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE SYSTEMS INTEGRATION.
SO IT'S GOOD TO BE BACK AND HAVE
THIS DIALOGUE ON THIS IMPORTANT
TOPIC.
EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT SO WHEN WE
GO AHEAD BEGIN WITH THE THE
UPDATE ON SALAS.
HI THIS IS CHRIS DUDLEY I WILL
GIVE THE PROJECT UPDATE.
SO ON THE COUNCIL'S PROJECT HAS
STARTED WE RECEIVED ALL OF OUR
FEDERAL APPROVALS IN FEBRUARY
AND THE PROJECT KICKED OFF ON
MARCH THE FOURTH OF THIS YEAR.
SO WE HAD AN EARLIER STRATEGY
MAY HAVE HEARD ABOUT WHERE WE
WERE GOING TO MOVE FROM THREE
SYSTEMS TO TO SYSTEMS AND THEN
EVALUATE THE SINGLE SYSTEM.
AND THAT WAS THE LRC FOR
MIGRATION THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS OVER A YEAR
AGO SAID WELL WE'D LIKE YOU TO
PULL MORE TIME INTO PLANNING AND
COME UP WITH THAT.
FULL SINGLE SYSTEM STRATEGY SO
AS YOU KNOW LAST YEAR WHEN WE
WERE HERE WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
THAT PLANNING EFFORT.
PLANNING EFFORT WAS COMPLETED IN.
DECEMBER AND WE SENT FORWARD ARE
FEDERAL APPROVALS SO I HAVE
PROVIDED A HANDOUT THAT SHOWS
OUR ROAD MAP FOR CAL SONGS THAT
ALL SPEAK TO TO SORT OF TELL
WHAT THOUGHT APPROACHES.
ND WHERE WE ARE. TO THE VERY
TOP LINE SHOWS THAT GOVERNMENT
STRUCTURE -- THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THERE WILL BE A FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTY GOVERNMENT
STRUCTURE A GPA AND IT IS
SCHEDULED TO BE IN PLACE BY JUNE.
OF THE SUMMER.
AND THEN THE SECOND LINE ON THIS
IS THE ACTUAL DESIGN DEVELOPMENT
CONVERSION IMPLEMENTATION LINE.
SO THIS IS WHAT OUR OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS ALSO WERE CLEAR THAT
THEY WANTED US TO LEVERAGE
EXISTING TECHNOLOGY INVESTMENTS
THAT WE'VE ALREADY MADE.
SO LRS WILL BE THE BASE SYSTEM
FOR CAL SAWS IT'S NOT A NEW
BUILD IT STARTED TO SYSTEM THE
ALERT SYSTEM WILL BE MODIFIED.
SO VERY FIRST STEP IN THAT THE
FIRST TRIANGLE IS THAT THERE'S A
NEW HOSTING STRATEGY AND OTHER
US WILL BE MOVED FROM AN ON
PREMISES DATA CENTER INTO THE
CLOUD.
AND THEN AFTER THAT THERE WILL
BE SEVEN RELEASES OF
MODIFICATIONS INTO LRS THAT WILL
TRANSFORM IT INTO THE CAL SAWS.
APPLICATION THAT MEETS THE NEEDS
OF ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
AND THEN THE NEXT STEP IS THAT
THE THIRTY NINE COUNTIES THIRTY
NINE C. FOR COUNTIES WILL GO
LIVE.
ONE AND THEN AFTER THAT WILL
BEGIN THE CAL NGUYEN.
EMPLOYMENT TATIAN BEGINNING IN
JANUARY TWENTY TWO AND THAT WILL
BE A MORE WAVED IMPLEMENTATION
IT HAS A DIFFERENT DATA
STRUCTURE ODDS MORE CHANGE FOR
THE COW WHEN COUNTIES THAN IT IS
FOR THE SEE FOR COUNTIES.
SO THEN IT WILL BE COMPLETE IN
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE
WELL IN ADVANCE -- OF OUR
FEDERAL DEADLINE FOR FUNDING OF
TWELFTH DECEMBER.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THE OTHER
LINES ON THE ROAD MAP REALLY
JUST REFLECT OTHER PROCUREMENTS
THAT WILL BE MADE TO SUPPORT.
BOTH THE DEVELOPMENT AND THEN
THE ON GOING -- MAINTENANCE
OPERATIONS.
I ATTACHED A SECOND PAGE THAT
HAS THE OVERALL BUDGET -- AS
OPPOSED TO THE PREVIOUS PROJECT
WE DO HAVE AN OVERALL BUDGET
THAT WAS APPROVED BUT THERE WILL
LIKELY BE.
ANNUAL UPDATES TO THAT AS WELL
AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND LEARN
MORE ABOUT THE NEEDS THAT NEED
TO BE COMPLETED.
THERE ANY QUESTIONS ALL RIGHT.
OKAY LA -- IT'S FINANCE.
QUESTION COULD BE MEMBERS OF THE
PANEL.
SO A ONE POINT.
SIX BILLION.
ALL RIGHT ICE ACTUALLY MAKE NOTE
THAT -- WELL BEFORE
STABILIZATION -- THAT WILL
HAPPEN IF YOU'RE ON SCHEDULE
THOUGH HAPPENED RIGHT AFTER A
TERM OUT SO WE YOU INVITE ME TO
THE RIBBON CUTTING FOR THE THAT
COULD BE.
AT THAT POINT WE'LL BE AN
ELECTED OFFICIAL I DON'T KNOW
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN IN THAT CELL
WILL BE THE SEA ITSELF.
ALL RIGHT -- FANTASTIC ALL RIGHT --
SO WE DO HAVE A PANEL HERE.
SO WE CAN HAVE OUR PANELISTS --
SEE THINK WE HAVE TO STARTING.
TO GET BE ABLE TO ORDER YOU WANT
TO GO IN OUR WILL WE CAN GO ON
THE ORDER HAVE HERE SO WE'LL
START WITH TRACI PATTERSON AND
THEN FOLLOWED BY.
A KEVIN US LAND AND FILE JOHN
BLAZE SO.
I ASK THAT YOU CAN TRY TO KEEP
YOUR REMARKS TO THREE MINUTES
MAX ALL THE IRAQIS THE TIME ALL
THE TIME YOU DON'T WISH RIGHT
THANK YOU WELCOME.
THANK YOU SO YES I'M HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE TO
TRANSFORM CAL FRESH WE ARE A
GROUP OF NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WHO
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF.
OF OF PEOPLE WHO NEED AND USE
CAL FRESHEN ALSO TO RAISE OUR
CAL FRESH PARTICIPATION RATES
I'M IN A EARLIER WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT COST EFFECTIVENESS AND
WHILE THE SAW SYSTEM SERVES MANY
MORE PROGRAMS AND JUST HOW FRESH --
WITHIN CAL FRESH WE PAY THE MOST
AND WE DON'T GET THE GREATEST
RESULTS -- JUST IN JANUARY
20001963% OF ALL CALIBRATION
AISLES WERE FOR PROCEDURAL
REASONS NOT REASONS OF
INELIGIBILITY.
AND SO CAL FRESH AND THESE OTHER
STATE WHY PROGRAMS RELY REALLY
HEAVILY ON AUTOMATION TO DELIVER
SERVICES AND WE NEED AN
EFFECTIVE SAWS IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO DELIVER THOSE SERVICES
TO PEOPLE.
AND IF YOU WANT TO BE CLEAR SOME
OF YOUR EARLIER POINTS WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE USERS WE
REALLY CARE ABOUT AUTOMATION
BECAUSE WE CARE ABOUT PEOPLE --
I'VE BEEN A RECIPIENT OF THESE
PROGRAMS MYSELF I KNOW WHAT IT
FEELS LIKE TO BE ON THE END OF
THAT PHONE AND FEEL REALLY
DESPERATE AND SEEKING NEED --
AND SO WHEN I FIGHT FOR CAL
FRESH IS BECAUSE I KNOW IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT AND WE CARE
ABOUT AUTOMATION BECAUSE WE CARE
ABOUT THAT HUMAN INTERACTION.
AND YOU PROBABLY KNOW FROM BEING
A DOCTOR BUT WHEN YOU INTRODUCE
EMR AS AN SYSTEMS LIKE EPIC IT
CAN REALLY CHANGE THAT HUMAN
DYNAMIC AND WE'RE REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT HUMAN
DYNAMIC AND WHAT WORKERS GRIPS.
AN OPTIONS MIGHT MEAN FOR FOR
CLIENTS ACCESS -- AND SO AS A
NEW GOVERNOR'S PRIORITIZING
TECHNOLOGY AND WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ACES AND TRAUMA AND
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A SAWS
THAT FACILITATES THAT AS WELL --
BECAUSE WE KNOW WHEN PEOPLE COME
TO THESE ONLINE PORTALS OR MEET
WITH WORKERS THEY'RE
EXPERIENCING A LOT OF TRAUMA AND
THE NEW SYSTEM THAT SERVES THEM
WELL.
AND SO WE'VE BEEN AN ACTIVE
PARTICIPANT IN THE STAKEHOLDER
GROUP THAT WAS ESTABLISHED THE
TRAILER BILL LAST YEAR WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT.
I'M A THERE'D BEEN SOME REALLY
POSITIVE OPENINGS IN THE LAST
FEW WEEKS TO SOLIDIFY THE
COMMITMENT TO MEET REGULARLY TO
OPEN TRANSPARENCY AND WE EXPECT
THAT COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE --
AND WE ALSO JUST REALLY WANT TO
MAKE CLEAR THAT WE CARE ABOUT
THE PROCESS AND PARTICIPATION
FOR THE OUTCOMES WE DON'T WANT
IT TO BE LIKE A CHECK BOX OF
QUARTERLY MEETINGS ARE WE HAD A
MEETING AND WE SAT THERE AND WE
REVIEWED AN AGENDA WE WANTED TO
ACTUALLY.
TRANSFORM THE SYSTEM BECAUSE
UNFORTUNATELY UNTIL NOW THE
TECHNOLOGY HAS OFTEN BEEN A
BARRIER NOT A FACILITATOR OF
ACCESS AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
AS WE BUILD A SYSTEM FOR THE
FUTURE THAT IT'S REALLY
FACILITATING NOT -- AND SO TO
THAT END WE REQUEST TRAILER BILL
THAT WILL ESTABLISH THAT THE
NEEDS OF CLIENTS AND APPLICANTS
FOR A SYSTEM THAT MINIMIZES THE
BURDEN OF THE OVERALL PROCESS TO
ACTUALLY GET ROLLED NOT JUST AN
APPLICATION OR RE CERTIFICATION
BUT THE WHOLE PROCESS.
THAT THAT WOULD BE HE NORTH
STAR OF THE WHOLE PROJECT
DEVELOPMENT AND SO WHILE THERE'S
THIRTY TWO WORK GROUPS AND
MONTHLY MEETINGS AND QUARTERLY
MEETINGS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IF
WE ARE NOT THERE IN A ROOM TO
CONSULT THE DECISION OR THERE'S
A TECHNOLOGY BEING CHOSEN.
THAT THAT WOULD BE THE GUIDING
QUESTION IS THIS GOING TO
MINIMIZE THE BURDEN FOR CLIENTS --
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT COUNTY
WORKERS AN ELIGIBILITY WORKERS
ARE USERS OF THE SYSTEM WE WANT
THE SYSTEM TO WORK WELL FOR THEM
AND TO BE INTUITIVE -- BUT THE
REAL END USER IS THE PERSON WHO
EITHER GETS BENEFITS OR NOT.
AND SO IF AN AUTOMATED QUESTION
THAT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE MEANS
THAT THIRTY DAYS LETTER THIRTY
DAYS LATER YOU GET A LETTER THAT
YOU LOST YOUR MEDICARE ALL.
THAT'S THE REAL TRAGEDY AND SO
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
BUILDING A SYSTEM THAT CAN BE
FIXED THAT CAN BE ENTERED OF
THAT CAN RESPOND TO CLIENT
FEEDBACK IN A CORPORATION THAT A
THROUGH.
DEVELOPMENT PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING KEVIN OWNING.
CALIFORNIA WHAT RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS THE CURRENT
THOUGHTS HAS CAL WHEN WHICH IS A
THING COUNTIES SEE.
FOR PLEASE ENTER OUR SWITCHES
ONE TONY WHAT THE EFFORT OVER
HIS TO PUT HIM ALL IN ONE PLACE.
THAT WAY WE DON'T HAVE TO SPEND.
THREE TIMES FOR THE SAME CHANGE
[inaudible]
STORE CLEAN -- THESE WE WE'VE
SEEN MANY DIFFERENT COMPUTER
SYSTEMS COMMON GOAL.
IN MOST OF THE TIMES THE
MIGRATION THE START UPS HAVE
BEEN A NIGHTMARE. FOR PUBLIC
BENEFITS FISHERIES.
THE SYSTEM IS NOT PROFESSIONALLY
TESTED.
BEFORE IT GOES LIVE WORKERS ARE
NOT INDEPENDENTLY.
VERIFIED THAT THEY'VE BEEN
TRAINED PROPERLY.
THE FISH WE SUFFER HOMELESSNESS.
THE TH THE TUITION AND HUNGER.
NGUYEN CAO NGUYEN WENT LIVE
ABOUT TEN YEARS IN THE PREVIOUS
CENTURY I THINK OR MAYBE TEN
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO.
ON A SATURDAY WE WENT DOWN THERE
TO DO A MOCK INTERVIEW.
AND I WAS DOING TO MOCK
INTERVIEW AND THERE WAS A WORKER.
THEY WENT THROUGH THE PROCESS
AND THEY COULD NOT.
PROCESS THE CASE WHAT THE
WORKING.
MONDAY THEY WENT LIVE.
WHEN YOUR BANK CHANGES TOOK
COMPUTER SYSTEMS NOBODY KNOWS
ABOUT IT?
IT ALL HAPPENED JUST PURE.
IT'S PERFECT NOTHING HAPPENS WHY.
BECAUSE WITH TALKING ABOUT MONEY
[inaudible]
BERMAN.
THE CALIFORNIA'S GOVERNED BY
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
AND HAS A BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF
NINE PEOPLE FOUR OF THEM COME
FROM LAYING -- DON'T KNOW THE
CLICK BENEFICIALLY MEANINGFUL
PARTICIPATION OF PROCESSES. TO
MAKE SURE THAT HISTORY DOES NOT
REPEAT ITSELF I WANNA MAKE SURE.
THAT WE PUT THOSE.
AND DOES NOT REPEAT ITSELF THE
ABOUT THIRTY TWO WORK GROUPS
MEETING REGULARLY.
ABOUT IT AND POLICY ISSUES FOR
CALIFORNICA IN THOSE THREE TO
WORK WITH THE JUST MEETING FOR
CALIFORNICA.
AN EFFECTIVE JULY THERE'S GOING
TO BE THE SAME WORK GROUPS ARE
GONNA BE MEETING TO GET ARISE.
CALIFORNICA WOMEN TO UNITE SO
IT'S GONNA BE THE GONNA REPEAT
THE WHOLE THING AGAIN.
THE LEGISLATION.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE COULD --
PROVIDE FOR ADVOCATES TO HAVE
MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT.
IN.
AND IT HAS A MEAN IT'S BEEN A
IT'S BEEN A STRUGGLE WITH WITH A
CHALLENGE.
THEY HAVE A NUMBER OF WORK
GROUPS.
HOMES THAT WE HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED
FROM HOWEVER RECENTLY KELSO'S
HAS AGREED -- TO DEAD -- HAS
AGREED TO ADD ADVOCATE IMPROVED
COMMUNICATIONS INVOLVEMENT.
SUCH AS MONTHLY MEETINGS AND TO
SHARE INFORMATION WITH US AND
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
SO WE HAVE PROPOSED OF TRAILER
BILL OR SUPPLEMENT REPORT
LANGUAGE THAT WE WOULD LIKE YOU
TO CONSIDER.
AND WOULD BE GLAD TO MEET WITH
THE DEPARTMENT.
AND THE WIND CAL SAWS ABOUT THIS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN -- SINCE
LAST YEAR WHEN -- THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED THE TRAILER
BILL FOR THE STAKEHOLDER
COLLABORATION THE COUNTIES -- CW
DA.
EXCUSE ME -- THE SAUCE CONSORTIA
THE STATE OF BEN ACTIVELY ENGAGE
WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS WE'VE HOLD
TO QUARTERLY -- STAKEHOLDER
INVOLVEMENT MEETINGS -- WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS WE'VE HAD TO TOUCH
POINT MEETINGS AND I THINK MORE
IMPORTANTLY WE'VE ENGAGED IN
SOME REALLY GOOD OFFLINE SMALLER
GROUP DISCUSSIONS.
THAT HAVE SORT OF HELPED US.
MOVE AND BE ABLE -- TO LEARN
FROM EACH OTHER -- BECAUSE WE
CONCUR ON A LOT OF THE SAME
THINGS A LOT OF THE THINGS THAT
WE DO NOT WANT TO SEE OCCUR IN
THE END AND IN THE FUTURE.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT STAKEHOLDERS
ARE -- FRUSTRATED AND THAT WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO ENGAGE IN SOME
OF THE DIALOGUE AND SOME OF THE
COR APPLICATION FUNCTIONALITY.
AND WE SHARE THAT FRUSTRATION.
THE FEDERAL SHUTDOWN THAT
HAPPENED AT THE END OF LAST YEAR
AND AT THE BEGINNING OF THIS
YEAR.
DELAYED THE START OF THIS THIS
PROJECT.
TILL MARCH FOURTH SO WE JUST
KICKED OFF THIS PROJECT THIS
THIS MONTH AND AS SUCH WE'RE
ABLE TO START TO SCHEDULE SOME
VERY MEANINGFUL -- MEDIANS ON
THE CORE FUNCTIONALITY OF PUBLIC
FACING TECHNOLOGY ON A BRAND NEW
PORTAL THAT WILL COME IN TO HAVE
ONE PORTAL THAT OUR CUSTOMERS
WILL INTERACT WITH.
AS OUR A PLANE FOR BENEFITS AS
THEIR MANAGING THEIR CASELOAD --
AND WE HAVE -- TO REALLY ALMOST
HALF THE MEETINGS -- WITH HER
STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITY TO REALLY
DIG DOWN INTO THAT AS WE LOOK TO
EVEN GET A VENDOR TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT.
AND TO BE ABLE TO WORK THROUGH
THAT SO THE REQUIREMENTS TO BE
ABLE TO LOOK AT OUR DRAFT --
THREE REQUEST FOR PROPOSAL AND
AS WE SECURE THAT VENDOR TO
ACTUALLY PARTICIPATE IN THAT
USER CENTERED DESIGN HELPING US
FIND.
THOSE PUBLIC MEMBERS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THAT TESTING IN
THAT DESIGNING GOING FOR TO WORK
HAPPY.
THAT THAT'S KICKED OFF WE ALSO
UNDERSTAND HAS MISTRANSLATED AND
MENTION -- THIS CONCERN ABOUT
CONVERSION TRAINING THAT
TRANSITION FROM ONE ONE SYSTEM
TO ANOTHER SYSTEM IS ALWAYS A
TIME OF HIGH ANGST AND HIGH RISK
FOR THE RECIPIENTS FOR THE STATE.
FOR THE COUNTIES AND WE KNOW
THAT WE WANT TO ENGAGE IN THAT
JUST KICKING OFF THE PROJECT
THIS MONTH -- WE HAVE NOW
SECURED OUR VENDORS WE ARE
PINPOINTING THE TIME FRAMES TO
ACTIVELY ENGAGE IN THOSE
IMPORTANT DISCUSSIONS BECAUSE WE
KNOW.
IT IS ABOUT THE DATA AND THOSE
TRANSITION AND AS WE START
PREPARING THOSE PLANS. TO BE
ABLE TO AVOID SOME OF THOSE
THINGS THAT MAY HAVE HAPPENED
BEFORE -- THAT WE WANT TO ENGAGE
WITH OUR STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITY
ON THOSE THINGS AND AND DO THAT
WE'RE ALL ALIGNMENT FROM
ACCOUNTING IS TO THE WORKERS. TO
THE STATE INTO THE PROJECT THAT
IS ABOUT AT THE DATA AND THE
DATA TRANSITION AND PREPARING
OUR USERS TO BE ABLE TO USE THIS
SYSTEM A SYSTEM THAT ALREADY
EXISTS TODAY AND THAT'S BEING
MODIFIED TO BE ABLE TO WORK --
FOR THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES --
THE OTHER ITEM AS IT'S BEEN
BROUGHT UP ABOUT THE WORK GROUPS
ONE OF THESE THINGS IS THESE ARE
LONGSTANDING WORK GROUPS THAT
HAVE BEEN IN EXISTENCE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FIVE THEY'RE VERY.
TECHNICAL AND TACTICAL THEY DO
NOT MAKE POLICY THAT'S MADE BY
THE STATE.
AND WE NEED TO GIVE THAT LEVEL
OF TRANSPARENCY WHAT'S GOING
THROUGH THOSE THINGS AND AGAIN
WE HAVE MONTHLY.
MEETINGS THAT WE'VE NOW
ESTABLISHED TO BE ABLE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR ADVOCATE
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE THAT
INFORMATION AND WE'RE ENGAGED IN
THAT DIALOGUE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND SO -- QUESTION SO I ACTUALLY.
AND I'M CURIOUS A STRESS SIGN IN
IN TERMS OF I KNOW THIS IS
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR TH
CONCERNS THAT YOU PHRASE THE IF
THE EXISTING SYSTEMS I MEAN THE
THIS IS.
MAINLY A PEOPLE PERSON ISSUE THE
WORKER WHO'S INTO OURS THEIR
UNDERLYING I MEAN TO DO THAT TO
TELL YOU HEARING THAT.
SOME SYSTEMS WORK BETTER THAN
OTHERS IN TERMS OF TECHNOLOGY
VERSUS THE PERSON IS ACTUALLY
THE INTERFACE WITH THAT.
IT'S BEST TO THE PROBLEMS WHEN
THE SYSTEM GOES LIVE BEGINNING
THIS PROJECT OKAY AT THREE YEARS
IT'S IT'S OKAY TO THE TRANSITION
PHASE IT'S NOT THIS.
OKAY THE REASON FOR THAT IS THAT
WORK WITH A SORT OF BEEN TRAINED
AND THEY BID DAHLE BLOOD INTO A
ROOM.
AND A GIVEN A LITTLE SPEECH AND
THEN THIS A GOLD WORK.
AT THE LARGEST SUFFICIENT I MEAN
AND TO ME BEFORE SOMEBODY GO
THROUGH TERMINA IN THE BANK I'M
SURE THIS TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
OTHERWISE YOU'RE GONNA LOSE
MONEY AND THEY SHOULD ADOPT THE
SAME TYPE OF PROCESS IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHOEVER'S ON THE
TERMINAL.
KNOWS WITH WHAT THEY'RE DOING
AND THEIR MAKES MISTAKES THE MAN.
FOR THE FIRST YOUTH IT'S CHAOS I
MEAN I'M SORRY OKAY SO.
AND AND AND THEN -- AND SO I
REALLY FOR DANGER TAKING
SEXUALLY THREE SYSTEMS AND
TRYING.
TO VERSION TOGETHER BUT TRYING
TO BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER AROUND
ONE SYSTEM AND WE JUST HAD THIS
WHOLE CONVERSATION ABOUT ANOTHER
SYSTEM IN TERMS OF MODULARITY
AND SO FORTH I MEAN.
IS THE WAY WERE PLANNING THIS
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE WE ARE SIR
TAKING PEOPLE FROM THREE
EXISTING ARCHITECTURES AND
TRYING TO BRING THEM TOGETHER.
IS -- AT THE END OF THIS PROCESS
TO IT MEANS IT IS EVER GOING TO
HAVE AN ARCHITECTURES OF ABLE TO
OF ALL OF OUR WE BECAUSE OF OF
GIVEN WHAT WE'RE HAVING TO BUILD
ON AND MAKES SENSE TO LEVERAGE
OUR EXISTING SYSTEMS BUT I'M
JUST.
YEAH WE TALKED ABOUT AT CHILD IN
THERE AND MODULAR APPROACH ISN'T
SO OR IS THAT WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO EVENTUALLY EVOLVED INTO WITH
THIS APPROACH WITH THE IN THE
FUTURE SINGLE SYSTEM ARE WE JUST
LIKE OKAY WE'RE TRYING IGURE
OUT ALL THESE THREE TOGETHER
WHEN I HAVE SOME SINGLE.
SYSTEM AT THE END OF IT BUT THN
SOME POINT LATER WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO REBUILD THE WHOLE THING
I JUST I I'M TRYING TO I'M
TRYING.
TO GET MY A ARMS.
ARMS AROUND HOW.
HOW THIS BEFORE WE GET TOWARD
THE END OF THIS PROCESS WHICH
WILL BE BEYOND MY TIME CELL WILL
BE?
SOMEBODY ELSE WILL HAVE TO
FIGURE FIGURE OUT ABOUT IT WHEN
IT FLOWS IF IT BLOWS UP I WAS A
WIN BECAUSE WE HAVE A SUCCESS
LIKE THE PROGRAM -- THAT -- THAT --
YOU KNOW HOW HOW.
HOW DO I HOW HOW WE MAKE THIS
WORK?
LET ME LET ME GIVE SOME THOUGHTS
ON THAT -- AND THEN AND THEN
MAYBE MISTER RELATING IT YOU
YEAH SOME TECHNICAL QUESTIONS --
TO SORT OF STEPPING BACK --
AGAIN THE ORIGINAL PLAN WAS
THREE SYSTEMS TO TO SYSTEMS TO
ONE FOR REALLY SIMPLIFYING AYE
WE REALLY REPLACE THE NUMBER TO
WITH THE WORD TEO THREE TWO ONE
THAT IS WHAT WE ARE DOING NOW --
IT THAT THAT CAME AS A CHANGE IN
THE CAME TO US FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN LATE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN AND THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT A VERY.
HARD DEADLINE OF BY THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO THEY WERE NOT GOING TO
PAY FOR ANOTHER SYSTEM SO.
A TON OF PLANNING WENT INTO
REALLY THINKING AHEAD TO WHAT
THAT ULTIMATE SYSTEM SHOULD LOOK
LINE.
THINKING ABOUT CAL WHEN DOING
USER LABS LOOKING AT ALL THREE
SYSTEMS AND A LOT OF THAT
HAPPENED IN SEVENTEEN AND MORE
OF IT HAPPENED IN EIGHTEEN WE
HIRE AN INDEPENDENT CONSULTANT --
MCKINSEY -- HELP WITH A LOT OF
THAT WORK AND THAT WAS -- THEY
WERE RESPECTED PARTNER AND
APPRECIATED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
PLAYED AN ENORMOUS ROLE IN THAT --
PLANNING PROCESS THEY WERE PART
OF MANY MANY OF OUR MEETINGS HE
OTHER BIG PIECE OF THE FEDERAL
GUIDANCE THAT WAS WHAT YOU SAID
THEY THEY DID NOT -- IT WASN'T A
DESIGN THE VERY BEST SYSTEM FROM
SCRATCH IT TO LEVERAGE THOSE
EXISTING SYSTEMS AND THEY WERE
LOOKING AT THE ENORMOUS
INVESTMENT THAT WAS MADE AND
WHAT WE CALL EL ARE ASKED THE
LEADER REPLACEMENT SYSTEM LOS
ANGELES THE SYSTEM.
SO -- AND THERE ARE A LOT OF
LESSONS LEARNED I THINK WHAT MR
AS LANEY IN MENTIONED ABOUT SOME
OF THOSE KIND OF ROUGH
TRANSITIONS WHEN WE WENT WHEN
CAL WENT WENT LIVE AGAINST ITS
LEGACY SYSTEM.
AND EVEN WITH ALL OUR ELSE --
NOT NOT NOT QUITE THE SAME THAT
DAY BUT THERE WERE SOME REAL
TRANSITION AND THERE ARE LESSONS
LEARNED AND THOSE ARE ISSUES THE
ADVOCATES OF REYES WITH US.
AND REALLY NEXT MONTH WE'RE
HOPING T KIND OF SEQUENCE A
WHOLE SERIES OF REALLYIMPORTANT
ADVOCATE CONCERNS AND FIGURE OUT
WHEN DO THEY REALLY FIT IN THIS
LIFE CYCLE.
AS MR BLAME MENTIONED WERE
MOVING VERY QUICKLY -- INTO ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT PUBLIC
FACING FACES AND THAT'S THAT'S
THE PORTAL AND THE MOBILE OUT.
AND ESSENTIALLY THERE WERE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO BRING ADVOCATES A
STAKEHOLDERS IN FROM THE
BEGINNING BECAUSE THAT'S GOING
TO BE A SEPARATE PROCUREMENT
THEY CAN EVEN BE PART OF THE
PROCUREMENT AND THE SETTING OF
SOME OF THE REQUIREMENTS.
AND WE'RE LOOKING REALLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO THAT INPUT SO THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF A LOT OF PLANNING
WORK HAD TO BE DONE UNDER THAT
FEDERAL DEADLINE AND A LOT OF
OUR INTERACTION WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS HAS BEEN CATCHING
THEM UP AND SHARING THAT.
AND REALLY NOW WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED TO BE MOVING INTO A MORE
ACTIVE PHASE OF GETTING THEIR
MORE DIRECT INPUT ON THE ACTUAL
THINGS AND THEN SEQUENCING IN
LIKE I SAID EVERYTHING WE ALL
THE CONCERNS THAT THEY REYES.
THEY HAVE THE PLACE WE HAVEN'T
TALKED ABOUT THE MALL YET BUT WE
WILL AND AND WE'LL WORK WITH
THEM AND FIGURE OUT THE RIGHT
TIME.
I HOPE THAT ANSWERS SOME OF YOUR
QUESTIONS -- SORT OF BUT I'M
ALSO TRYING TO THINK ABOUT AND
WHAT DO I GET BACK TO SOME OF
THE INTERFACE ISSUES --
ESPECIALLY -- FOR THE
BENEFICIARIES BUT IN TERMS OF SO
AT THE END OF THIS PROCESS RIGHT
AND AND THE UNDERSTAND SO
GOVERNMENT WANTS YOU TO USE A
MADE A HUGE INVESTMENT ON THIS
UNDERLYING ARCHITECTURE FOR I
GUESS IT'S L. R. S. RIGHT.
IT SO WHEN WE END UP IN.
WITH OUR UNIFIED SYSTEM IN.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE I GUESS IT'S
A GOOD SO WE ASK ABOUT THE
QUESTION THE NATURE OF THAT
SYSTEM AND IS IS A PLAN TO TRY
TO GET IT TO A PLACE WHERE --
THIS IS WE WILL HAVE A NEED TO
ADD FUNCTIONALITY ETCETERA IS
THAT WE COULD SEE AN
ARCHITECTURE THAT AS ACTUALLY
PERHAPS MORE.
FLEXIBLE AND I DON'T KNOW HOW I
I JUST DON'T KNOW ENOUGH ABOUT
LRS IT'S WAS WELL YOU KNOW WHAT
GIVEN WHEN IT'S DEVELOPED AND
WHAT'S LIKE BUT AND AND AND
MAYBE ALSO.
TECHNOLOGY CAN.
CAN CAN COMMENT ABOUT YOUR
INVOLVEMENT IN THIS AS WELL SO
YEAH.
A DOCTOR BALLOT THINK IT'S THAT
IT'S A GOOD AND FAIR QUESTION.
YOU'LL SEE THAT THE FIRST THING
THAT -- DEPUTY DIRECTOR DUDLEY
SPOKE ABOUT WAS THE MOVEMENT OF
THE LRSD PLATFORM OFF OF AN ON
PREMISES DATA CENTER TO A MODERN
DATA CENTER -- WE ARE GOING TO
THE A WS -- A CLOUD WE'RE GOING
TO FIRST BRING UP PRODUCTION LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WITHIN TWENTY
NINETEEN TO THAT PRODUCTION --
CLOUD AN UPDATE THAT THAT GIVES
US MORE FLEXIBILITY AND SOME
MODERN COMPONENTS THAT WE CAN
ENACT AS WE GO FORWARD.
IT'S ALSO IN ORDER IF APPROACH
TO BE ABLE TO SEE HIM PRODUCTION
HOW THAT'S HOW THAT'S WORKING
THERE ALSO LEVER LEVERAGING
PROCUREMENTS THAT ARE
ADMINISTERED BY THE DEARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY.
AND CONTRACTS THAT THEY'VE PUT
IN PLACE TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
THAT PROVIDES US WITH A GOOD
FOUNDATION SO THAT WE'RE ON A
MODERN ARCHITECTURE.
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE
TO DO IN ORDER TO SCALE TO FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES.
IS RE ARCHITECTING SOME OF OUR
NIGHTLY BATCH JOBS TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE A MORE MODERN STREAMING
ARCHITECTURE. TO COME TO A NEW --
REPORTS MECHANISM TO BE ABLE TO
MINE DATA BATTERED FOR
DEPARTMENTS USE IN THOSE TYPES
OF THINGS THOSE THINGS HAVE BEEN
AND ARE BEING BUILT INTO THE
BUDGET AS WE O FORWARD.
SO IT IS MORE MODULAR AND IT IS
MORE -- MODERN AS WE GO FORWARD
SO THAT WE DON'T IMPLEMENT A
SYSTEM THAT IS OUTDATED FROM
FIRST DAY BUT THE DIE HAS BEEN
SET.
BY OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS SAYING
YOU WILL LEVERAGE LRS.
IT WILL BE ACCOMMODATE THE FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES SO THERE IS A LOT
OF FUNCTIONALITY ENHANCEMENTS.
BUT WE HAVE TO MAKE IN ORDER TO
SCALE FOR STATE IS LARGEST
CALIFORNIA ARCHITECTURAL
ENHANCEMENTS SO WE'RE NOT.
IMPLEMENTING AN OUTDATED
ARCHITECTURE WHEN WE GO LIVE.
RIGHT IS HELPFUL.
THE COMMENTS FROM TECHNOLOGY BUT
YOU'RE INVOLVED IN THIS PROCESS
AND SOME OPPORTUNITIES THERE.
SO DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY --
WORKING WITH THE OFFICE OF
SYSTEM INTEGRATION -- WE WE'VE
BEEN MONITORING WE'VE BEEN --
WORKING WITH THEM TO GET THIS
STATUS AS AS IT'S GONE THROUGH
THIS FEDERAL APPROVAL PROCESS.
AND AS MISPLACING HAS STATED IT
IS IT WAS -- THE DECISION'S BEEN
MADE BUT IT WASN'T MADE --
LIGHTLY I AM IN THE THE AMOUNT
OF DISCOVERY THAT THAT WE HAVE
WITNESSED GOING INTO THESE
DECISIONS IMPROVING NOW THAT
THAT THIS WOULD WORK -- WAS WAS
VERY IN DEPTH BEFORE YOU'RE AT
THAT THE STAGE YOU ARE TODAY --
IN ADDITION -- LEVERAGING YOU
KNOW THE CONTRACT VEHICLES THAT
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY -- HAVE
HAVE -- PUT OUT THERE -- IS A
GREAT PARTNERSHIP FROM THE
COUNTY CONSORTIA LEVEL TO THE
STATE LEVEL SO THAT WE WE ARE
SEEING THE SAME THINGS IN THESE
MODERN -- ARCHITECTURES AND WE
CAN YOU LEVERAGE THE LESSONS
LEARNED -- FROM BOTH THE STATE
AND THE COUNTY SIDE.
AND A FREE **** ACTUALLY THE
CLOUD THE SECOND PIECE THAT IS
THAT SOMEONE ELSE IS A STATE
OPERATED CLOUD.
IT'S PUBLIC CLOUD EIGHT OF U. S. --
BUT THROUGH THE CONTRACTS THAT
THE DEPARTMENT TECHNO QUE ALL
RIGHT.
THEN ONCE AS THE CLOUD THE CLOUD
IS ACTUALLY PHYSICALS.
CONNECTION IN THE US RIGHT AND
YOU KNOW THERE'S IT'S SOMEONE
ELSE'S SERVER SO CONFIDENTIALITY
ALL THAT OTHER STUFF RIGHT SO.
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS HAS MADE
SURE THAT THE SECURITY LEVELS
ARE ARE SUFFICIENT FOR THE THE
PROJECTS THAT ARE ALLOWED TO USE
IT OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL I THINK
THAT'S GONNA BE ROOM.
FOR I MEAN. FOR MY COMES THAT TO
THAT OKAY AND I I HEARD ABOUT
THINGS LIKE MOBILE AND OTHER
THINGS SO IN TERMS OF FEATURE WE
HAVE THE APPROPRIATE INTERFACES
FOR BOTH WHETHER STRICTLY WITH.
THE VAN FISHERIES OR THROUGH TO
CASE WORKERS -- WE HEARD
TESTIMONY ABOUT -- ILL WITH.
SOMEONE GO IT WILL BE DOING
FOCUS GROUP TESTS ON THESE
INTERFACES TO BE SURE THAT --
WITH CLIENTS THAT THEY THEY
ACTUALLY THE QUESTIONS IN THE
WAY THEY'RE PRESENTED AND SO
FORTH MAKES SENSE IN THAT --
EASILY UNDERSTANDABLE AND I
DON'T ABOUT LANGUAGES AS WELL
GIVEN THAT THE INTERFACES --
THAT THE FOR THE SPEECH FOR THE
INTERFACE IS THAT THE CLIENTS
WHO ARE GOING TO SEE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE FLANK THE ALL
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES THAT PEOPLE
CAN.
DIRECTLY SEE.
CASEY TO WHAT KIND OF WORK
YOU'RE DOING TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN
YES THE THE SHORT ANSWER IS IS
IS YES TO THOSE WERE GOING TAKE
BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
AND NOW WE'RE GONNA WAKE WORK
WITH OUR STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITY
MAKE SURE THAT ALL THOSE
REQUIREMENTS ARE IN THERE AS WE
SECURE A VENDOR.
AND TO BE ABLE BY IDENTIFY AND
WORK WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS ON
WHO ARE THE INDIVIDUALS TO BE
INVOLVED IN THE DESIGN AND MAKE
SURE THAT THERE ARE FOCUS GROUPS
AND PUBLIC GROUPS THAT WOULD BE
ABLE TO USE THIS.
AND LOOK AT THE USER INTERFACE
OF THIS AND WORK THROUGH THAT
AND MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
ROBUST TESTING. ONE SIX OF THE
MOTHER -- I MEAN I THINK WE HAVE
NOT I MEAN WE HAVEN'T SEEN THAT
HAPPENED YET AND I THINK WE
HAVEN'T SEEN IT HAPPEN YOU KNOW
JUST LOOKING AT EL ARRESTED AS
PEOPLE INTERACT WITH THE C. FOR
ENOUGH SEE FOR YOURSELF.
PORTAL IT IT'S NOT USER FRIENDLY
RIGHT NOW AND WE COULD SHOW YOU
SCREEN SHOTS OF IT IS EXTREMELY
HARD TO NAVIGATE AND TO
UNDERSTAND -- EVEN YOU KNOW WITH
A MASTER'S DEGREE IN ALL THESE
SORTS OF THINGS IT'S TRICKY --
AND SO I THINK WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT IS YOU KNOW
CONTINUALLY GOING ON AND THAT
ALSO IT'S IT'S NOT ONLY THOSE
PORTALS AS YOU MENTIONED -- I
THINK WITH THE VERIFICATION HOW
PROJECT THAT WAS A REALLY
IMPORTANT DECISION BECAUSE THESE
WORK GROUPS ARE I. T. GROUPS.
AND THEY DON'T SET POLICY BUT
THEY IN TURN POLICY IN A WAY BY
THE INTERACTIONS THAT THEY
SCRIPT OUT AND SO WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT SOMETHING LIKE
VERIFICATIONS YOU COULD HAVE
POLICY ABOUT VERIFICATION.
BUT YOU COULD SET A TONE IN THE
QUESTIONS THAT A WORKER ASKS OR
HOW THEY MOVE THROUGH THE
PROCESS THAT EITHER OPENS IT UP
TO SAY WE'RE GONNA PAYING EVERY
OPTION POSSIBLE.
OR CAN SAY THIS IS AMERICA
VERIFICATION PRESENTED OR WERE
DONE AND THOSE SORTS OF
TECHNOLOGICAL SCRIPTS ACTUALLY
GUIDE THAT HUMAN EXPERIENCE AND
SO WE DO CARE A LOT ABOUT THE
PORTAL ON THE WEBSITE.
BUT WE'RE WE'RE JUST REALLY
CONCERNED THAT I. T. DECISIONS
THAT COULD SEEM LIKE YOUR I. T.
DECISIONS.
CAN HAVE AN IMPACT ON ON CLIENTS
AND SO WHILE WE CAN'T BE THERE
FOR EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
DECISIONS THAT'S WHY WE WANT
THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S
THE FOCUS OF THE PROJECT.
OKAY DOES I NEEDED THAT.
SO I THINK IT'S GONNA BE REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT RESIDENTS I SAID
BEFORE THE SUCCESS OF ANY I. T.
PROJECT ACTUALLY IS USUALLY NOT
THE I. T. ITSELF THE TECHNICAL
GUYS CAN USUALLY FIGURE STUFF
OUT BUT HE SAID THAT.
THE DIET AND BASICALLY THE
DELUDE DESIGNING THE UNDERLYING
YELL DID YOU EAT.
THE STUFF UNDER THE HOOD MAY
WORK BUT THE ON THE STEERING
WHEEL DOESN'T REALLY TURN THE
BRAKES NEEDS A TOO MUCH PRESSURE
SO FORTH AND THE VEHICLE DOESN'T
WORK RIGHT FOR TO TO A PERSON
HAS TO USE IT.
SO -- SO HOPEFULLY HE SAID --
BUT THEN IT WILL IT ELKS GIVE IT
YET AND SO -- IT'S A BIG BUDGET
ITEM OBVIOUSLY Là IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT SYSTEM BUT I HOPE THAT
THEY'RE SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO
BE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE KIND OF
WORK ON THE INTERFACES SHOES AND
THAT'S WITH THE CLIENTS AND ALSO
WITH THE PEOPLE AT THE USE THE
SYSTEM.
AND THAT AND SO THAT THEIR
NOLLIE WELL TRAINED USES THE
SYSTEM BUT EVEN ORE POORLY THE
SYSTEM IS WORKS FOR THEM IS
INTUITIVE -- FOR THEM AND FOR
CLIENTS AND THAT ACTUALLY WE
WANTED THAT THEY'D BE GOOD IF
THERE'S ACTUALLY -- SINCE WE'RE
TALKING TECHNOLOGY WHERE WE CAN
ACTUALLY EMPOWER CLIENTS WITH
THE SYSTEM TO GIVE THEM MORE
INFORMATION FOR THEMSELVES SO
THAT THEY CAN THAT THAT THEY CAN
ACT ON INCIDENTS LIKE WONDERING
WHAT'S THIS MYSTERIOUS BLACK BOX
AND I HAVE TO ASK MY CASE WORKER
AND ON A CASE WORKER.
CAN TELL MYSELF I CAN LOOK UP
STUFF.
ABOUT MYSELF MY OWN IN THEIR OWN
SYSTEM AT SOMETHING WE EXPECT
MAULER OTHER SYSTEMS RIGHT WE GO
TO HIM WE TOOK UPPER COUNTS
ONLINE WITH ITS ADDRESS WE
SHOULD HOPEFULLY.
WE'RE ASKING THEM TO PROVIDE A
LOT OF VERY PERSONAL INFORMATION
ABOUT THEMSELVES SO THAT THEY
CAN GET ACCESS SERVICES.
THEY SHOULD ALSO GET.
FEEDBACK THROUGH THE SYSTEM.
IS TO NOT ONLY WHAT WHAT THE
SYSTEM KNOWS ABOUT THEM BUT ALSO
WHAT THE SYSTEM CAN DO FOR THEM
AND NOT HAVE THE NECESSARY GO
THROUGH OTHER PEOPLE TO FIND OUT
IF WE CAN BUILD THAT KIND OF
INTO THEIR BABY.
THE CLOUDS OF SILS SEE VALUE IN
OUR BASEMENT AS WELL.
SO THAT [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
BOY I WAS GONNA TAKE QUESTIONS
AT THE END BUT OKAY ALL RIGHT
OKAY.
I ALWAYS ONLY REQUEST THE
ACCOUNT THOUGH.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT -- OKAY ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS I ACTUALLY
WENT OUT SO I HAVE TO ASK YOU
KNOW THIS BIG BIG PROJECT LOTS
OF MONEY LA -- OVERSIGHT --
HOW'S THE HOW'S IT GOING.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME BUT WE'RE CERTAINLY
MONITORING THE PROJECT.
OKAY SO I MEAN THIS IS THAT IT.
THIS IS A BIG ONE ALL RIGHT OKAY
THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON THEN TO ISSUE
NUMBER.
FOUR WHICH IS THE V. C. P. FOR
ELECTRONIC VISIT VERIFICATION WE
DID HAVE A QUICK DISCUSSION
ABOUT WHAT TRYING TO VISIT
VERIFICATION IN A PREVIOUS
HEARING -- SO WE CAN.
BRING UP FOLKS HERE AND YOU CAN
INTRODUCE YOURSELVES THE RECORD.
RIGHT WE GOT A FEW NEW PEOPLE
AROUND THE TABLE -- OR EVEN
RETURNING PEOPLE THAT
[inaudible]
PLEASE THE JEEZ YOURSELVES FIRST.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS MY NAME IS
CYNTHIA TUCKER I AM A DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WITH THE OPPOSITE
SYSTEMS INTEGRATION HE AND OUR
TIME RIGHT HI.
I'M SARAH DION ON THE PROJECT
DIRECTOR FOR THE SCENE UP SYSTEM.
THANK YOU YOU.
BRENT METZ CARRILLO.
JANIE BELL L. L. OKAY FINANCE.
SITTING TANIMOTO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
RENDON ANSWER DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY OKAY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
AND THE DRIVERS INTERPRETATION.
YES OKAY SO THE ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION IS REQUIRED BASED
ON THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
CURES ACT WHICH WAS APPROVED
BACK DECEMBER.
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND SO FOR THE IN
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES THE
SYSTEM THAT IS GOING TO BE --
BRING IS COMPLAIN TO THAT
FEDERAL REQUIREMENT IS A C. MAPS --
WE ARE LEVERAGING -- THE
ELECTRONIC TIME SHEET.
THE PORTAL THAT WAS CREATED AND
WE IMPLEMENTED.
PROBLEM THAT A YEAR AND A HALF
AGO -- SO WE'RE ACTUALLY TAKING
THAT -- INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
WE'VE ALREADY IMPLEMENTED AND
BUILDING A TOPIC.
SO THE REQUEST IS APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY FOUR POINT THREE MILLION --
THAT INCLUDES POSITIONS -- SIX
PERMANENT POSITIONS AS WELL AS
FUNDING FOR AN EQUIVALENT OF
SEVEN POINT.
FIVE MAKE SURE IT STAYS THERE --
AND THEN THE TWENTY TWO MILLION
ROUGHLY -- FOR A SIZE WITH
REGARDS TO INFRASTRUCTURE --
APPLICATION MAINTENANCE SYSTEM
ENHANCEMENTS AND IMPLEMENTATION
HELP DESK YOU KNOW ALL THOSE
THINGS THAT.
YOU GO TO SUPPORT THE PROGRAM.
OKAY.
RIGHT LA -- ANY COMMENTS.
WE REVIEW THE BUDGET PROPOSAL
HAVE NO CONCERNS FINANCE.
ALRIGHT WELL WE TALKED ABOUT
EVEY READY FOR USE HEARING SO
THIS IS JUST.
BUT WE NEED TO DO TO MAKE IT
WORK OKAY SOUNDS GOOD.
ALL RIGHT NO OTHER QUESTIONS
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
THEN TO ISSUE NUMBER.
FIVE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FOR
STATE WIDE FINGERPRINT IMAGING
SYSTEM TECHNICAL CLEAN UP
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHTS.
THE A SEVERITY INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES AGAIN SINCE WE'VE HAD
NEW PEOPLE AROUND THE TABLE ARE
PEOPLE RETURNING BUT JUST FOR
THE RECORD.
AGAIN TODD PLAN FOR CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES --
OKAY LA OF SORRY.
BRENT METZ CARRILLO.
JANIE BELL L. L. FINANCE.
TIGER WOODS FINANCE.
SEC RENDON HANSARD DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT --
WE VIEW THIS PROPOSAL IS
COMPLETELY TECHNICAL AS YOU KNOW
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE THE
GOVERNOR AGREED TO ELIMINATE THE
FINGERPRINTING SYSTEM OVER OVER
ACTUALLY A MULTI YEAR PERIOD BUT
IT IT IT IT.
WE HAVEN'T BEEN USING IT SINCE
LAST YEAR AND THE CLEAN UP AND
SET ESSENTIALLY REMOVING THE
EQUIPMENT AND US GETTING RID OF
A TRADING THE DATA ALL THAT
PROCESS IS UNDER WAY ALL THIS
TRAILER BILL DOES IT REALLY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN CALLING
INTERACTED LAST YEAR IS -- TIE
UP SOME LOOSE ENDS THEY WERE
ALWAYS -- CERTAIN POPULATIONS
THAT WERE -- EXEMPT FROM ANY
FINGERPRINTING OR ANY ID THIS
JUST LITERALLY SUBSTANCE SINCE
THE THE WORDS IN ON AND
PRESERVES AS EXEMPTIONS IT IS IS
COMPLETELY TECHNICALLY
CONSIDERED NONSENSE FAN OF A NON
CONTROVERSIAL [inaudible]
OKAY.
SOUNDS GOOD HELLO -- WE REVIEW
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IN
AGREE IT'S LARGELY LARGELY
TECHNICAL SNOW CONCERNS OKAY
FINANCE.
ALL RIGHT.
YEAH THE TWO STAFF OKAY THAT
SOUNDS SOUNDS GOOD SOMETIMES YOU
NEVER KNOW CONTROVERSY WE'LL SEE
IF ANYONE WANTS COMMON IN PUBLIC
COMMON AGAINST ITSELF ALL RIGHT.
OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
TAKE.
THANK YOU GO AHEAD TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT TO THEN ON THE SECTION
WITH THE THE SYSTEMS INTEGRATION
SO.
ALL RIGHT WELCOME COMMITTEE
THERE FRANK MECCA WITH THE
COUNTY WILL FOR DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION.
ON THE SAUCE ITEM.
WITH RESPECT -- TO TRANSPARENCY
IN THE COMMITMENT TO STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT AND LEARNING THE
LESSONS FROM PRIOR --
CONVERSIONS I'D LIKE TO LINE MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF MR BELAY
AND OUR PARTNERS AT THE STATE --
I ALSO THE THOUGH THANK THAT
BUILDING OFF OF A COMMENT YOU
MADE EARLIER IN THE HEARING THAT
WE SHOULD TAKE A MINUTE TO THINK
ABOUT THE SUCCESS OF THE SAUCE
SYSTEM.
THIS THIRTEEN MILLION PEOPLE
TODAY RIGHT NOW IN CALIFORNIA
WHO ARE RECEIVING CAL WORKS CAL
FOR ASH.
MEDI CAL GENERAL ASSISTANCE SOME
INDIGENT HEALTH PROGRAM.
BECAUSE THAT'S BECAUSE OF A
SYSTEM THAT WORKS.
AND IT HAS FOR A COUPLE DECADES.
AND THE REASON YOU DON'T READ
ABOUT THAWS IN THE NEWSPAPER IS
LARGE IT IS IS BECAUSE IT WORKS
AND SO.
I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO
CELEBRATE ST AUTOMATION
VICTORIES AND FOR A COUPLE OF
DECADES THIS IS BAD ONE OF OUR
MOST SUCCESSFUL IF NOT THE
STATE'S MOST SUCCESSFUL.
IT VENTURE AND I THINK THE
PEOPLE AT THE STATE AND THE
COUNTIES.
ARE TO BE CREDITED FOR THAT CAN
THAT SYSTEM AS IT INVOLVES
MOVING FORWARD BE EVEN MORE
CLIENT FRIENDLY AND WORKER
FRIENDLY ABSOLUTELY WERE
CONSTRAINED TO AN EXTENT BY
FEDERAL PARAMETERS THAT WE'RE
WORKING WITH AND BUT WERE
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO IT.
BUT WE'D ALL BE REMISS IF WE
DIDN'T TAKE A MINUTE TO SAY --
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS DONE A
REALLY GOOD JOB WITH WHAT FOR
AUTOMATION WE SHOULD CELEBRATE
THAT.
THANK YOU EXCELLENT POINT.
OTHER PUBLIC COMMENTS ON HI WELL
KEVIN AS A COLD TO CALIFORNIA
FROM ITS ORGANIZATIONS.
THE SUPPORT OF THE FINGERPRINT
OF A WE KIND OF FINGERPRINT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
Q..
WELCOME.
HEY M. DIANA JENSEN I'M WITH THE
SAN FRANCISCO MARIN FOOD BANK --
THE SERVICES GRAMMAR ENTRY BANK
IS A FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
ALLIES TRANSFORM CAL FRESH SO
WE'VE -- WERE I'M SUPPORTING
LANGUAGE THAT HIGHLIGHTS THE
SORT OF THE NORTH STAR OF
REDUCING OF MAKING SURE THAT WE
REDUCE THE BURDEN ON CLIENTS.
I WOULD SAY -- I AGREE THAT I
THINK THAT THAT IN OUR HEARTS WE
ALL THAT'S WHAT WE ALL WANT BUT
SOMETIMES WHEN WE HAVE ALL THESE
PRIORITIES ABOUT -- YOU KNOW
WE'VE WE WE GOT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS X. Y. Z. WORKS UNDER
THE HEAD SOMETIMES I CAN GET
LOST IN THE SHUFFLE A LITTLE BIT --
WE'VE BEEN PARTICIPATING IN THE
STAKEHOLDER GROUP AND I AGREE
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF MOVEMENT
TOWARD KIND OF GETTING TO KNOW
EACH OTHER BETTER AND GETTING
READY TO DIG IN A LITTLE BIT
DEEPER -- SO I APPRECIATE THAT --
I WANTED TO JUST ONE QUESTION
THAT THAT YOU ASKED ABOUT
WHETHER ON WHETHER THE PROBLEM
IS IN THE TRANSITION PEER AT THE
CONCERNS ARE IN TRANSITION.
IT OR SORT OF THE CORE
FUNCTIONALITY OF THE SYSTEM AND
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF ISSUES
I YOU KNOW I THINK WE ARE THERE
ARE WORRIES ABOUT THE TRANSITION
THAT.
BUT THAT ON ADVOCATES HAVE --
THAT THAT I THINK WE ALL HAVE WE
HAVEN'T I AGREE -- MINISTER PLAN
WE HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO DIG
INTO WHAT THOSE CONCERNS ARE AND
HOW MUCH IS BEING ADDRESSED
ALREADY AND THAT KIND OF THING.
THERE BUT THERE ARE OTHER
UNDERLYING -- PROBLEMS WITH THE
EXISTING SYSTEMS THAT I HOPE
WILL BE ADDRESSED IN THE NEW --
WHEN WHEN THE TRANSITION SO FOR
EXAMPLE THERE'S REALLY KIND OF
INCONSISTENT -- LIKE A DATA
COLLECTION ABOUT REALLY
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT MAKES IT
SO THAT WE CAN'T KNOW AT THE
STATE LEVEL LIKE HOW WELL WE'RE
DOING WE CAN'T -- WE HAVE THIS
AMAZING FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY SORT
OF EXPERIMENT WHERE YOU SHOULD
BE ABLE TO LOOK ACROSS DIFFERENT
COUNTIES AND SAY OKAY WELL
THEY'RE DOING IT THIS WAY
THEY'RE DOING IT THAT WAY.
BUT WE HAVE DATA COLLECTED THE
SAME WAY IN BOTH PLACES AND SO
LET'S DO SOME EVALUATION THE
CURRENT THE CODE THE WAY THAT
THOSE -- REQUIREMENTS ARE SET IN
THE EXISTING SYSTEMS.
JUST DOESN'T ALLOW FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN AND THAT'S A SHAME -- THE
LAST THING I WOULD SAY IS THAT --
THAT YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA'S STILL
HAS ONE OF THE LOWEST COVERAGE
PARTICIPATIONS IN THE COUNTRY SO --
WE DEFINITELY CAN DO BETTER BY
BY CONSUMERS IN CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS BECKY GOES ON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
FOOD BANKS -- OUR ORGANIZATION
IS ALSO ONE OF THE FOUNDING
MEMBERS OF THE ALLIANCE TO
TRANSFORM CALL FRESH.
AND WE'VE ALSO BEEN
PARTICIPATING IN THE STALLS
SAUCE STAKEHOLDER GROUP THAT'S
BEEN CAN BE AND OVER THE LAST
FEW MONTHS AND HAVE REALLY
APPRECIATED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE ABLE TO LEARN ABOUT THE
PROCESS AND ALSO.
PROVIDE FEEDBACK AND
RECOMMENDATIONS WHERE THAT'S
BEEN APPROPRIATE AS WELL SO
THAT'S BEEN A REALLY GREAT
PROCESS.
AND WE ALSO WANT TO THINK THE
LEGISLATURE CSS SO SORRY SEE WA
OTHERS I AM FOR CONVENING THAT
GROUP AND AND FACILITATING ABOUT
SPACE TO MAKE IT HAPPEN -- AND
WE ALSO SUPPORT I'M ANY OFFER IT
AGAIN TO CREATE THIS NORTH STAR
AND AND TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
HEART THE REAL HEART OF THIS
PROJECT IS TO MAKE SURE.
THAT CLIENTS ARE ABLE TO ACCESS
THESE REALLY REALLY CRITICAL
BENEFITS THAT THEY'RE ENTITLED
TO SO THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THE
SPACE FOR THIS CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT SEE NO ONE ELSE AT THE
MICROPHONE APPRECIATE -- THE
COMMENTS -- IT'S CERTAINLY AGREE
THAT WE SHOULD TRY.
TO DO WHAT WE CAN TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR THE CLIENTS AT ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT -- WE ALSO TO
WORK WITHIN THE CONSTRAINTS OF
THE FEDERAL SINCE WE DO GET A
LOT FEDERAL MONEY AND THEY DO
HAVE REQUIREMENTS SO --
SOMETIMES WE ARE CONSTRAINED BY --
BY THOSE BUT TO THE DEGREE THAT
WE CAN -- WE CERTAINLY WANT TO
MAKE.
THIS IS THAT THE SYSTEM IS IS
FRIENDLY AND WAS USER FROM ONLY
USER FRIENDLY BUT ALSO
FACILITATE PEOPLE GETTING THE
BENEFITS THAT -- THAT -- DATE
SERVE CELL PRESHEAF THAT MAYBE
WE CAN FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN GO
ABOUT DOING THAT.
OKAY SO WITH THAT THEN -- WE
WILL HOLD OPEN -- SHE WANTS TO
SET A REVIEW IT'S ISSUE
[inaudible]
TO AS UPDATE.
SO IT'S IT'S REALLY ISSUE FOUR
AND FIVE OR TO TO ACTUAL BUDGET
ITEMS WILL HOLD BOTH OF THOSE
OPEN.
NOW WE HAVE THE PARM SOCIAL
SERVICE STATE HEARINGS DIVISION
AND WE JUST SEVEN THE C. P. FOR
THAT AND I THINK.
FOR AND SINCE THIS IS ANOTHER
MAJOR SECTIONAL GO AROUND THE
TABLE AND ESTABLISH FOR THE
RECORD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MR
CHECKED -- CALORIE ACTING
DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
TRYING TO MAKE SURE I GET THE
MICROPHONE GOING CORRECTLY MY
NAME IS MONUMENTAL AND I AM THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR AND CHIEF
MINISTER LAW JUDGE -- FOR THE
STATE HEARINGS DIVISION OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND I'M HERE TO PROVIDE
A OVERVIEW OF THE P. C. P. -- I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES THAT
WE GET READY TO DO THAT AROUND
THERE OKAY OKAY ELIA SO EXCITED
CARRILLO.
JANIE BELL ALEJO AND IT'S TIGER
WOODS FINANCE.
RENDON HANSARD DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY OKAY WE'RE JUST WE'RE
JUST ESTABLISHING WHO'S AT THE
TABLE SELF ALL RIGHT PLEASE
AGAIN WELCOME.
OKAY I WANT TO THANK MY PARTNERS
FOR MORE SCI. FOR SHARING WITH
YOU ALREADY -- BUT THAT COAT
TODAY WE'RE HERE TO ASK FOR
RESOURCES TO ENSURE THAT THE
SUCCESSFUL.
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
WE HAD ON SEPTEMBER SEVENTEENTH
OF OF LAST YEAR AND CAN NOW MOVE
FORWARD WITH ENSURING THAT -- WE
HAVE THE OF OUR TECHNICAL
RESOURCES IN OUR INFORMATION
SERVICES DIVISION TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE GO
FORWARD AND ADDRESS ISSUES AS A
AS THEY COME UP.
AND THAT -- THESE RESOURCES THAT
WE ARE REQUESTING -- WILL BE
ABLE TO DO THAT FOR PARTICULARLY
ARE TIER ONE AND TIER TWO LEVEL
SUPPORT.
UP TO THREE SUPPORTERS COSTS TO
THE VENDOR -- THIS IS A CLASS
PRODUCT.
AND SO WE STILL WILL NEED TO
MAINTAIN A RELATIONSHIP.
WITH THE VENDOR THAT OWNS OF THE
PRODUCT FOR THOSE -- TECHNICAL
SUPPORT PIECES THAT -- WE DON'T
HAVE -- THE LEGAL AUTHORITY TO
BE ABLE TO DO OURSELVES -- BUT
IN SHORT A DOES THAT'S THE OF
THE BCP PROPOSAL IN NOW.
OPEN FOR QUESTIONS.
THE ONLY THING I WANTED TO ADD
MISTER CHAIR IS THAT THIS IS THE
PROJECT THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER IN THE HEARING THAT WAS
DELIVERED ON TIME AND ON FUND
BUDGET -- BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
REALLY HAS TRANSFORMED -- THE
THE INTERFACE OF THE USE FOR
CLIENTS AS WE WERE TALKING THE
IN THE LAST -- ISSUE ABOUT SAW
IS.
THIS REALLY A ALLOWS FOR THE
VERY FIRST TIME CLIENTS TO
ACCESS THEIR OWN CASE AND TO GET
THEIR OWN DATA AND TO ACTUALLY
BE ABLE TO DOWNLOAD INSTEAD OF
LITERALLY HAVING TO DRIVE TO A
COUNTY OFFICE TO PICK UP A CASE
FILE.
THEY CAN ACTUALLY ACCESS ALL OF
THAT INFORMATION ONLINE SO IT
REALLY HAS TRANSFORMED THAT AND
THIS IS ONE OF THE PROJECT SAID
AS YOU SAW THAT PORTFOLIO OF
ALWAYS SIGN ALL THE PROJECTS
THEY MANAGE.
THEY MANAGE THIS PROJECT WHILE
IT WAS BEING DEVELOPED IN
THROUGHOUT THE CONTRACT PROCESS
AND SAW THAT EVERYTHING YOU KNOW
OVERSIGHT THE ENTIRE DEVELOPMENT.
NOW THAT IT'S MOVING TO MEET ITS
OPERATIONS IT'S A SMALL PROJECT
IS MOVING BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT.
THAT SO WHAT THE RESOURCES ARE.
FOR EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT -- HELLO --
NO CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL A
FINANCE.
ALL RIGHT AND JUST CLARIFY THIS
IS -- FOR THREE POSITIONS AND
WELL THREE HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND OF WHICH HUNDRED FIFTY
ONE THOUSAND GENERAL FUND TRADE.
OKAY SO IS IS THIS SO IT'S THE
CLEAR RISES SAID THEM IS THAT
MONEY FOR A CONTRACT WITH THE
WITH THE VENDOR TO DO
MAINTENANCE OR ITS THREE BECAUSE
IT'S FOR THREE POSITIONS SO I
THOUGHT.
PROTECTION HOUSE THAT RIGHT OKAY
I WASN'T SURE FOR THE TESTIMONY
SO I COULD BUY.
OKAY -- ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS YES -- YES KEVIN AS THEY'RE
CALLED TO CALIFORNIA BEFORE ITS
ORGANIZATIONS.
ACMS IS ONE OF THE BEST SYSTEMS
THAT WE WORK WITH WE'VE BEEN
INVOLVED WITH A FROM A TO Z.
WHICH IS VERY UNIQUE AND LIKE
THE THE CALIFORNICA Là THE A
POSITION STATEMENT THAT IS.
DOWNLOADED.
I HAVE -- DOWNLOAD TO CONDITION
WOULD DRAW IT'S A VERY GOOD
SYSTEM AND WE SUPPORT TO PEACE
THE PEACE SIGN THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT OKAY SEEING NO OTHER
COMMENT -- WE WILL HOLD THIS
OPEN UNTIL AFTER MAY REVISED AND
I WANNA TAKE SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE AND PRESENTING THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT BYE THANK -- ONE THINK
AT ALL ALL THE PRESENTERS TO
HEAR AND ONE THINK OF THAT THE
LA -- AND FINANCE A AS WELL
THREE SUPPORT AND ALSO I THINK
FIVE TECHNOLOGY YOU I KNOW THAT
WE INVITE YOU TO BE HERE.
YOUR AND CUT -- AS WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE SYSTEMS AND SO
I KNOW YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE HERE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE
GIVING US HERE.
YOUR THOUGHTS AND YOUR WORK ALSO
WITH THAT THE AGENCIES THAT --
THAT WERE BURIED HERE FOR THE
HEARINGS THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
AND WITH THAT -- THIS CONCLUDES
THE AGENDA FOR THIS HEARING OF
THE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE ON
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES THIS
HEARING IS NOW ADJOURNED